foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this year saw the return of the pro
chess league and thank goodness chat so
good to have you back PCL the St Louis
Archbishop returning to the pro chess
League playoffs let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh one
hundred thousand dollars up for grass
the quarterfinals of the pro chess
League playoffs have finally arrived
we win oh my God the PCL is here to stay
who will be crowned its next champion
hello everyone and welcome we are back
after a long wait with the protest
League playoffs to Crown the best team
of season 2023 we saw immense amazing
action in the first five weeks and I
can't wait Daniel for all that's coming
up by the way I'm International Day with
the prophet Grandmaster
Daniel how excited are you for this one
week of chess I was getting scared that
time you didn't know how to refer to you
well Tanya it's it's an honor to be
covering the PCL I can't believe we're
here again it's playoff time there are
no mistakes allowed one strike and you
are out seat belts fastened and
mandatory cannot wait to jump in oh my
God every match so much on the line
single Elimination Brackets and we
started with 16 teams in the protest
League we are down to eight it has been
the end of the road for eight teams
after the five week regular season
action that we saw we saw ups and downs
twists and turns they were brilliant
tears they were big upset and finally
eight teams were eliminated now in the
playoffs there is a big price fund of a
hundred thousand dollars that the
players are fighting for but apart from
the money it is about the glory it is
about the bragging rights of becoming
the pro chess League champion of winning
the most entertaining the most
competitive online chess League Daniel
it most certainly is Tanya obviously the
prizes are generous and that matters but
I think that the honor uh and the the
willingness to not disappoint the top
guys on your team so many super Grand
Masters competing in the PCL this season
to lend it that magic quality I think
that really is what takes this to the
next level in terms of the way that each
and every team player is treating
particularly these playoffs Tanya it's
no different from a very serious
over-the-board tournament everybody
wants to win and everybody wants to win
really badly
absolutely that's exactly the kind of
Fighting Chess that we've been seeing
and that we love to see we will also be
revealing the most valued players on the
teams on Sunday and they will be winning
a prize of five thousand dollars so
definitely a lot on the line here and
these are our eight teams the brackets
for the quarter finals we will be
starting today with the Shanghai Tigers
taking on the Norway gnomes and later on
we've got the age-old debate with the
Knights versus Bishop well at least it
will be settled today for the protestly
or the night stronger are the Bishops
man two incredible matches today Tanya
and what's awesome you'll delve into
this uh momentarily the fact that each
team has taken a uniquely a distinct
road to the playoffs but that's the
great thing about the playoffs in any
sport the Slate is wiped clean so you
can forget about the matches you've
already played it's zero zero the game
starts Anew and man these matches today
you don't want to do anything productive
you won't be doing anything productive
because you'll be pegged to the screen
uh speaking of the road to the playoffs
Indian Yogi is there who will be playing
their quarterfinals against Blitz the
yogis had a phenomenal performance in
the regular season they won all their
three matches back to back were the
first team to punch their tickets into
the playoffs but they've got a tough
task ahead of them they're playing
against Blitz which features two former
world champions embryo and grishek
yeah is there anybody good playing Tanya
can you name the actual interesting
players that we'll be watching today no
I mean the yogis the yogis were a
machine in the regular season obviously
the archbishops that could not have been
an opposite road to the playoffs they
were oh and two they were staring down
the barrel of elimination when you when
you've got people like Fabia on your
team you can be sure uh that they are
not going to go gentle into that good
night but it's the playoffs you cannot
lose a single match because you are out
the atmosphere in the air it's just a
little bit different
we do have that big matchup coming out
later today with the Bishops taking on
the night we will see Fabiano caruana
heading his team and Hikaru heading his
that's gonna be a big one but we've got
another big one that we start with with
the Shanghai tigers and the Norway
gnomes now these two teams they won
three matches they lost one in the
regular season to punch their tickets in
week four for the playoffs and these
this is the squad now with a single
elimination match there is so much
pressure on the teams to really put
their best players on to bring in those
points the first team to score eight
points will go will go into this eight
and a half points will go into the
semi-finals and look at that Daniel
we've got Wei one of the biggest
strategies in the history of Chess
heading the team and of course a big
pillar for Norway gnomes Pavel alienov
man we've got some amazing players
obviously the Women's World Champion Jew
and June and we've got a mixture of
Youth and experience particularly on the
right side on the Norway side we've got
Pavel Eliana who has decades-long
experience at the very top level of peak
feed a rating over 27.60 and Incredibly
exciting young players pernav uh needs
absolutely no introduction to anybody
who's watched online chess or twitch
streams really for more than a week uh
and obviously elham abdul-rauf ignore
that I am in front of his name because
he is more than Grandmaster strength man
oh man we have some exciting lineups
it's gonna be super fun and pranav is
the 75th Grand Master from India he is
just 16 years old and as you mentioned
in online during the pandemic he just
really took to Blitz I was seeing Daniel
that pranav has actually played over 3
000 games against Oman Hamilton alone
and he is such a bullet Beast he loves
this format he's a speech test
specialist super excited about that one
but the one thing that stands out to me
is this big risk this big gamble that
Norway gnomes has taken now you
mentioned International Master alham
Abdul Ralph he makes his season debut
today he hasn't played in the protest
League this season at all is that too
much risk with all on the line
I don't think so I think it's an
incredibly bold decision uh Bayou
Ludovic hammer and the Norway gnome's
leadership team yes elham will feel
those Jitters but everybody feels those
Shooters they know that there are
thousands of players watching fans
across the world no matter how many PCL
matches you've played you're gonna feel
those butterflies in your stomach to
start the match but elham is such an
exciting player to watch I've played
hundreds of Blitz Games with him I've
watched him seemingly get better Tanya
by the day he also has some incredibly
exciting opening preparation to bring to
the table and he's gonna be hungry he's
going to be hungry to prove that yes it
might be my first match but I am here to
stay and I'm here for a very good reason
only time will tell we're about to find
out in the next couple of hours but
preliminarily I like that decision
wow super exciting stuff there by Norway
gnomes elham Abdul RAF is definitely an
exciting emerging Talent from Norway and
even though he's an international Master
he's got a grand master rating there
crossing over 2500 and this is a round
one pairing now this is the most uneven
round of the day it starts with board
one taking on board four we see where he
will be playing Nino Bata Billy while
Pavel Alano will be playing board four
of the Shanghai Tigers Daniel this is
also the round where we've traditionally
seen so many upsets what are you
expecting from this one
and you're not just saying that either
we actually have seen board fours defeat
board one for some reason this reminds
me of round one of the Qatar Masters I
think in 2016 when Nino betsyashili made
a draw uh against an obscure chess
player known as Magnus Carlson she's got
the white pieces against Wei Yi and uh
she's a very solid player so this is by
no means Tanya a a walkover or Pavel
Eliana and for away and or it's two and
three they're actually pretty evenly
matched so it's impossible to predict
how round one is going to kick off but
it's so important to get off to a good
start particularly if you are away uh
and Pavel Eliana and you lead your teams
a hundred percent Daniel and we've seen
the women players they matter so much on
the team but not this player he is an
absolute Phenom in the Chess World he's
the he crossed the 2700 barrier when he
was only 15 years old where he from
China he broke Magnus Carlton's record
as the youngest player to ever get to 20
700 became a grand master at 13. he
needs to deliver today for his team
starting from the top at the top table
Board number one way for the Shanghai
tigers and we see they're ready to go
Nino about she's a multiple time
Georgian woman Champion has won so many
medals for her team at the Olympiad it's
going to be a difficult fight and we've
seen big upsets Daniel what are you
expecting from this one
man I mean we've got two very solid
teams I think this is going to be a
close one uh but the first round it
doesn't necessarily decide the match
we've also seen teams get off to a very
sluggish start you know 3-1 even three
and a half but you need eight and a half
points to advance it's not enough to put
in one strong round and I think we're
gonna see solid play Tanya by uh Wei and
Nino but Sia I think they're gonna get
into long games they're gonna bring
their a game in terms of their opening
preparation so that's been a very
exciting phenomenon in the protest
league as well most of these players
like I said they treat this like a
serious opening uh like a serious
tournament they bring serious openings
to the table
you say we're gonna see a solid game I'm
gonna push back in this I think this is
gonna be a wild one where he is one of
the best attackers in the business we've
seen the kind of creativity and the
Tactical sharpness that came against
Dominguez from the earlier season where
he bought Israel with the black pieces
all the way to H1 his Immortal against
Bruce on but there's that I don't know
it's gonna be fire on the boat Daniel I
remember that game when it was I was
actually thinking about that game as you
were talking but right now we're going
to be thinking about this game that's in
front of you right now with Nina but
Seeley The Grandmaster from Georgia
handling the white pieces tap board from
Shanghai with black D4 G6 all right Tony
you're right my comments already have
not aged very well but he very clearly
showing that he ain't in it for a
Queen's Gambit declined or something
solid he wants a nice little King's
Indian
yeah and you say that because when black
plays G6 Bishop G7 you know that they
are going for blood they want a fight in
the middle game and Daniel this is an
opening that I know you love seeing on
the board with the black thesis
absolutely now ways developing is not
developing the night the king's night
just yet Tanya which could mean
absolutely nothing he could play Knight
F6 and transpose to a uh classic King's
Indian here but no he's playing a
slightly more obscure version I would
still call this a king's Indian type
opening immediately attacking the D4
pawn and oftentimes this is followed up
with the e75 when uh the king's Knight
can actually develop Tanya to E7 and you
can quickly try to push F7 F5 it's a
dubious setup and you still can play a
king's Indian right now with Knight F6
but I think Wei is trying to get
something relatively non-theoretical to
start the game they call you a prophet
for a reason as you pointed out the
Knight doesn't come out to F6 he does
strike in the center with E5 another big
question is that will blackhead with
that Knight on C6 all the way to D4 is
he going to take that big decision and
plant the Knight there or will he
Retreat and of course F5 is always in
the air far away he has made his
intentions clear from the very start in
this one he wants to keep the pieces on
the board after Knight D4 perhaps Nino
could have offered a night exchanges
developing her own night but with Knight
E7 we know that move F5 is going to
arrive before the other Knight develops
to F6
this is definitely a dubious setup from
an objective standpoint but the engine
often over evaluates White's position in
most King's Indian structures and I'm
not just saying that because I'm a
king's Indian fan but I love the way
that nino has responded in an early C4
C5 this is exactly what white wants to
do you don't want to wait around Tanya
for black to start attacking on the king
side you want to take it to Black on the
other side of the board and you know
very accurate to start this game C5 is
on the board
oh my God I love it and she she barely
took a minute to make this big decision
and where he now slows down I don't know
who's playing for an advantage look at
what we've got we've got four pawns at
the center of the board that pawn
structure you don't get to see so early
on why does targeting blacks D6 Pawn
black is targeting White Center on e4
this is already a mess told you Daniel
no solid play in this one
and now the ball back in Nino's court
she can solidify the E4 Pawn with F3 she
can do it now as well but she starts by
delivering a check on B5 and because the
center is relatively closed uh generally
in Kings Indian structures you want to
preserve the light squared Bishop so I
would not be surprised uh if y e shifts
the king over to fa this would be
congruent with uh the type of plate that
he's been displaying thus far in this
game of course you could also cover with
the bishop but then later on in the game
time it will be much harder for black to
attack on the king side still I like the
way that Nino's handling the opening I
think white is better
wow yeah there is so much going on here
as you mentioned the bishop will block
but if we he's on fire he just moves his
King to F7 I can imagine White's Knight
arriving on G5 with a check now King F7
would feel like it's a mouse slip kind
of a move what is going on in this
opening immediately Nino does Target the
G5 Square A6 had to be played Daniel a
very important call that you can't allow
white snipe to step in with the check on
G5 and then potentially on to E6 that
would be a devastating idea and newer
Kings Indian players often allow this
and lose the game uh on the spot again
you want to preserve your light squared
Bishop now Way's next move is very
obvious he will finally finally develop
the king's Knight Knight F6 will be on
the board and Nino has to figure out how
she's going to support the E4 Pawn that
was the downside of developing the
Knight to F3 Tanya and it's very easy to
blunder and drop the Knight back to do
two let's support this Pawn a little bit
uh how about Let's Lose the bishop after
F4 so white has to avoid stepping on
some minefields here as as well and you
also don't normally want to play e takes
F5 and give up a further share of the
center
it's absolutely insane what we're seeing
in this game right now and while Nino
well I was gonna say Nino is about to
think she immediately takes a decision
to trade on F5 we will come back and
dive deeper into this action because
it's definitely fire on the board but
let's zoom out for a moment because
action is on on all the other games and
at the protest League every game matters
every board matters it is a theme event
and Daniel I look across it's clear that
that is the top left board where all the
fire all the action is but even
Vengeance against elham there's a lot
going on there as well White Queen on
effort a centralized Knight being under
pressure right now
mm-hmm let's go to that game that's the
top right of your screen the other two
games telling you pretty much calm
they're both uh in a scotch game so
definitely uh second in terms of fire on
board is elham's game I also mentioned
his opening preparation uh which is so
so dangerous particularly in shorter
time control so let's take a somewhat
deeper dive in the women's world
champion she has the bishop pair as she
chases elham's Knight out of the center
with F7 F6 I think the position is
probably balanced there's a high
probability of heavy piece trades on the
e-file but if you're Jew and June okay
maybe you do want to take anyone but you
don't want to give up the e-file uh
unless you figure out a very clear
follow-up maybe takes takes and then the
bishop could come out to D6 at the end
but there's some calculating to do here
for black
and you always have to take these
decisions right if you trade on C4 you
allow white to have a better Pawn
structure in the center that pawn from
the side of the board will go further on
to control Central squares you kind of
don't want to do that but if not what is
your waiting move white meanwhile seems
to have an easier play here even though
the position is pretty level white can
trade once on E8 and bring the other
Rook open to the e-file Bill wanjin
takes the decision to allow that herself
rookie one rookie one traded and she
falls back with the Knight to F7 and I'm
just wondering why what is going on here
because it's not very clear what is the
future of that night she wants to go D5
but that would block her own Bishop on
B7
yeah the Knight on F7 is not ideal I I
do think she wants to play D7 D5 chase
this Knight out of C4 and then bring her
dark squared Bishop out to D6 and if all
of that happens she can then support the
d-pawn with C7 C6 now if this happens
whitesnite on C3 is also going to
struggle to find decent accommodations
so elham can't Sleepwalk through this
moment uh one very interesting way to
unbalance the game is to actually push
his own Pawn to D5 to beat Black to the
punch Tanya and one might say well isn't
the D5 Pawn a weakness in that position
well it's both a weakness and a strength
Drew and June can bring her dark Squad
Bishop to B4 elham decides not to go for
it I think he might regret that decision
after Jew and June pushes D5 and then
brings her Queen out to D7 and her Rook
on E8 she's got the bishop pair she's
got the better Pawn structure so
positionally I think black is in really
good shape here oh and the prophet
strikes again D5 on the board Knight
falls back what alarm wants is perhaps
to put the Knight on G4 also watch out
for threats on F6 there is the G7 pin so
Knight G4 ideas are in the air it would
be a dream for white to plant that
Knight on F5 but currently not that easy
to get with the queen on D7 defending
that square so lots of good Dynamics
here and as you mentioned for wengen the
plan is clear you want to put that
Knight on D6 you want to try to get it
to E4 you want to place your Rook on E8
on that open file this game is pretty
level let's zoom out for a moment and
take a look at the other action because
look at that bottom left board I do see
a lot has happened there what is Black's
Knight doing on G4 ideas of Queen H4
threatening a mate in one on H2 comes in
and I see that the eval Bar says that
Zoo Yi is in driving seat it's clear
it's because of more space more central
control
and I definitely want to take a deeper
dive I'll quickly mention that top left
Nino and Wei are still in that
approximately same structure where we
left them with the pawns on E5 and uh F5
looks like a pretty good position for
shanghai's board once a Waze opening
Choice has worked out well but let's
look at buddy pranav as he is amicably
known in certain uh twitch chess circles
he has the black pieces a very Dynamic
opening repertoire uh this started out
as a four nights scotch and pronounced
kind of unbalancing the game not playing
D5 as is more standard but rather
keeping the pawn on D6 Tanya and I do
think that he is regretting uh his
decision as he tries to put more
pressure on White Center he shifts The
Rook over to E8 uh zhuyi could knock the
Knight off with H3 I think it's also
important not to dismiss the value of
this Knight on A4 Knights on the rim or
Grim yeah but only sometimes because
it's completely restricting the mobility
of this bishop taking the sting out of
what would have been a very strong check
on B6 but now how is white going to
protect the pawn Tanya
that's a big question blackbirds brush
on the Central Pawn you want to take out
your pieces I was going to say bring
that Queen to F3 and Julie does it does
defend that E4 pawn and really nicely
pointed out that that Knight on A4 which
initially looks like an eyesore is
actually doing a brilliant job of
dominating that Bishop on A5 making sure
that it doesn't come onto that strong
diagonal black can continue targeting
the central pawns with doubling up on
the e-file first guards the C6 Pawn also
eyeing the move C5 we've been talking
about that Knight on A4 you know what
Daniel it doesn't have too many squares
to retreat to C5 is a threat on the
board
it most certainly is and you definitely
don't want to play B3 in that position
then C3 is weak and I think Julie has to
get going on the queen side and play
b2b4 Kick the bishop away forcibly to B6
trade Knight for Bishop get the bishop
pair and the other benefit of B4 Tanya
while it may appear to weaken the C pawn
it also creates a fin keto post for the
dark squared Bishop so the ideal setup
for white would be to bring the bishop
to B2 then push the C Pawn up to C4 when
the Bishops are both going to be staring
at the king side eventually I think he
wants to push E5 and just shatter a
Black's King Side open up the file his
pieces are in very good attacking
position but it's important not to miss
this moment if you're shoyi maybe in
response to B4 black it's still play C5
and counter attack the Knight so I think
that might be one thing uh that shuyi is
is calculating here oh that's a big mess
B4 C5 you might see that on the board
right now Julie has slowed down so we're
gonna take this moment to go to the
messiest position that we have in this
round because that action is absolutely
insane uh Daniel it is the top right
board now we see the eval Bar says that
on all boards it is pretty level but the
positions are anything but equal and I
think we have to jump into rayy against
Nino and look at those Central pawns
marching down the board Unstoppable upon
has arrived on F3 black is threatening
to come in with that Knight on H4 to
really put the pressure on the G2 Pawn
how dangerous is this for Nino very
dangerous man this game could not be in
more stark contrast to the board one of
uh the Norway gnomes probably Yana who
has a completely normal equal position
and we'll get to it eventually but this
is the place to be right now Waze
opening strategy Tanya has worked to
Perfection you know really hasn't gotten
off the ground on the queen side I liked
her early decision to play 5 but she
hasn't managed to assemble any pieces to
exploit that open open C file she just
hasn't had the time to play Rook ac1 and
Knight B5 way he most certainly has had
the time to start shattering White's
King side right now the epon is hanging
way he defends it with Rook 88 he's also
got a big time Advantage he's
threatening Knight F5 to H4 and it's so
easy to get checkmated here or White and
the other problem Tanya is that black
isn't even down material so what you
very well could trade Queens here and
continue attacking even with the ladies
off the board he could chase the night
away with A6 Knight F5 to H4 could
appear anywhere and it could be just as
dangerous with the Queen's off as with
them on
yeah and it's such a human move right to
play Queen B5 you feel the pressure on
the king side you want the Queens traded
off but we see where he he's just
blitzing out the moves keeps his
Advantage as you said it is a queenless
position but black keeps all the Trump
if white actually recaptures on G2 that
will be great news for black you can
start with the activity on the G file
bring in that Rook to T8 the knight from
F6 once that starts hopping around
Knight D7 Knight C5 the B2 Pawn is weak
the bishop and G7 will be an absolute
monster the Black Knight jumping onto H4
Daniel it feels like a position where
we're seeing all the trumps for black
but White's play is hard to see also I
want to point out one more threat the D5
Pawn The Rook can come into E5 hitting
that pawn and where he immediately
captures it with Knight D5 and that's an
extra Pawn a healthy extra yeah he
captures it straight away and white just
has no answer to that move then I don't
have five cannot be chased away that
would be the only tactical flaw in
Black's position right the possibility
of a fork that's a pipe dream at this
point you don't have a Jeep on to push
to G4 it's been captured now capturing
on A7 tongue I don't even want to
analyze that there's no way in a million
years that white would get away with
that move you know but it's not dead
lost here she's got some active pieces
and I really like her last move Rook 81
maintaining her composure trying uh to
set up some sort of Discovery with
Bishop takes H6 perhaps but uh with that
extra time on his clock I think when he
is going to drive this point home he
could bring his Rook up to E6 and
reinforce uh the D6 Pawn so that when
his Knight moves out of D5 uh White
would not be able to gang up on that
pawn with her Knight and Rook so a lot
of options here orwayi he starts with
rookie great called by you and he
keeps the attack going on the king side
uh Nino has to bring her King back to H1
now and perhaps where you could also
centralize his Bishop uh in uh on E5
although he has to be careful not to
blunder away the C4 Pawn
and King H1 on the board now White's
Knight can get to G4 and start
activating so I won't be surprised if we
also decides to slow down a little bit
push that H Pawn taking away the
activity and then your ideas of putting
pressure on that h29 at a good moment to
move Bishop E5 B2 Pawn is hanging
everything becomes very difficult for
white hair and we see A6 a very natural
human move there by way you're just
pushing the Knight but the eval bar
doesn't approve of it
so of course white isn't obliged to move
this night Nino realizes this that's why
she's taking almost all of her remaining
time she could still move this bishop
and she plays Bishops he won the best
move and she has a new lease on life
because if black takes Tanya white
recaptures on D5 and those weaknesses
that we were talking about they were
shielded by this night when this Knight
disappears I don't have five hangs Pawn
on B5 hangs Pawn on e4 potentially hangs
and Nino is still very much in this game
fantastic
defensefield with Bishop C1 that was
clearly overlooked by Wei this is an
amazing move and as you were pointing
out weaknesses let's point out one more
weakness the D6 spawn if black actually
steps back with that Knight anywhere
white can simply swap up that pawn on D6
Knight D6 The Rook gets super active and
it does look like Nino indeed is back in
the game and we see she's got a minute
and a half on the clock but the first
time in the position she's the one who's
putting the threats on black Wiggy he
slows down a move a backward moves there
the hardest to find and it was
definitely missed what a great find by
Nino this was Bishop to C1 and it looks
like where he is not feeling uh as under
control as he was earlier
well because he can't just make a random
move in flag white right if he moves
this Knight white takes on D6 that end
game is very easy to play with a wide
open Center as you indicated white could
deploy the other night with G4 this
might be something that way you miss he
might have relied on Rook E8 to E5 here
but then white drops in uh to G4 with
the Knight and actually wins material
because then not only does The Rook hang
but the Knight will hang after that so
are you doing the right thing slowing
down and I don't think he should
catastrophize I think you should take on
B5 meet Rook takes D5 with something
like Rook E5 he might have to sacrifice
his Pawn back but I think his Superior
piece activity is still going to give
him a fair share of winning chances in
the end game but serious strong chances
here for the Georgian Grandmaster what a
big result that would be Tanya because
the other board seem to be holding it up
rather well for the Gnomes as well
it's gonna be super important for her to
keep her clock under control though
because the game will go on and even
though the worst is over you can trade
on E5 you can pick up that E4 Pawn as
well Rook takes E4 that was the other
weakness that we were looking at rookie
Five played she is considering the move
Knight G4 as well because you want to
get that Knight into the game before you
start swapping up at the E4 Pawn Knight
G4 is super tempting
yeah it is and white is going to
continue fighting here for a draw her
clock might be a big problem but we've
got some action on the other boards uh
in particular we have interesting stuff
going on on the Norway gnomes board one
pile of lyanov locked in a very very
tense battle Tanya what catches your eye
here look at the top right the eval bar
on the top right in bed
is my I
we bought we
win driving seat and it looks like
wengen on that top right board is in
driving seat with a bishop bear in the
position a long-term advantage that end
game she's going to push for a win in
the bottom left board it is again the
Shanghai Tigers who are in the driving
seat against pranav zuyi with a big
Advantage whereas blacks play White's
the one again with the bishop bear
pushing for in that Central space but
that bottom right board is where Pavel
needs to strike for the Norway gnomes he
does indeed and you're absolutely right
this looks like a technically winning
position for the Women's World Champion
she's playing this very confidently
Pablo eliano if he has to strike we're
gonna go to his game and see how he's
doing I thought that he was better a
little bit earlier Tanya because I
looked at this Pawn it's a protected
password guess what the Knight is
considered the best blockader it is
completely immobilizing that pawn it's
also immobilizing Black's Queen which
does not have access to iwan and
Visually look at the activity of White's
piece tandem the queen I8 locking up
Black's minor pieces the bishop can drop
back to B5 black has weaknesses on the
King on the queen side this is tough for
Pavel who's also down two minutes on the
clock
but often you need time for that Bishop
to get active you first need to sidestep
the pin with the move like King 87 then
you've got to move the Knight away and
only then can you start getting the
bishop into play we've been talking
about this being the board where Norway
gnomes needs to strike but I think Pavel
right now given the position will be
happy if he survives with the draw here
yeah and in order to survive of the drug
he might have to solve his problems
tactically by sliding his Queen up to E2
that leads to some very interesting
tactical play uh if we could bring uh a
quick analysis board up after Queen E2
this is undoubtedly what Pavel is
calculating white could respond with
Bishop to B5 counter-attacking the
Knight now if you take the Knight on D3
white wins with Bishop takes D7 and you
lose the bishop so in that position
after Bishop B5 black has to play the
com Knight F6 which leads potentially to
some sort of a Perpetual I think people
can follow and understand something like
Queen E1 and queen E5 with a move
repetition is not unlikely and would be
a great result for the Shanghai tigers
and queen E2 is on the board as we go
back to the live board plenty of time
here for white to figure out Bishop B5
and he's playing
it doesn't help the Norway no
you know it's been a big turnaround on
the top boardy versus Nino if you just
get our bird's eye view we left that
game thinking that nino solved all her
problems and will be fighting for a draw
here but a lot has happened and Daniel
once again look at those pieces on the
top left that we see upon on E3 a solid
past Pawn the king is just marching down
the board this is just game over
we can go to that game and watch the
last couple of moves because this is
about to be zero one and Nino with a
Herculean defensive effort but she just
had too little time right there was
still a lot of problems left to solve
Wei just has to make a couple more
accurate moves his time management is
incredible he always seems to have the
right amount of time to figure out those
moves okay Knight H4 he's got made
threats Galore with Knight F3 so I would
probably go King T3 Nino's last hope is
to keep delivering those back checks to
the king but the king can seek shelter
on the H file which well but Tanya King
G3 maybe bishop can drop back to E1 and
you can force a rook end game so still a
little bit of you know a few teas left
to cross for away here okay but now it's
over yeah he's just gonna pick up the H3
Pawn the king is absolutely safe there
E2 coming in Knight F3 check coming in
which is going to be Checkmate if avoid
isn't careful and that is it with
seconds on the clock Nino resigned this
is game over it is one point to the
Shanghai Tigers let's bring up our
bird's eye view because it doesn't look
like it's going to be the only point for
the Shanghai Tigers top right board two
Vengeance still in a dominating end game
the king is more advanced a bishop pair
that D4 Pawn is already a pass Pawn
white spawn structure is the weak one is
that going to be a point for Shanghai
tigers
I think it is five seconds also for
elham and Jun declining a drug a little
bit earlier let's go to that game
because the chain the Norway gnomes need
a miracle they're not going to get one
elham is unfortunately going to lose his
first PCL game he's dropping all of his
pieces here King takes F4 just happened
and When the Smoke Clears after
something like Bishop E5 white can
simply resign Tanya because yes material
is technically equal but it's not going
to be for very long it's all about the
king activity here Black's King is just
gonna mop up all of White's pawns this
is like target practice all you can eat
buffet here in this bishop end game
look at that black king
the strongest PC are going to snap up
all those white pawns as you're pointing
out now you've got the a parcel that can
March down the board at the right time
King D4 Once Upon goes to C5 you can
start targeting the bishop on B4 step
with the King to C4 this looks like it's
gonna be a tough one you can see alham
on the screen he's almost giving up
right now playing on seconds but it's
not about the clock the position is
busted for white
yeah he's got the Michaela moroney not
impressed face you and June is going to
follow up with Bishop D4 check pick off
the C5 Pawn there's nothing left to play
for and alham lets his clock run out yet
another victory for Shanghai with the
black pieces huge result for Jew and
June we go back to the bird's eye view
now it's more important than ever for
Pablo Eliana to strike this could be a
disaster Tanya for uh Norway because
pranav is locked in a Time scramble he
has managed to turn things around though
so a little piece of good news for the
Norway gnomes I think pranav has serious
winning chances in his game as he stands
a pawn up and White's attack has
completely evaporated or not was the one
with a Time Advantage as well so let's
see if pranav can pull out a much needed
point for Norway Norway Norms needs to
win on both these boards to keep the
match equal this is the big fight with
just seconds on the clocks you pronoff
can start targeting White's clock as
well a very solid position it's clear
you compare the Bishops it is pronounced
Bishop on D3 that's the stronger Bishop
the pawn on e4 really ties on the White
Queen but is it going to be enough he's
going to start putting pressure on the
clock the only thing is I don't see a
break for black how does black break
into White's position here
I don't see one either and that's why
the email bar is so modestly positioned
Pavel by the way is also worse so he
really needs to win this game now black
has to be careful right if you play F5
to solidify this Pawn Tanya the bishop
could drop back to D4 and we talk about
this often opposite colored Bishop
middle games very different from end
games the side uh that has the attacking
chances has the advantage because you've
got an uncontested set of squares the
bishop on D3 looks very pretty but what
exactly is it still is it doing it's not
really participating in the attack
pranav trying to trade off the Rooks and
if white can trade the queens that
should be a drawable position also for
now down a minute himself yeah but the
draw will just not cut it for the Norway
gnomes that would mean around one
Victory two points lead there and we see
Pavel eliano if we just zoom out for a
moment and gets our get our bird's eye
view on we see the white cars all the
way up how many bonds is that the answer
is oh my God but it looks like a lot
it's about to be more though we gotta go
to that game Pavel is in Mortal Danger
he is dead lost in this end game against
yipping Lou he's just played Knight D7
to F6 trying to engineer some counter
play White is playing this perfectly
Queen E5 Queen traitanya is game over
with the spawn sitting on A5 Pavel he's
gotta go Queen B7 but then you start
dropping more pawns this is I don't want
to say this is over Pavel is a very
resilient Defender I don't see a move
for him look at the clock situation
bubble is down to 10 seconds on the
clock unbelievable enough time to try to
convert this game he's in driving seat
he's going to pick up another Pawn the
end game is a disaster keeping the
Queens on the board Knight C5 Also let's
point out the Knight on F6 isn't an
eternal pin we see that Pavel he's
shaking his head he knows it's gone
terribly wrong and can white start
targeting Knight D7 it's not just game
over on the science Bobble can resign
here and he will resign he'll let us
clock right now that's it it's 3-0 and
shanghai's board 4 has defeated Norris
board one a shock defeat suffered by
Pablo yanov now pranap has to win his
game and he will win his game so one
point will be scored by the Norway
gnomes pernav keeping them in the match
it would have been 4-0 potentially or
three and a half half as we go to that
game and watch the last couple of moves
man oh man is this a big result for
Shanghai nonetheless
absolutely that was a blowout game that
matched round that we just saw 3-1 and
it could have been different on this
board as well but pranav still keeping
the spirits alive keeping hope alive
yipping with the big upset the big upset
around one defeating the top Board of
the Norway gnomes and that means that
the Shanghai Tigers lead with 3-1 and
Daniel starting with that opening
getting the king to F7 that was some
phenomenal play by the Tigers
yeah great opening play really all
around June June had a good position out
of the opening even juyu who lost his
game against pranav he was much better
at one point so this easily easily could
have been 4-0 Tanya uh pranav as always
carrying things for the Norway gnomes
and keeping them in the match but 3-1
that's a big early score but as I
pointed out beforehand you need eight
and a half points so it's not this is
not nothing right this is a big big lead
given how solid they are but Norway
needs to avoid getting down on
themselves they've got three more rounds
uh to erase this deficit and get back in
this match
the first team to eight and a half wins
the match will go through to the
semi-finals the other team it will be
the end of the road what Norway gnomes
has to make sure is that this deficit
the two-point deficit the Shanghai
tigers do not break away with a bigger
margin it's already a huge margin going
into round two Norway gnomes has to
strike and these were the results that
we saw now for elham against Vengeance
engine was in driving seat regi as well
some great player there with the black
pieces very ambitious from the start but
it was yiping who was the star of the
round the MVP of round one for the
Shanghai Tigers defeating the top Board
of the Norway gnomes and defeating him
in positional style and Pavel alyanov's
own style this wasn't some fluke tactic
some blunder by Pavel he got outplayed
soundly from the opening Until the End
Game better time management by his
opponent and for elham Abdul rahoof it's
going to be so important not to get too
disappointed this was your first BCL
game right gotta calm down gotta tip
your hat to your opponent and play the
next game as well as you can I think
that's going to be the big X factors for
Norway Pavel yanov can he start to play
uh in the style that we're familiar with
and can helham score his first PCL
Victory Tanya but it's clear that
Norway's hands are full and they need a
big big round too
responsibility on
he scored a Solid 5 out of eight on the
top board for the Norway gnomes he's had
a disastrous start today losing round
one two the fourth Board of the Shanghai
Tigers but he needs to keep that behind
him he needs to start picking up the
points or this could end super badly for
Norway Norms you've got a big round to
coming up we'll be back after the shot
break
[Music]
we first thought that we had experienced
the chest bone that had washed Over Us
in 2019 at the end of 2018 kind of going
into 2019 we kind of looked at oh well
that was guys that was the chest boom
and oh we're a new level we compete it
was kind of then but then like literally
like covet happened we were ramping up
so quickly in each country that locked
down Italy India you could see the
registrations flying through as each
country locked down and it was all
happening so fast there was no like oh
this is so cool this was like oh my gosh
we're going to uh we literally couldn't
keep up and so there was no like
positive coolness out of this it wasn't
until like we were into the you know
pandemic and then like several months
and we're like oh wow this okay well
during the pandemic more people are
gonna play chess they will die back down
nope then came POG Champs and what Dean
talked about and we're like oh my gosh
then okay after that no okay and then
came Queen's gambiter like all right
well that was definitely the peak and
then the media started writing about
Chess and then okay where is it gonna
stop we have been yeah it's three you're
just gonna get away after wave after
wave and then there's the stuff in the
media now which is like wave and like we
almost can't even come up breath fast
enough to recognize this before there's
like another wave coming from this point
on we just don't know what to expect is
there another way of coming probably
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what just happened she takes it all
oh my Goshi is a magician what a devious
move Knight takes up six loses oh my
gosh this is just crazy level of
tactical Vision Way Yi is Unstoppable in
the Pro chess League let's check my
check my phone because he do Knight F2
check and you win the game by oh man
this is amazing I mean he had a plus day
on board four for the Shanghai tigers
foreign
Tigers has had a phenomenal performance
in round one and this could end up being
a one-sided match if Norway gnomes
doesn't pick up the pace in round two
look at the roster that Shanghai Tigers
has it is the strongest in this season
of the protest League an average rating
of over 2600 which has been capped with
the rules at 25.50 but we're leading the
50 the Phenom who broke the 2700 barrier
when he was just 15 became a grand
master at 13. three times women world
champion Jew version on board two and of
course exciting young talents in zui and
you Liu ping nihua who's actually the
trainer of juwin Jin is also in the
roster so many Grand Masters it's tough
to pick up a squad and right now it
looks like they've made all the right
decisions coming into this quarterfinals
with these four players they have played
in the first stage of the protest League
they've had the experience in this
format picked up each one of them has
picked up several points for the
Shanghai tigers and Daniel today in
round one that experience really showed
it absolutely did they've got such a
well-built roster Tanya and you know
these players in these rosters I think
what's amazing about the PCL is how the
how the requirements so nicely make the
teams evenly match so we've had a lot of
teams with similar average ratings but
that doesn't mean that they perform the
same in the Shanghai Tigers they have no
weaknesses they've got a great board for
as we just saw they've got an amazing
board one they've got a little bit of
everything
and that's what this is about right
having each of your boat bring in the
point you need to break in a point or
two on the bottom boards you need the
top boards to perform and of course for
the Norway gnomes it is time to shine
and bring on the fairy dust now alham
Abdul RAF who made his debut who's
making his debut in the protest league
has a tough start and it doesn't get
easier for him he will be playing
against Wiki in round two that's not an
opponent you want to face when you're
feeling shaky at all way with the white
pieces we saw what he did against Nino
with the black pieces are we expecting
another firefight on that one we are and
Tanya what a story that would be if
elham loses round one with white and
then at the very least pulls out a draw
with the black pieces against shanghai's
top board but it's so easy to get tilted
to get down on yourself uh you know I've
got no chance elham certainly has a
chance huge X Factor game and the second
one as I pointed out before round two is
Pavel El yanov can he strike back or the
Norway gnomes you need over 50 I think
that's been the biggest rule thus far in
the PCL your board one needs to score
two and a half out of four or more if
you want to have a serious chance
against a good team
a super Grand Master his speed creating
has been 27.65 that is just absolutely
insane he's been in the world top 10
Peak ranking of world number six but it
has been a tough start for him in round
one of the protest league and that's
what makes this format so fun and so
exciting that ratings are just a number
on the paper and absolutely no result
can be guaranteed we've seen big upsets
with a format of just the short time
control with a one game uh with a one
game format if anything can happen and
that's exactly what we saw in round one
but Pavel needs to come back he needs to
leave that behind him because he's
definitely the one who has to score
points for the Norway gnomes and also
for elham it's time to show why the team
decided to debut him today and for print
off he's got to keep his positive streak
going build on the momentum that he
acquired with his excellent first round
Victory with black but all of that uh
will be addressed in due time first of
all we've got a game underway it is way
Yi with the white pieces against elham
abdul-roven way not mincing his words a
sharp opening in round one and he starts
round two with one E4 his main opening
entertainment off by the Norwegian
phenom
I love it it doesn't matter where he is
white or black we know we're gonna have
an attacking tactical entertaining
battle an open Sicilian here and as you
mentioned the move A6 it controls the B5
Square stops any Knight jumps and
eventually black wants to take out the
bishop and see it on B7 that's what Elam
wants he wants to try to create counter
play on The Queen side you want to go B5
you want to put that Bishop on B7 and as
you're pointing out if weighi makes his
intentions clear with a potential Queen
side Castle move that Queen to D2 or to
F3 free up the way alongside Castle then
we'll know that this is going to be an
absolutely fun fight because
let's just face it Daniel when a 2700
plus player like Wei he goes alongside
Castle you know that you're up for an
attack absolutely and this is one of the
sharpest Lines within one of the
sharpest openings in chess and look at
how quickly they're blitzing out there
moves Queen F3 Tanya uh got popular
about 10 years ago it's been all the
rage ever since and uh the reputation of
this line has shifted back and forth
white introduced the novelty taimana was
kind of buried then black founder
responds to that right now I still think
Queen F3 is not considered to be a
refutation of the taemona but it is
still a very dangerous line and Knight
E5 to G6 apparently caught Way by
surprise don't be too surprised by the
movement of the h-bomb that's not tilt
that is standard Taman Affair to slow
down the progress of White's King side
pawns Wiggy has a vast Choice here he
can make a simple move like Bishop D3 or
King B1 but oftentimes you see white
sacrificing a pawn with something like
f2f4 even a night sacrifice with Knight
F5 or Knight T5 uh is not too uncommon
but good news thus far Tanya from the
Norway gnomes elham already has a
90-second Time advantage and he's still
well within his preparation
and we're when we're in a two-point
deficit this is exactly what you need
right whether you're playing white or
black you want a game on the board you
want to create a mess and the chaos to
try to pick up the points now that elham
has decided to March down the board with
the H Pawn a thematic idea one thing's
clear though Daniel that black sting
will not find safety on the king's side
and very often will just end up spending
a lot of time on the center of the board
meanwhile once again for elham it is
going to be about advancing that B Pawn
down with B5 developing the bishop to B7
trying to create play on The Queen side
it's going to be a race to each other's
King and this is going to get fun the
move Bishop D3 a developing move white
wants to get the H1 Rook to E1 and then
a potential sacrifice Knight D5 in the
air always absolutely this is going to
escalate in intensity but uh the match
as a whole will escalate because the
other games are getting underway so
let's go to the bird's eye view and
catch the start uh of el yanov against
Zhu Yi Ken Norway gnome's board third
one uh the experienced Ukrainian
Grandmaster strike back in a big way
he's got the white pieces let's not
mince words he really really needs to
win this game not in Pavel with the
white pieces is very very dangerous he
is an opening expert let's see what
zhuyi brings to the table we have a
oh I don't even want to say the name of
this opening Tanya I'll let you do that
honestly after the world championship I
think now this is an absolutely legit
way to play and this is going to be not
your traditional London I can see Daniel
you're enjoying this now oh yeah and
this is a well-known line this queen
takes me to variation uh it's been known
for several decades now uh Rook B1 sacks
the pawn on A2 black doesn't want to get
his Queen trapped though so the queen
steps back to A3 if I remember correctly
the best move here is Bishop F1 uh 2b5
you sacrifice the C5 Pawn as well and
this is more like a taemon of Sicilian
than like a London system white often
strikes with C4 but okay Tanya I think
Queen C3 is more popular so maybe this
move caught Pavel by a surprise
yeah this is an absolutely crazy opening
and it's clear that yui had this in mind
because you don't snap up that B2 Pawn
if you don't know what you're doing and
Pavel now slowing down he is down upon
but of course a lot of compensation but
it's all about timing here why it has to
keep the momentum going Bishop B5 makes
a lot of sense you want to go shot
Castle but then again are you willing to
give up another Pawn we will come back
to this while Pavel thinks about how he
wants to proceed let's go back let's
just zoom out for a moment get our
bird's eye view because we have a big
match up on that top right board as well
at the protest League every board comes
it is uh two engine taking on Nino Bata
shivili and we see there wenjen has got
reasons to be pleased with the opening
outcome a knight on E5 a bishop on G2
she loves these Catalan positions she
does indeed let's take a closer look at
the opening phase of that game a 95 was
indeed the last move of the game of
Catalan with the bishop coming out to A6
not uncommon I call this the hyperfian
keto the bishop here more active than it
is on B7 we rewind a couple of moves uh
Nino playing a very solid line uh Tanya
of the Catalan csap playing this almost
like a semi-slave then playing B6
deploying the bishop to A6 and it also
is very common for white to sacrifice
the C4 Pawn if you take it you have to
yield complete control of the center
these positions are very very dangerous
particularly in Rapid time control so
Nino playing this more modestly but
right now black has to be very careful
it's so easy to make a blunder Tanya
Knight bd7 whoops gave up the C6 pawn
another very common tactic if you play
Knight ft7 often times after the trade
on T5 white has tactics related to
Knight takes D5 sometimes even Knight F7
there are some crazy lines here Knight
ft7 on the board okay we might be seeing
this we've got to take a closer look at
this because Knight D7 is such a
thematic way of getting rid of that
Central Knight because you can't move
that B8 and I if you take on D5 and you
take on D5 Knight D5 and now you don't
have time to pick up the E5 Knight
because Knight E7 is a nice little
Intermezzo and then you just end up with
an extra pawn and The Rook is hanging on
it you have to take on D5 for that
reason and I think if white takes on D5
then this works out for Black Knight
takes C5 you take the rook and When the
Smoke Clears after Queen takes D4 black
has two pieces for a rook and white
doesn't really have anything all that
impressive but there is another
Intermezzo you can take on F7 here then
take on D5 you're currently two pieces
down but black has no way to defend the
rook and a I have no idea how to
evaluate this position the eval bar is
giving approximity quality in June June
she's taken on D5 and she took quite a
bit of time this is gonna get really
really exciting but but of course white
does not have to engage in this June
June can also make a solid move like
Bishop F4 and I think Nino I might be
smelling a rat here
time for Nino to actually first put an
Intermezzo an intermediate move of
picking up that Knight on E5 allowing
all these tactics on D5 just looks super
scary for black could end up down a
whole piece or a pawn really soon 95 I
feel is a move that keeps more it keeps
things more under control and Nino's
slowing down I think she's gonna pick up
the night before she picks up the D5
Pawn just so that the queen also defends
the D5 Pawn
I think that's a great call and you can
sense the wheels turning uh in the
Georgian Grandmaster said she she knows
this idea this is standard fare in the
Catalan she's trying to work out the
complications in response to Knight
takes E5 white can make an Intermezzo in
response to an Intermezzo and shove this
Pawn up to D6 that is a positional Pawn
sacrifice to clear up the D file but no
nino she says game on C takes D5 on the
board This Is The Moment of Truth boo
but I can't really blame Joe and June
she wants some more composition she just
says listen I've got the kind of
position I know perhaps better than my
opponent let's just keep the tension she
plays Rook do on a very reasonable
choice
that makes a lot of sense and always the
tactics of Knight D5 are in the air if
black was to capture an E5 it looks like
you're doubling up white spawn but after
95 D takes E5 The Rook on D1 is nicely
placed and white can advance the E2 Pawn
to E4 and really start targeting Black's
Central D5 so Knight E5 is a trade that
you're not too happy making but
meanwhile still Nino is struggling to
develop the pieces on the queen side
it's not going to be an easy decision
and even though you might not be happy
grabbing that Knight on E5 it might be
the way to go because there's so much
pressure on the center we'll wait and
see what Nino decides here let's zoom
out for a moment we've got action on on
all the other boards let's get our
bird's eye view up and the board that
catches my attention is that bottom
right board Lou yaping versus pranavi
this is the clash of the youngsters the
Young Generation and they both had first
round Victory so they're deaf definitely
high on that and it is a position that's
super fun ex they're going to be
sacrifices at some point on F6 and by
the way big blunder by ninobots really
we don't have to go back to that game
she has forgotten about Knight takes D5
so that's going to be an extra Pawn or
Jew and June who's on the first captured
on D5 already some bad news for the
Norway gnomes and so it is all the more
important for V pranav uh to cash in
this sharp Sicilian position but uh he's
got a big time deficit contrasted to the
previous round uh where he had a big
time Advantage so Louis ping showing
good knowledge of the Sicilian let's
take a quick look and see if pranav has
serious chances to develop attack on the
king side he's gone Bishop to G5 so
there are sacrifices in the air but the
more I look at this Tanya I was excited
at the semi-open f file and at the queen
on G3 but after something calm like
Bishop d8 to E7 and then Rook Ada I
really not that sure that pranav has
anything tangible on the king side
Knight G8 great defensive move saying I
want to take some pieces off the board
looks solid for the Chinese
International master
you want to try and get rid of those
dark Squad Bishop White's the one with
the more active bishop and that's why
pranav decides to fall back no trades
that it's there are we gonna see a rap
eruption and I would I would be very
surprised with that given the two point
deficit Prana with the white pieces I
think he's gonna play on We're not gonna
see the move Bishop G5 right now he has
to find a way to keep the game going but
yipping showing very resourceful plan
making his intentions clear that well if
this ends in a draw with the black
pieces that's an absolutely fine result
in a game
absolutely is Rook C8 comfortable
position for Louisa Peng but we have a
breaking news alert uh ladies and
gentlemen and it's not that the Golden
State Warriors are still in the NBA
Playoffs it is that Wei has sacrificed a
knight on the top board against elham
Abdullah let's take the bird's eye view
here for just a moment
um by a terrible position for Nino but
see Philly she is very likely going to
lose her game within a couple of moves
but Wei Tanya what on Earth is going on
the open e-file I'm calling a complete
Bluff here I think elham can get away
with this extra piece and consolidate I
don't know if Wei uh has done this out
of desperation I think he has let's take
a closer look I think elham can just get
the heck out of the center the Castle's
Queen side here tell me where White's
compensation is what am I missing now
where is the attack it's a full peace
sacrifice and it happened on with the
Knight moving to F5 to open up the
e-line and I don't know uh Daniel if we
can just back up yes this is the point
where he decided to go for this opening
up that East Central Line Knight F5 just
voluntarily giving up a night definitely
something that way you thought was
interesting as we were mentioning he's
one of the most creative player one of
the most attacking players in the
business he goes for this but it looks
like it's not enough but practically
it's still a lot of chances for white I
see the eval bar but that can be so
deceptive in this format black still has
to be careful absolutely and what he was
getting outplayed there so he tries to
change the course of the game now his
idea is this if black just takes on e4
that plays right into White's hands
Knight takes E4 hits the F6 Pawn Black's
Pawn structure is really bad right now
white only has a pawn for the minor
piece but if you get that second Pawn
then you can kind of play casually you
don't need to Checkmate black in order
to justify this sacrifice but elham
correctly Castle in Queen side now
Bishop B7 already on the board and if
Wei plays Knight E4 here this is just
not that impressive with Black's King in
relative safety elham for example could
claim some of the center with D5 and if
white takes on F6 not only is the Knight
very loose but black could pick up the
pawn on F2 drop the bishop back chase
the Knight away there is no question in
my mind that elham is borderline winning
objectively but he has to be feeling
really nervous he knows that he has a
big chance for Redemption and it's so so
important to keep your composure we know
how good every Super Grand Master is at
making something out of nothing D5
Knight F6 is on the board
Greg called that Donald you've literally
just called out the whole game as we
were seeing it's being played at Knight
F6 played everything is under control
black has an extra piece but when you're
playing a player like Wei you know he's
gonna try and make it messy he will
create his chances but of course right
now it looks like elham who's making his
debut today is almost about to beat the
top seed the top Board of the Shanghai
Tigers but there's work to be done the
good news for elham right now is that he
also has about four minutes on the clock
but he's struggling a little bit to find
the next move Knight F6 played if you
give white one more move you want to go
Queen to F3 you want to start targeting
the D5 pawn and build some play on it he
doesn't immediately pick up the F2 Pawn
because that does leave a few pieces a
bit loose and that's kind of
understandable I like the move Rook D6
that you're pointing out just hitting
that knight kicking it out of F6 but
this happens so often when you're
playing top players I've had this
experience against the car you know
you're winning and then you start
overthinking you're like I really want
to find the accurate move I don't want
to give my opponent chances before you
know it you've got one minute on the
clock uh but elham his Blitz skill is
going to come in handy he takes on F2
this is Flawless play right now by elham
but he has a lot of work to do the good
news for Wei the one minor piece of good
news that Black's King is going to be
weak and loose for really the rest of
the game so as long as we can keep some
pieces on the board I like your
suggestion of Queen F3 he's going to
have some tactical chances the Knight
can repurpose itself it can go back to
G4 and then toward E5 so let's not
pretend that this game is over this game
uh is in many ways just getting started
elham has to show some excellent
technique to take away you down but what
a huge result Tanya this would be
this is amazing stuff and Ella I'm
looking super confident I don't know if
you saw but he did a little dance there
a little bobbing of his head he knows
that this is so close and this would be
a massive result for the Norway gnomes
and for elham Abdul Ralph playing
against where you Queen F3 on the board
now the one move that comes to my mind
for black is you want to block out that
diagonal the move Queen to C6 you defend
the D5 Pawn you hit that Knight on F6
you keep things under control and you
block this H1 to A8 threats that the
queen on F3 is creating but elham has
slowed down a little bit the one thing
Daniel he needs to be careful about is
to keep the clock under control he goes
Rook 86 also a nice move the eval bar
approves as long as you're hitting the
Knight Knight takes D5 I think is a bad
idea because of all the pins Queen C6
would be a deadly move Rook D1 Knight G4
I I agree completely Knight two four is
going to happen this game is going to go
on it's stabilized let's go back to the
bird's eye view there because we're
about to have a result uh as we expected
June June is smoothly converting her
extra Pawn against Chevy we don't even
have to go to that game because it's
totally decided that pawn on E6 is going
to end the game momentarily she's going
to take on F7 the eval bar all the way
up so an early Point going to be scored
here by the Shanghai Tigers but given
elham's position it's really not the end
of the world I'm also looking at Pavel
eliana's position against Julie this
might end up being the X Factor game in
this round and the Ukrainian GM the top
board for the Gnomes is once again in a
good deal of trouble this is just a flat
out bad position he's got nothing going
on the queen side other than a ruined
Pawn structure wow this is absolutely
surprising I'm still trying to take this
position in so if we just do a quick
count because it's kind of hard to do
that when you've got this kind of a pawn
structure it's not as easy as it looks
but the actually it's even material the
material is absolutely even but as you
pointed out it is the pawn structure on
the queen side destroyed right now that
Rook on B6 is shaky can be attacked with
a fallback off the bishop to d8 you can
just kick it out of there Black's got a
long-term advantage of not just the
weakness in White's camp with the pawns
but also a double Bishop pair which will
count for something and it looks like
Pavel eliano is once again in trouble in
this one comes back he's inviting a
repetition here oh I love psychological
trickery by the Chinese Grandmaster in
an OTB classical game I think he would
play Bishop d8 to C7 without thinking
but why is he repeating moves first of
all he might not engage in the
repetition we're about to find out oh my
God
what do you think Tanya is he going to
repeat because Pavel really doesn't have
much of a choice for Pavel to play for a
win here would be Brazen he has to play
this objectively and that's it Julie
decides Hey listen we're up two points
this is the top board we're talking
about I'm gonna take a draw it depends
on how the other games go but I think
it's a pretty reasonable decision
actually yeah it's a great result for
the Shanghai Tigers they're both four
and that bought three with a one and a
half out of two against the board one of
the Norway gnomes definitely something
with the black pieces that you can be
happy about but the action is strong and
on especially if you see the top half
now where he is completely he is
he's actually just losing he's down a
piece and elham needs to win that or
meanwhile top right board to engine the
woman world champion she's on fire that
pawn on F7 uh it looks like well you're
up in exchange you've got all the
compensation on the board that's over so
that's going to be a one one to these
team it comes down to pranav's board it
comes down to pranav against yiping and
I think that's the one that we need to
do a deep dive into because this will be
the decider
yeah and I'm Gonna Keep a side eye on
the way you game but right now that game
is very close to being over it's a full
extra piece for alham if something
changes on that board we will take you
to it but you're absolutely right Tanya
this is going to be the deciding game
this game is going to decide whether
zhui's decision to repeat uh was in fact
good if pranav wins then it wasn't a
good decision at all because Norway
would have made up a point off of their
deficit but that decision is looking
pretty good given Louis yeping's
position which is Rock Solid he's got
that Bishop ensconced on D4 the other
Bishop is holding pernab's Rooks at Bay
uh which are just staring at this F7
Pawn The Exchange Tech yields absolutely
nothing because the queen can shuttle
over to the king side at a moment's
notice this is trouble for pranav who
has to get something going on the king
side I would play Queen H4 maybe try for
some Bishop H6 some Brazen sacrifice but
with two minutes Tanya he's got to
figure this out really fast
for he's trying to build that attack on
the king side right now not so easy to
find but this Rook landing on F6 there
are all these tactical ideas Prana looks
pretty relaxed though about his position
he knows he's got a game and we know
that he is tactically super sharp so it
looks like the kind of position he
enjoys playing and once it becomes a
Time scramble it's gonna be anyone's
game Queen H4 I like it creating threats
like Rook F6
and I think B takes A5 that decision to
snap up a pawn might have given white
the tempo that renov needed to actually
get things going yeah Rook F6 Bishop H6
you know don't be surprised at these
moves because Black's King is pretty
wide open I mentioned that the queen is
a good defensive piece well that's not
entirely true that only becomes true if
this bishop moves out of E6 it is
nowhere to go I suppose you could play
Bishop B3 in fact you might play that
move but then Rook F6 might come with a
Tempo purnov loves he thrives in these
kinds of tactical positions practically
Tanya I'm starting to reconsider I think
he's got pretty good chances as yipping
says I need to bring some more beef to
the king side excellent defensive move
there Bishop back to C5 yeah not an easy
one to find a bishop Retreat making an
attacking piece a defensive one but a
strong one but let's zoom out for a
moment because we might be having
results very soon let's bring up our
bird's eye view now look at that top
left board where he has actually made
some progress it's gone into an end game
and he's playing on seconds it's not
going to be super easy for elham to
convert this one meanwhile the top right
Port Wenger in driving seat up in
exchange that's a one point for Shanghai
Tigers is where ye back is this
difficult for elham now alham is
starting to mess up the nerves are
starting to show let's go to that game
because Juan Jun is literally going to
win within a couple of moves that's a
guaranteed result elham is making zero
progress now he is up a bishop but Wei
has secured a second Pawn for that extra
piece I think a draw is now yeah well
given his time it's hard to say but wait
he's so good I'm playing with increment
but but Tanya I mean it's a pretty easy
position to defend for white Rook F2 you
bring the king up to defend the pawn
your goal is just to push these pawns
trade off the F Pawn and those positions
with pawns only on one side of the board
are often theoretically drawn way is
very close to pulling out a magical save
here
and the more pawns that get traded the
closer white gets to that draw Rook have
to hit that pawn on C2 but the F6 Pawn
will still be pinned white can bring up
the king to B3 and try to defend it but
then some mating ideas with A5 what is
happening is where you're gonna start
getting ambitious with the move G6 if
allowed and alham stops IT Rook G3 on
the board and now comes back and we see
the eval bar definitely with such few
pawns on the board it looks like it's
getting closer to the draw
this is fantastic defense by way Bishop
F6 Rook F7 I think he gives a check on
E6 and now he's gonna push that H Pawn
and he might be getting ambitious you
can blunder this away with black Bishop
G7 would be a nervous move that blunders
the bishop now Wei Rook G6 he's playing
all of the top engine moves he still has
eight and a half seconds on the clock so
just enough time to figure things out
this is insane I think it's now
basically a dead draw Tonya H6 Rook G7
and H7 is basically going to prevent
black from making any progress in this
position and with elham's clock
dwindling down I mean for Hellam has to
be a little bit careful not to blunder
this game away he can feel it in the
heat he's down to 30 seconds he knows he
needs to win but it's not easy in this
position anymore meanwhile Zhu engine
has delivered for the Shanghai Tigers
she wins her second game in a row taking
down Nino batser Chevrolet So currently
the Shanghai tigers are up by a point
and it looks like where you will survive
this disaster that was with the white
pieces checked upon advances to eight
seven and now the problem with black
skin is going to be once it finds its
way all the way to the queen side to
pick up the 87 Pawn the queen side pawns
for black will get weak and white can
start targeting those
that's exactly right
and Wei trying to achieve the ideal Pawn
setup on the queen side elham
maybe we'll try something like A4 and
maybe try for some tactics related to
Bishop E5 take C3 I mean there's still
chests left to be played but the biggest
problem Tanya is that this Pawn is on a
light Square so it can't be targeted by
the bishop it's an obvious point but
it's the most important factor here and
Wei right now is nothing to worry about
A4 by elham and he just shuttles his
Rook back and forth
and then you have to move your king back
and then maybe the king can get in
all right Ella I'm still trying to pick
up some seconds on the clock he just
makes a simple move and I saw in chat
that white is holding while white might
be holding but we're just seconds on the
clock any result is possible one bad
move with Black actually elham can be
the one in trouble but right now he does
block off White's King on A2 he's
struggling to find a way to improve this
position Daniel black needs to find a
way to start pushing his King to D5 to
C4 to B3
he's trying I think he might go for it
right now King D5 is on the board and
Wei still has work left to do Bishop E3
threatening so tricky is keeps forcing
the king back Bishop C1 Bishop C1 King
B1 King B1
just queens and wins the bishop so that
would be your draw and this is clear
elham is still trying to when he falls
back with the bishop not falling for
that sneaky trap
oh that was so close Sonia and wait he
is just iron clad and his determination
to not give up half a point here King
back to B1 he's not about to fall asleep
one more attempt by elham here comes his
King but where does he put his Bishop
White's Rook is such a pest
maybe at some point black has to put the
bishop all the way back to h8 to be able
to come forward with the king so that if
white does attack on E8 then black can
pick up the eight seven Pawn a check
right now would drive a black skin back
he attacks maybe bishop h8 now the
bishop is safe there
it is safe because rookie 8 would
blunder the pawn elham with 100 1.5
seconds as he made his move it is so
easy to get nervous and lose on time
he's an experienced Blitzball he's made
zero progress this is going to be a 50
move roll eventually Tanya I think
they've made probably about 30 moves in
this position and at some point elha
might just say listen I'm not making
progress this is a draw you could also
get mated with the King on B3 and
White's Rook on B4 so there are ways to
lose this game by getting over ambitious
yeah with no pawn move so 50 moves the
clocks would automatically really stop
well right now it has been no progress
we have another game that's going on
let's do so much for this because once
again it will come down to this bird's
eye view what we see on the bottom right
pranav against luji ping all the pieces
on the board all the heavy pieces on the
board everything to play for Lu Yi ping
the eval Bar says black is slightly
better here but this is far from over
but there is a lot of activity for the
Shanghai tiger player with the C file
under control
this has gone South for the Norway
gnomes again let's go to that game
because Wei's game with a 95 certainty
will be a draw June June has indeed won
her game pranav has to deliver here but
his position does not look appetizing at
least he his attempts at a king side
attack have been repelled but both sides
under 30 seconds no question Tanya that
pranav is the much better Blitz player
but Black's position is really
watertight Queen can come to D4 you've
got the extra Pawn on the queen side
Louisa pink can basically tread water
here if he wants
D3 is a weakness B2 is a weakness and LU
you pink targets that the queen can also
come to B6 start hitting that B2 Pawn
any heavy peace trade with that with the
light Squad Bishop will favor Black
right now look at that move Rook before
I love it you blocked the attack on A5
placing your Rook on such an active
square and now after Queen C3 the E5
Pawn is hanging it's still a little
tricky because the A5 Pawn needs to be
defended where do you put your queen he
offers a queen tray with Queen D4 but
this does allow Rook takes A5
yeah and I think Louis pink trying to
play this without risk but as a result
he's messed it up why did he take on C3
there's no need to do that he corrects
White's Pawn structure and I think his
lack of bliss experience showing a
little bit he's trying to get a
repetition here white can't play C4
pranav now playing for a win but black
using the pawn to deflect white shark I
think this is going to be a draw and
Louisa pinga makes sense he knows the
match score he's just trying to force
this game into a draw now pranavas to be
careful too because he still has this
weakness on D3 I think black should play
H5 here just get the optimal Pawn
structure and basically just sit don't
lose on time and don't blunder a fork
don't collect 200.
meanwhile where he has survived that big
Square scared down a piece he managed to
fight be resourceful against these stop
guys the analy is just so hard to win
getting a winning position means
absolutely nothing against them nope
absolutely nothing and right now this is
a dead draw Tanya but pranav he might
try but you don't want to catastrophize
right you're still going to be two
points down to the draw but the match
would be far from over if you lose with
white then you're in even bigger trouble
so prernav I think he just needs to
accept the inevitable I don't see a
single winning attempt here for white
you want to try and make get your knight
into an activity but look at where it is
on F2 every Square was controlled you
want to try that to get that Knight to a
square like G5 or D5 but it's such a
hard way uh on route to that position
with the bishop and The Rook controlling
all squares Rook F1 pinning that Knight
hard to imagine white getting active
with the Knight here
you hit the nail on the head just
impossible to figure out a route to E3
purnova is trying though he keeps
declining repetitions
um he knows that he's the better Blitz
player but there's just no attempts he
can't even get the knights E3 Tanya but
you called it the bishop would still be
restricting the knight from reaching one
of these squares
he goes C3 another way but where is the
nine headed the D5 square is under
control and that's the problem Rook H2
was a threat doesn't want to trade
pranav is ambitious but that ambition
doesn't have Foundation here it's so
hard to make progress for white
yeah I mean this is almost like the way
you game and that we've had this exact
position for the last 25 moves this
could be a 50 move roll but I think
pronounce should just repeat he's got
five seconds here trying to figure out
he's thinking about maybe going D4 but
that only asks her trouble it weakens
the E4 Pawn black could go Bishop H3
here and Trey oh no slip nope wait whoa
oh my God your mouse slipped he meant to
take the bishop and he accidentally
stepped on H2
Ben cannot believe it either
wow this is heartbreak
and Prana oh
my God you have to feel for him right
now he was the one who was pushing he
was the one who was trying and then a
mouse slip costs not just him but the
Norway gnomes the round two this is just
unreal what we just saw
grabbing his head in all of my Blitz
Games with pranav I've almost never seen
him Mouse lip but your hands are shaking
you've got the butterflies in your
stomach that's what that does to you and
a very costly loss for the Gnomes who
somehow lose this round they were
completely in charge Tanya at one point
elham was winning prernav was attacking
at the end elham fails to win pranav
actually loses in an absolute heartbreak
as they go down three points
the barrels of online chess a mouse slip
costs Prana of the game and that was in
was absolute disaster for Norway gnomes
once again it is the Shanghai Tigers who
win with the two-point margin with three
one in round two increasing there lead
by Four Points the Shanghai tigers are
at sixth Norway gnomes are at two Daniel
this is a one-sided affair
so far it is and correction I I thought
they were down three points no they're
down four points both rounds with a
score of three to one and the Shanghai
Tigers could win this in the very next
round with a score of two and a half but
we have seen crazy comebacks in the PCL
and the Norway gnomes they did have some
good positions but right now they've got
to throw all caution to the wind elham
has to win his game it was still a good
result when all is said and done a draw
with the black pieces but when you look
at the game I mean if you're the manager
of the Norway gnomes if you're young
Ludwig or you're one of the fans you are
praying right now
well the normal gnomes have made a
comeback earlier even after being down
after two rounds they have done it in
the regular season earlier stage of the
protest league but now they just have to
throw everything at their opponent and
they need to score big they need to do
it fast because the Shanghai Tigers just
need two and a half points to win this
match to make it through to the
semi-finals they are currently leading
six to two that is a big ask from Norway
gnomes to score heavy I mean this entire
match could be over in the next round
with the Tigers just needing two and a
half points
yeah and right now the Norway gnomes
they need to have one goal in mind get
this to round four right get this to
round four give yourself a chance to tie
it and if you're the Shanghai Tigers you
don't have to get two and a half here a
score of two to two would be just as
good you would need only half a point in
the fine around Tanya so you don't need
to go crazy it doesn't matter how many
rounds are played the only thing that's
recorded is the final result of the
match so more solid play coming for the
what seems to be unbeatable Shanghai
Tigers right now
anything but solid flare coming from the
Norway gnomes as we will be
will be win big can they make a comeback
we'll find out after this break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this year saw the return of the pro
chess league and thank goodness chat so
good to have you back PCL the St Louis
Archbishop returning to the pro chess
League playoffs let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh one
hundred thousand dollars up for grass
the quarterfinals of the protest League
playoffs have finally arrived
we win oh my God the PCL is here to stay
who will be crowned its next champion
the Shanghai tigers have been burying
their fangs against the Norway gnomes we
are heading into a big round tree but
the chess action will continue even
after this match as the Gotham Knights
take on the three times protest League
champion the Saint Louis Archbishop
that's gonna be a big big match that's
coming up and then tomorrow on Friday
the quarterfinals continue with mgd1
taking on the Wizards and the yogi
against Blitz it's so hard Daniel to
pick a favorite in any of these matches
oh it is and the next match is going to
be amazing as well I mean the St Louis
Archbishop they're just happy to be here
because they lost the first two matches
they were one match away from
elimination and now here they are but
facing off against a formidable foe each
and every one of these matches Tanya is
so unpredictable and honestly that's
what makes the PCL so amazing we want
evenly matched lineups we want matches
where you literally cannot predict the
result of a single game who could have
predicted that this was going to be a
blowout after two runs
it's been too much fun on the board and
with the teams the kind of lineups that
they've been bringing in and today it
looks like Shanghai Tigers has been
doing everything right and if they
continue doing that well this match
could be over in this round three that
is coming up the Tigers need only two
and a half points they need to win this
match with the smallest of margins
meanwhile gnomes needs to win they need
to win big because even if they are able
to level this round three with a 2-2
score a half Point going into the last
round needed by the Tigers that's only
delaying the inevitable for the Norway
gnomes Daniel in my eyes this is a Do or
Die situation for the Gnomes they need
to win this one and they need to win big
absolutely they do and looking at it
board by board obviously pranav has the
white pieces against the way he who has
shown uh some weakness pernav has to
show you know his Sunday Best opening
preparation one E4 go for mate Pavel oh
yeah he's gotta make his presence known
he has had a rough go of it so far as I
always say Tanya uh one of the biggest X
factors for every team is their board
one if the board one scores under 50 you
are in huge trouble just by definition
and Pavel is half a point out of two
right now everything has to go right
let's not mince words everything has to
go right the Norway Noms have to get
lucky and they have to be incredibly
good everybody has to play their best
this will take a miracle but we have
seen our share of miracles in the PCL
thus far
pranav also needs to show a lot of
mental fortitude after what happened in
round two he was so in control he was
trying trying to get ambitious in the
end game but a really moment
with an unfortunate Mouse slip saw
everything fall apart for the 75th
Indian Grandmaster the 16 year old
pranab he needs to keep that behind him
because right now it really is an hour
never moment for the Gnomes and for the
Tigers we've been speaking about the X
Factor juvenger the women world champion
has been such a power player and of
course that top board Wiggy who will be
taking on front of in this uh very
critical round three pranav's gotta
leave what what has happened behind him
with the white pieces he has to go all
out but he's playing against weigi
that's a big big ask from front of
Daniel
and we is obviously going to play for a
win that's just the way he plays but the
Shanghai Tigers uh they don't need to
Roar quite as loudly as they did the
previous two rounds they can afford to
play solidly but you have to avoid
relying too much on your neighbors on
your teammates and just say listen I'm
going to take care of business myself
I'm not going to rely on board two and
three and four to play well that's what
Wei I think is telling himself if he
wins his game with the black pieces then
the match is essentially over because uh
the Chinese players who have white are
just so so so solid they're hard to beat
uh in the top board I think is going to
try to prove his own fortitude and
really put pranav down pranaba you're
absolutely right forget what just
happened forget King H2 play the new
game and we are off with E4 E5 on the
board we are off and it is a Spanish
well no Berlin so where you still keeps
all the chances on the board pranav
needs to find his chances with the white
pieces as you mentioned 62 for the
Tigers they don't need to Roar they just
need a little growl in this one and they
will be true but Prana I'm looking chill
at least body language wise it's clear
that he is still feeling confident
Bishop C5 but he slows down and that's
an early slowdown because usually black
plays this move after playing the move
B5 you kick that Bishop on A4 and then
Bishop C5 are those normal usual
standard Archangel setup with this move
order it did take pranav a little by
surprise
and pranav is not super theoretical he
plays sharp openings but he likes to
play Sidelines within those openings the
same goes for the Sicilian and you know
he does play uh I wouldn't even call
this a sideline D3 has been such a
popular way to play the real Lopez in
the last few years we saw it of course
uh heavily in the nepo dang world
championship match so D3 and C3 standard
rui Lopez farron I think what you will
play B5 at some point he can play it now
uh but he's not exactly afraid of Bishop
takes Knight that's not a dangerous move
it hands over the bishop pair and that
resulting Pawn structure is uh nothing
to write home about so I think he's
going to Castle and then he's gonna have
to decide where to position his own
light squared Bishop do you bring it out
to G4 or do you play B5 and Bishop B7 so
hard to make any conclusions thus far I
think a lot is going to be decided
really by the next five to seven moves
all right now everything's solid and the
reason pranav has slowed down is because
he's trying to understand his own
approach in the middle game at some
point white wants to try to push the
Deep on wants to make the move d4 but
you have to watch out for the E4 Pawn so
he first continues with development
plays the move Knight D2 The Rook can
slide over to E1 the Knight can come
back to F1 find its way over to the king
side but you always want to make a
little move like H3 with white at some
point just taking away the jumps on G4
you don't want to allow black to count
to play with the move Knight G4 because
watch out for that Bishop that's just
moved back a seemingly defensive move
that is a key piece in Black's position
that Bishop on A7 eyeing that F2 pawn it
would be a dream to get Knight G4 and F5
in but not happening anymore Daniel
and where you could have played Knight
F6 to H5 with F5 but again right given
the match situation no need uh to try to
be a hero instead he Maneuvers his own
Knight over to G6 so now the position
looking a lot more like an Italian uh
then a real love is in fact this could
be a direct transposition uh into uh a
certain line of the Italian if black
plays B5 and the bishop drops back for
example to C2 which is not unlikely way
you could also rely on the d65 pawn
break a very flexible uh positioning
here of blacks pieces and ultimately
he's gonna have to make a decision in
the center so I think he's deciding
between B5 D5 and maybe some sort of
slower move like H6 uh or Bishop to D7
and meanwhile for white it is all about
trying to get that Central break D4 in
to create your own peace activity get
that knight from F1 to the G3 Square the
bishop usually falls back and create
some sort of a complex tensed position
in the center let's zoom out while this
one develops it's going to be a slow
fight in this one it's gonna take its
time all pieces and pawns are still on
the board and this is our bird's eye
view action is on on all the boards and
I know one one board that Donald you're
not going to be too happy to see that
top right guess what we have another
London is London becoming a mainstream
opening now listen it's a beautiful city
I love the city of London I don't know I
don't love the opening that's named
after it unless there's a javava report
uh affixed before it so Pavel he's being
solid
um it is definitely mainstream opening
especially after the World Championships
Tanya and for the longest time it's had
this reputation as a very popular
opening amongst beginners and
intermediate players but it couldn't be
called me mainstream at the top level I
think that is changing and the opening
has gotten very theoretical right you
don't play it anymore to avoid Theory
there's a lot of stuff to know for both
sides so let's have a look and see if
Pablo alyanov is showing anything here
in the opening I really don't think he
is it's not because I bear a grudge
against the London I promise I'm
evaluating the position objectively I
think the Women's World Champion is uh
is handling handling these very well
challenging the Knight on E5 and if
Pavel has to take on t7 then there's
going to be a mass trade and total
equality he has to try an idf3 here
that has to be the move for white the
more pieces that get traded traded off
with a Vengeance Pawn already on C5 the
nice central control that she's got in
black is going to be absolutely fine
after Knight F3 there are ideas that you
need to watch out for well Knight H5 can
that be a potential sacrifice on H7 can
there be moves like Knight G5 and things
could get super duper messy with that
kind of play Knight F3 is what we are
expecting and it is on the board
and I think we're going to see 94 but we
could bring up an elsewhere I think you
you uh brought up a very instructive
line Knight H5 is a very common mistake
for newer players it's a common idea
let's go after this bishop right well
there's Bishop takes H7 a Greek gift is
standard fare in the London system and
it's a great gift on steroids because
you don't actually sacrifice anything
getting H6 runs into a discovery King G8
runs into Queen takes H5 and white as an
extra pawn and a devastating attack so
June June obviously not touching this
with a 12-foot pole as we refresh the
live board she has decided to expand on
the queen side and I think Pavo might be
doing the same thing on the other side
of the board let's go
we might be seeing that well engine on
the queen side Powell with H4 will make
his intentions very clear get that H
Pawn the g-pawn rolling and who knows we
could have a messy messy London we keep
referring to the World Championship uh
because dingler and one a fantastic game
with the white pieces after shocking us
all employing in fact the London system
for the first time ever in the world
championship and we've been seeing the
London so many times in these faster
speed formats but I have to say vention
it's pretty clear that she's showing a
lot of confidence in the way she's
handling this against the top Board of
the Norway Norms now Pavel slowing down
he's taking a think let's just zoom out
for a moment because action is on on all
the boards in the protest League every
player counts every board matters and
let's just do a bird's eye view well the
top left again lots to play for the
position is even with such an
asymmetrical Pawn structure and once
again it's a game for all three results
the other game that catches my eye is
the bottom left board with Nino against
Zhu Yi and this also feels like Nino
should be happy out of the opening with
the black pieces it is quite a thematic
standard line that she's played and
pretty much gotten everything that you
want with black
yeah we've got a Mainline fortnite
Scotch we've got we have had quite a few
uh fortnite scotches thus far we haven't
looked as carefully at those games
because they tend to be on the quieter
side but this one has some promise and I
think Julie isn't really playing this
opening to draw the game necessarily
right you can play the fortnite scotch
for a win but he's definitely airing on
the side of being solid he's just played
Knight to D4
objectively I think the position is
equal but Nino has to be very careful
about how she defends C6 don't go C5 and
walk into the fork
I wouldn't go Queen C7 because of the
prospect of Bishop F4 even though black
can play Bishop D6 I wouldn't set that
potential tactic up don't take on B2
that is not a fair trade I think the
only move here that keeps all of Black's
trumps alive is Rook B8 to B6 but it's
not an easy move to play and practically
Tanya I really like White's position I
think White's got the initiative in the
center Rook can come to E1 and I can
come to F5 but Nino staying on top
finding Rook B6
you know I've been playing some very
very accurate moves and I think the
results of her game haven't been
reflective of the quality that she's
been bringing in that move Bishop C1
again the way you in the first game such
a difficult defensive move to find and
she does it again with Rook to B6 but
Daniel in this format in the regular
season earlier in protest League we have
seen Nino struggle a bit she's played
four games so far for her team and she
scored half a point elham has making his
debut today for the Norway gnomes now
it's so important for these players to
score simply because it's single
elimination there's no margin Ferreira
and right now with the six to two score
Nino has to make sure that she holds
this game with the black pieces Rook B6
is the first move in the right direction
in terms of match strategy Nino is I
think should be okay with a draw so she
shouldn't Force things uh if the game is
headed in that direction obviously if
you have a choice between an equal end
game and a complex position given the
match situation uh there's really no
decision here so Rook a to e one played
and I think this is a great example of
that nino could make a non-descript
developing move like Bishop D7 or she
could try to expand in the center with
C5 and orchestrate some tension in the
position maybe even grab the pawn on B2
later on I would I would go C5 and I
would make that decision pretty quickly
to put some heat on White's clock here
Tanya
this is amazing C5 definitely asks a lot
of questions well you're speaking of
decisions and some big decisions have
been taken on the other boards So Daniel
we'll zoom out for this for a moment
because this one is still heating up and
take a look on that top right fire that
we have on with wengen against Pavel we
were talking about the H Pond marching
down the boat Powell chooses the Jeep on
Gary the G Pawn has arrived on G5
Vengeance still with the space on the
queen side but this looks like
white 4h5 breaking into G6 who would
have thought that the London could get
so exciting
crazy and Pavel doing exactly what he
has to do but another game I want to
visit briefly a tactical blunder
unfortunately committed by elham Abdul
rauf uh who has just simply blundered
upon to a very dick so if we could take
a quick look at that game and then
perhaps we can go back to pavel's Game
and Watch that double edged battle
unfold elham
everyone
back uh Queen's Gambit to climb they got
a common Pawn structure with these uh
pawns on E3 F4 and E5 and elham carries
out the typical plan Bishop F3 meets
with F6 looks like a great move Tanya
because F6 runs into Queen takes E3
check but no Bishop takes D5 and right
out of the Clear Blue Sky after CD
Knight takes D5 the queen cannot
maintain contact with the C5 Knight and
black actually loses two pawns there
elham is forced to move his King here
bad bad bad news or black he's got to be
careful not to get blown out here
such a cool tactic because once the
Knight would have arrived at D5 and we
can just Mark the square it also
controls the queen coming on to C7 so no
contact with the Knight that would have
meant two pawns up but this looks like
big oversight by elham and it's so
difficult this tightrope of playing fast
and trying to be as accurate that's why
we see these big misses happen it's such
a grueling demanding format requires
speed and accuracy Bishop E6 played so
elham now in the back foot tail he's
gonna try to try and find play against
the central E5 and E3 pawns that's the
big compensation in the position shaking
his head he's definitely not happy with
how things have turned out Lu yiping
once more in driving seat
he's in the driver's seat although I'm a
little bit surprised at Bishop C4 I
thought he could have taken on F6 there
and use tactics to correct his Pawn
struck
stands I think alham is still very solid
he's down upon
well I was gonna say we're gonna see
Bishop take C6 and 94 Bishop E2 what a
strange move allowing Queen G5 here
which alha misses and a lot of sloppy
moves here for both sides Queen G5 there
Tanya would have forked to the epon in
the h-man I still elham Smith is okay
he's gonna win the pawn back Bishop P2
is a terrible move by white he should
have just traded everything and maybe
even just made the draw now suddenly I
think the table
let's look
because once he loses E5 E3 might be
next
it is about these two pawns right and he
I don't know why to actually defend the
E5 Pawn the Knight on C5 controls the E4
Square so there's no Queen E4 you played
the move Knight E4 that makes a lot of
sense you can't pick up the E5 Pawn now
because the C5 Knight is hanging well at
least for the time being white keeps the
central pawns safe so 94 the only way to
keep the central pawns alive
yeah that's a great move and lip Louis
ping realizing that he's got to be
precise here likeliest
draw a high probability of a lot of
Trades here Rooks can
I and elham again just like Nino he
shouldn't try to force it obviously when
you're in a deficit like this the
players of the white pieces are
ultimately the ones who did to deliver
but oh I'm trying to keep the tension
from the it7 let's go back to the bird's
eye view though because pavel's game
continues to heat up sharper and sharper
the position gets
man Tanya mouth-watering display here on
all boards oh all boards I mean we I
mean look at that bottom left
top left what we gotta run to that board
we've got to see where he gets thrown up
where are you coming in with Knight G2
the eval bar hits it but we love it
because this is such a practical
decision
what's stressful for the players is the
best for the commentators and the fans
we already know there's an inverse
relationship uh in that sense Knight
takes G2 a knight sacrificing itself to
shatter White's King position bernav has
nothing to think about take that night
man you've got nothing else to do I
think he's trying to figure out wayi's
follow-up I think that follow-up is F5
F4 Tanya opening up the bishop the queen
has direct access to the king side take
that EBA bar and toss it in the trash
can because practically White's position
is going to be very very hard to play
this is amazing stuff we saw where he's
sacrificing his night in the previous
game Knight to F5 to open up the king
now he once again sacrifices the Knight
on G2 to open up whites King the queen
will land on H4 hitting that pawn on F2
the F Pawn will start marching down the
board and notice that Bishop on CT C8
suddenly opening up assisting that Queen
on H4 to hit that H3 pawns so many
threats on the board and like you see
like you said the eval bar absolutely
deceptive here this is a nightmare to
play with the white pieces and you can
see it on prana's face how does he play
like this Daniel he is an absolute beast
at creating these ideas
he wants to end the match but if we
examine why the eval bar gives such a
good assessment for white it's because
of one move it's literally a nightmare
you've got to bring your knight from E2
up to G3 and it's a natural moves on the
surface but it looks like it fails to F4
if we could bring up an analysis board
very quickly because we are going to see
a move here shortly after Knight G3 F4
it looks like you're getting mated but
it turns out Knight takes E4 black will
deliver the check on H3 the king calmly
drops back to H1 the line continues
takes the Knight now for some reason
white has to take on e4 with the Rook I
have no idea why and after Queen takes
F2 still looks like you're getting mated
but Queen F3 somehow holds all of the
key mating squares together and in the
resulting position white finally starts
to consolidate the extra piece so this
is what stands Tanya between pranav uh
and a defense of the attack he also has
less than three minutes on the clock
this is going to be massive if he finds
these moves well he might do the process
of elimination
it's right on the board it's either
it's either threat physically but then
after Rook F1 you would be terrified of
the move F4 coming in it just looks like
with that Bishop H3 and F3 ideas this
will look like game over and I think
even though the line that you pointed
out is hard to find through this process
of eliminating Rook F1 Prana will be
able to play the move Knight G3 he has
to make sure that he takes that decision
in time he's down to just two minutes on
the clock and the critical decisions are
just starting in Rook F1 on the board
and that is a mistake Daniel F4 F4 he he
got in his own head I think prernav is
just in that negative mindset where you
already trust your opponent F4 is on the
board Nike one is his idea but oh what a
tactic Bishop H3 and F3 ends the game
this is insane
oh my god wow
um that's a two-piece Sacrifice by Wei
incredible what is this one of the best
games of the protest League this is
absolutely gorgeous he's giving
everything away it the bishop doesn't
even to participate in the attack all
you need is the knight in the queen
Tanya what's the idea as pranav is
realizing after Knight H3 the idea is to
play F3 check deflection what are you
deflecting you're deflecting the knight
from the H2 Square why are you doing
that to be able to deliver the check on
G2 separating the king in the other
night Tanya King H2 Rook takes F3 is
game over it's Checkmate Seven Ways to
Sunday uh seven ways to Friday I guess
no it's Thursday
anyways to the semi-finals it might be
this is just amazing stuff by
the board what
pointing at Daniel your attacking skills
with F3 immediately spotting this idea
this is insane stuff you're playing out
all the mates that are happening on the
board and you can see it on both these
players way israelizing it he's on the
brink to victory in this one for Prana
with the white pieces the position has
fallen apart in 20 moves unbelievable
Knight G2 Bishop H3 a double piece
sacrifice taking the victory I'm telling
you that game against Bruce on Batista
in 2015. that's when we knew what we
where he is capable of it's crazy how
quickly he played Bishop H3 that was out
of a cannonball it's like he was playing
a hyper bullet game that is how
confident he is at his attacking skills
this game is over bernav is sort of in
this process of accepting the inevitable
with 30 seconds on the clock even if he
did have a defense here uh it would be
virtually impossible to find you really
cannot blame him uh for failing to
consolidate they're particularly given
uh the previous round and how upset he
was to start the game this one's over in
just a couple of moves not H3 F3 is on
the board dropping the king back does
not help you get Lobster pincer mated on
G2 or F2 so were you playing out the
line Rook takes F3 and I think Knight G1
Rook F2 might in fact be the end of the
game okay that's basically the
resignation Queen that's it yes
it's just delaying the inevitable gives
up the queen but there isn't much a
night after Knight G4 is coming in next
The Rook will come to f8 the attack
still continues white has got no
development no compensation black
doesn't even need that Bishop on A7 and
just 10 seconds on the clock Knight G4
is a big threat with a mate coming in on
H2 Queen G3 Queen H2
that's it one second pranav I think
we'll let his time around 94 Queen G3
that's game over that's Checkmate that's
it and that's a point for the Shanghai
Tigers one step closer to winning this
match in blowout fashion
unbelievable so far it really has been a
one-sided match you can see the pain on
Prana right now it all started with that
Mouse slip and now Wei with a brilliancy
in this one two minor piece sacrifices
gets the point for the Norway gnomes but
the good news for gets the point for the
Shanghai Tigers the good news for Norway
gnomes is that top right board Pavel
Aliano has found his rhythm in this one
against the women world champion 2
wenchen he's dominating compare that
White Knight on E5
55 if anyone can push this position it's
got to be the Norway gnomes it's got to
be Pavel eliano and that bottom right
word for elham it looks like he's
stabilized he's stabilized but given the
result in way this game is a great
result for Louisa Peng he just has to
hold things together make sure he
doesn't blunder the e-pawn or the b-pawn
oh I'm very tricky in the end game so
that's likely to end in a draw Nino is
slightly worse so Pavel I mean at this
point he literally has to win but it's
actually not a simple conversion as
beautiful as the Knight looks let's zoom
into that game it's actually hard to
make progress here and with one minute
on the clock Pavel has a weakness on G5
which means the queen is kind of stuck
in place the b-file is hard to get a
hold of I'm actually not convinced that
from a practical perspective this is
even close to winning
yeah and you're talking about these
points and I just want to get my queen
on E5 so I can start threatening a
debate on G7 at some point but where do
you move that knight from E5 you can't
fall back to G4 you can't fall back to
F3 you can't fall back to D3 black does
control all the squares and it's really
a beautiful looking piece but it kind of
comes in the way of White's attack
you're pointing at how does white
actually continue the momentum
everything looks beautiful but where is
the finish here Rook B8 is a move that
you're mentioning and I'm also trying to
I'm trying to figure out where do you
break you never want to play F3 you
might have to trade on B7 how do you
continue with this position how do you
land that Queen on E5 that's the dream
and I'm really I'm not sure why June
took as much time as she did every
second is golden here and right now she
just has to tread water Queenie a queen
E7 Queen E8 and look up at your opponent
say hey how are you going to make
progress that's what you're talking
about Pavel might have to play F3 just
out of necessity you cannot draw this
game the match might be over then and
there because Louis ping is
is actually on the defensive side so
Pavel gonna try to gain some time the
last thing you want to do if you're Jew
in June is burn all of your clock on
waiting moves just go back and forth
force yourself to play fast and she's
not doing it she's taking a lot of time
that might make it difficult Tanya to
handle the situation when things get
tactical and they will
a hundred percent but the move F3 right
it is so scary to play because you're
literally lighting the Matchstick there
and there's no way home from there
bringing on the fuel you open up that
Bishop on D5 and you know that it can go
either way Queen C7 a nice move look at
the amount of pieces on that b8h2
diagonal so really lining up everything
but black needs to be careful to keep
that Queen on C7 defendant otherwise a
tactic like Knight G6 could come on the
board a move like Rook B8 or Rook B3
would be so irresponsible by black in
these positions so you still need to be
careful about Knight jumps great points
Anya so keep this Rook on B7 I would
shuttle the other Rook around between B3
and B2 I don't see a single idea here
Pavel has to try something and the
literally the only pawn move available
legally is F3 the question is when do
you play it I would play it now and he
does oh my God great practical attempts
might get an end game Tanya Knight F3
and the King can actually make its way
along the dark squares to E5 this could
get dangerous for black if Juan soon
fails to keep her composure the Knight
can later come back on E5 there's some
sacks on G6 so still a little bit of
juice left to be squeezed in this
position
a hundred percent and you don't want to
trade that Bishop for the night because
then 56 Pawn is a super weakness Rook a
two not an accurate move now white can
start fighting for the B5 and perhaps do
do you want you will have to come back
with the Rook or do you start marching
with your king to E5 I think she might
have missed that after Rook be one
there's a trade and black plays her
capsu why could sack the Knight and Shaq
made on F6 Pavel misses it though 95 is
a good practical move this is still very
much playable I don't like Rook A2 at
all
so rookie for your sacrificing the pawn
so you can get control of the b line
because then Rook B1 and you can't fight
for this and want and that's a joke we
want your Rook comes to ba that will be
absolute disaster what is going on after
Rook B13 she wants Rook B3 but she
missed Rook A1 there which was winning
the game this is also great Jun losing
her mind here a little bit and now Rook
A1 gets control of the a file black is
suddenly collapsing on all fronts
yeah we see the evolver is doing a
little bit of a dance but Pavel keeping
it precise he does play the move Rook to
A1 a check the King has to be tied down
to h8 because you can't give up the H7
pawn and now look at this move King E5
that is amazing and you don't care about
a discover check anymore and the other
boards are looking good as well elham is
actually taken over in his game he might
win as well Pavel is going to win now
almost for sure this is over elham has
an extra Pawn in a night end game the
only piece of bad news Nino failed to
win that position so that's a draw
it's currently one and a half but both
remaining boards look like Surefire wins
for the Shanghai Tigers it's official
Nino but see Australia is drawn let's go
to Louisa Ping's game against elham who
is about to strike and give the Norway
gnomes a serious chance at a miracle
comeback
that would be one right because if they
win two and a half one and a half they
do keep their hopes alive then they will
go into the final game with needing a
big victory but not by an unachievable
margin and as you mentioned both boards
are almost there let's jump into the
elhamboard it looks like it is getting
closer to Victory than me
whoa what did he just do this happened
before Hans he's still probably winning
though I think practically this is still
winning white apparently has to find
King C3 you can't take this Pawn that
would be suicidal because you give up E3
and G2 and then H3 Falls so apparently
white can draw this with some sort of
sequence of engine moves now he's got to
find G4 to fix black spawns but he's got
the time to do it and he's finding it
and he does it
so precise well that was I think King C3
was a brilliant move G4 you make it
because you need to defend the G2 pawn
and eventually your king will if King F3
then you can start giving a check with
95 Knight F7 start targeting those King
side pawns with the white knight and
this means that yipping is back in the
game after G4 it's not easy for black to
convert this and he's down to 12 seconds
there was no need to give up the queen
side pawns Knight F6 and Knight G8 is
going to chop off the H Pawn then the
game is a draw immediately alham don't
flag here because you lose the match one
second take a move oh
low snide F6 now
Knight F6 King G3 Knight G8 you go off
to the king side pawns and they'll all
be traded and eventually white will get
the move King D4 hitting that Knight on
E3 and winning that C4 point we're
seeing this being played out just after
Knight G4 do not trade the knights you
simply go Knight F7 or you can start
with King T4 King F4 Knight F7 the one
thing you want to avoid is
so he's so mad at himself right now
yep
that's it Knight F7 immediate draw and
that was unaffordable for the Norway
gnomes who will have Force around four
times but they will need a 4-0 victory
to force a tie now King takes C3 and the
game is over yeah and you just sacrifice
your knight and black has insufficient
material and that is it wow yipping
survives that and that means that Pablo
eliano's Victory against juventian was
so critical but this round three ends in
a tie but that's too little too late for
the Norway norms
yeah I mean good job forcing round four
stabilizing things but once again the
Norway gnomes are gonna be kicking
themselves because renov uh he got mated
by way he that was a huge victory that
is why you're top board always has to
play for when we with a huge Victory all
they need Tanya is one draw a single
draw puts the Shanghai Tigers through to
the next round
this is not stability this just feels
like delaying the inevitable extending
the torture here in the next one
Shanghai Tigers needs half a point with
Wiggy with you
and Louis ping where does then where do
the Norway gnomes find a way to beat
them for zero and also we've seen Pavel
struggle in this match so far Nino
batser Chevrolet which is half point out
of three Daniel raditzki it's gonna take
more than a miracle for the Gnomes to
come back it will take divine
intervention it will take one of the not
one of it will take the craziest round
in PCL history for the Norway gnomes and
that only forces tie breaks so if you're
the Gnomes listen have fun you got
nothing to lose go crazy play your
sharpest opening literally you need to
look at this positively as a fun
experience as hard as it is to do that
but again let's call this beta Spade
this match is as close as it can be to
being over only divine intervention will
help the Roman gnomes here
yeah they need that fairy tale ending
for this
would probably be the s
with the kind of performance that we
have been seeing by the Shanghai Tigers
we are going to have a final round there
will be round four coming up but the
Tigers need only half a point on these
four Birds we will be back with the
action on the other side of this break
[Music]
so I first learned about ill Cafe
through my buddy Aaron he was like Hey
me and a group of fellas meet at this
Cafe downtown on Sundays and we play
chess there it'd be really cool if you
could stop by and hang out with us and
you know just feel the vibe and so I
showed up
and it was a nice bike I was like yo ill
Cafe is pretty ill
Ness
don't do it
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh
uh you know anyone trying to develop
their chess game if you do find you know
style of play that you enjoy that's good
but you could also try to sharpen it by
implementing you know another form of
into your bag as we would call it
[Music]
thank you foreign
welcome back everyone to the
quarterfinals of the pro chess League
we've had a fantastic season so far and
we've had some fantastic play by the
very best in the world so far take a
look at the highest win percentages that
the players have shown and there is a
certain way with 80 percent he has been
on fire today but leading that at 90 no
surprises there Hikaru Nakamura but also
let's point out that the biggest upset
of the protest League season was in the
first match of the Gotham Knight with
Josephine heinemann taking down Hikaru
Nakamura but he has been Unstoppable
since then Magnus carlsen's theme the
chess bras have been knocked out but
look at that score that he had with an
87 win Daniel that has been a lot of
decisive chess we've seen so many
incredible individual performances Tanya
car losing to heinemann and then winning
10 other games he hasn't given up a
single other draw that is absolutely
incredible it cannot be overstayed did
how much of an effect a good performance
by board one has on the success of your
team and obviously Wei uh is currently
playing for the Shanghai Tigers he is
putting through another solid
performance not giving up a loss
refusing to lose that game against elham
and that is really when things went from
bad to worse or the Norway gnomes who
need a 4-0 victory two horse overtime
at the top of the table with the highest
win percentage with just one loss in his
very first game of the protest league
and once again he's been on fire ever
since winning 10 games and Wiggy on the
on that list as well with 12 wins out of
15 games phenomenal performance there
Fami was on the list as well and we're
gonna see yeah Fabi versus Hikaru match
up later today after this match right
now it is all about the Shanghai Tigers
needing just half a point to get
business done to make their way over to
the semi-finals Norway gnomes it looks
like they're staring at the end of the
road the end of the tunnel for them but
they need a miracle to come back on this
one and Daniel if we take a look at the
scores the players have had you can see
on the Norway gnome side on the right
side of this that nobody so far from the
Gnomes has really managed to deliver on
that team nobody over 50 that tells you
all that you need to know Pablo yanov
making it to 50 with that on-demand
Victory against Jew and June but things
have gone South foreign who won his
first game and then losing two uh very
disappointing games that Mouse slip in
round two and of course alham and his
first PCL performance playing great
chess right he was defeating uh wayi he
was winning his last game
um that really was a game that he wants
to have back and he's got to push all of
that aside right now the Norway gnomes
have only one assignment and that is to
do their best in this final round to go
all in you don't even have to look at
the board of uh your teammates right
because you know that no matter how they
do you need to win your game every
single thing has to go right for them
let's watch this is gonna be really
really fun
it's gonna be really fun it's gonna be
really tough for the Norway gnomes and
again a 50 score is just not in at the
top board carrying the team but Reggie
has been such a great performer not just
the result not just the score line but
the kind of Chess that we've been seeing
by him that last game for me was one of
the best games that we've seen in the
protest league so far against Prana with
the black pieces finishing it off in
under 25 moves with two minor piece
sacrifices just going for the king some
amazing stuff there and finer evenly
match round where it will be way against
Power that is a youth versus experience
match there and what are you expecting
out of that one Daniel well obviously
each and every player on the Gnomes has
to play a sharp opening so I'm expecting
Pavel to play a way you like opening
maybe a G6 you know maybe some even a
nimso Indian but anything but something
overly symmetrical like a queen's gamut
accepted obviously a void forced
drawlines like the plague of course
there's only so much you can do because
the players on the Tigers super well
prepared wait he's super well prepared
so first and foremost you need a
playable position out of the opening but
don't go D4 A5 right you also don't want
a lost position you want to strike that
balance between getting an unbalanced
position but still getting yourself
concrete chances to win the game because
way is not going to let you go if you
play something overly offbeat
it's such a clash of styles on this
board one as well we see Pavel Aliano it
hasn't been a great day so far for him
but he can't turn it around if he
manages to win this one against where he
has been on fire and we were talking
about a clash of generations here where
he's just 23 years old and it's easy to
forget how young he is simply because of
how impressive he's been in the early
years of his career once again
Grandmaster at 13 broke the 2700 barrier
when he was just 15 taking that record
from Magnus Carlsen becoming the
youngest player ever to do that and
today he has really delivered for his
team I'm expecting akaro Khan my code
should always say that one E4 is the
better move to play if you want a draw
because there are more forcing Lines
within E4 openings Pavel is a Karo Khan
player uh but he's also played the
Sicilian he played the Tamanna against
me a couple of years ago so let's see
what he chooses it is indeed akaro kind
of the Karo Khan is as good of an
opening as any it almost by force gets
an unbalanced position no matter how
solidly you play if you want to play the
most solid line Tanya then you go D4 and
you take on D5 yeah so way he's gonna
play a pawn of attack which does contain
some four straw variations particularly
if black brings the other night out so
Pogo might want to play an early E6 here
to get at least some play
it's amazing you've just been calling
out you just called out the karakan from
happening in this board Daniel you need
to go buy a lottery ticket today as soon
as possible that was an insane call we
did see a Karo Khan on the board now the
thing is Right given the Norway gnome
situation I think for eliano it's great
that he's playing a player like way he's
way in the regular season out of 15
games had no draws he won 12 games and
he lost three and that's just his style
of play we've seen that today as well so
we can definitely expect chaos and
that's exactly what eliano wants with
black to try and score
yeah I mean listen you're choosing
between a hurricane a tornado and a
tsunami but you're absolutely right if
there is a super GM that you want to
play uh it's you know it's it's not
someone like I don't know anishikiri or
or someone on the solid sidewayi is
going to play for a win every game
that's just his style and it's a
well-known very true cliche but the best
way to secure a draw on demand is in
fact to play for a win so we have an iqp
that is the most common structure which
arises out of the Pawn off attack this
is going to be a combative game and
Pavel very experienced in this type of
position but Tanya the bad news even
though these positions are sharp on the
surface there still are a lot of of
Pathways to get a quick drive white
pushes D5 there could be a lot of Peace
trades so I'm a little bit pessimistic
let's see if Pavel can at least get out
to a combative position here in the next
couple of moves he might play B6 here
because you want to put your Bishop on
this long diagonal you want to develop
that to be seven the light Squad Bishop
doesn't have so much of a future where
it is right now that makes a lot of
sense you've got to start putting
pressure on the D4 point now the move D5
that you mentioned where you would play
that if he was getting something out of
it with his style of play just seems to
kind of hint the fact that he wants to
keep more pieces on the board so after a
move like B6 perhaps just take out that
Bishop on C1 continue with development
either to F4 or to G5 and I would be
surprised to see D5 on the board but but
we might if we just needs to draw for
his team why not just simplify finish
the match right here
definitely Knight C6 could be met with
D5 uh B65 there's always the capture on
uh C3 which you have to be careful about
that leads to what is called the hanging
Pawn structure it's almost like rather
than one isolated Pawn you have two of
them on an island on C3 and D4 the
downside of taking on C3 particularly if
White's Bishop gets the G5 is that you
suffer on the dark squares and Pavel
sinking in a bunch of time here trying
to figure out the best setup to get
himself winning chances he does in fact
play B6 good call us and queen E2
instantly by way he's trying to get that
time advantage
and he puts the Rook on do you want to
defend D4 so that makes a lot of sense
the White Knight can jump on E5 D5 when
and if it comes on the board with the
Rook on D1 will be that much more
powerful 95 Bishop G5 you can see where
you're trying to get the kind of middle
game that he likes yeah no this is great
decision making by way not wasting
unnecessary time and Pavel he normally
even a classical game would be thinking
this long he literally is fighting two
enemies so he's fighting Wei Yi and he's
fighting the draw Monster uh trying to
figure out can white play D5 against my
move
maybe H6 maybe some Bishop takes E3 just
to get an imbalance but again Tanya the
problem is you're pulling a 2700 So
getting an unbalanced position is just
the start of it you actually have to win
the game
absolutely and even with the black
pieces it's so hard to imagine getting
the kind of position where you've got
chances but again where he will not go
for lines that just simplify the
position it's just not his style of play
he's always hungry for the wins so even
given the math situation I'm gonna say
this Daniel that way he is ambitious
he's gonna play this out till the end
he's not going to try and trade off the
pieces no it's just not what he does and
I'm expecting uh in this position once
black makes the move for where you
either put that Knight on E5 or develop
that light Squad bishop and just keep
all the tension on the board I am a
little surprised with the amount of time
that Pavel has taken to reach this
moment Pavel has to wake up here it's 11
moves and he's got six and a half
minutes I mean this is already not
looking great I think the biggest
decision that he's trying to make is
between taking on C3 and developing the
Knight the issue is that he's already
three minutes behind on the clock way is
so good in the opponent's time pressure
we saw what he did with when purnov
dipped to two seconds this is exactly
what Wei is going to do Knight bd7
ultimately is decision but on a great
call you D5 is on the board the moment
he got the chance to do it he plays it
and White's actually on the better side
of what's going to be a very drawish
position this is already looking really
bad
yeah absolutely and now with the Rook on
D1 D5 comes with so much more power
because you'll end up winning that
Knight on D7 there will be a lot of
Trades here we'll see how this one
develops but of course the other board's
super important for the Norway gnomes to
create their chances
the Shanghai Tigers need half a point on
any of these positions and they're
through to the semi-finals and looking
all around especially that top right
board Vengeance against Prana it looks
like it's not going to be a tough task
for the Tigers what is going on it for
enough how did he get those ruined pawns
on E6 and E5 he's already in Mortal
danger here and a disaster he made a big
positional blunder just a couple of
moves ago let's go to that game uh
forget Pablo lyanna who's got to win uh
a completely dry position pernavis
borderline lost here positionally he's
given up that Bishop on E6 that Bishop
was replaced by a pawn Tanya his
structure is ruined his whole position
is in shambles right now
absolutely and I think the pranav it's
been hard since round two since that
mile slip moment he started the day on
sahai winning a game but then it all
went down after that Moon King ish to
just a mouse lip that blundered the game
has been hard for him he's been fighting
it mentally psychologically and it looks
like these are the outcomes of that
moment Bishop E3 played Queen see some
new been pointing out the pawn structure
activate that Bishop get the Rook on to
D1 it's white who's playing for
everything I love this idea of Queen C4
how is black going to even try to defend
E6 you have to fall back with the Knight
on f8 but that would only allow white to
jump on with the Knight to C5 exactly
and pranav on a bit of tilt there he
missed a good opportunity to stabilized
the game when Juan June played C3 he had
that Intermezzo Knight C5 could have at
least tried to prevent White's Bishop
from coming out to E3 and restricting
Black's minor pieces even further very
Classic Plan here is to play H4 and
Bishop H3 I think June June is going to
do that fast first she's gonna put a
rook in the center White's position is
so easy to play the moves basically make
themselves here she know she's known H4
Bishop H3 type plans since she was three
years old and I think we we're gonna see
H3 Maybe it to the C4 white is in total
luxury here
for the shine guy tiger she beat Maxime
washer legrav in the regular season and
that was a phenomenal performance so far
she scored eight out of a possible fifth
today's game so she's been a heavy
hitter for the team and today on gay on
board too she's held her own she's had a
fantastic score over 50 and now here we
see completely in control she will be
fighting in July to retain her world
championship title which she has been
absolutely on fire in this format this
season she has survived and thrived in
the highest pressure situations Tanya
imagine that experience level and having
someone like that on gym who has
literally played and won a World
Championship match it doesn't get any
more nerve-wracking than that this is
cake compared to sitting in front of
tens of thousands of fans and players
and playing for the ultimate chess title
what a luxury for the Shanghai Tigers to
have uh Juan Jun and Wei uh and an
incredibly solid IMS and GMS to round
off boards three and four this is this
is just such a dreadfully Dreadful scene
to face
absolutely and she's also a former World
rapper champion and that just goes on to
show how strong she is in these formats
she's Unstoppable in these shorter time
controls and that's the kind of Chess
regardless of who she's playing she's
hungry for those wins Knight D2 played
that Knight is headed to C4 once again
to try to vacate that square for that
Queen so that from from C4 you can't
Target the E6 Pawn you were mentioning
that ideas like H4 Vengeance sees them
in her sleep and that's exactly what
we're seeing happening with the bishop
arriving on H3 this is going to be a big
trouble for pranav he B5 desperation
desperation it's not too early to say
that word Tanya because his position is
collapsing junjun's gonna go Bishop H3
and I think she will play Pawn C4 and
you want to dance on the queen side
let's dance on the queen side because
you don't have the Firepower to keep
things up here C4 is going to cut into
Black's uh space advantage on the queen
side then the pawn could drive up to C5
if you have a trade on A4 the a file is
going to open black is worse everywhere
this is just I mean the Evo bar is
giving plus three that is not an
exaggeration it really is that bad for
black
yeah this looks like benjen will be the
one who will take this point but there's
work to be done because there are still
a lot of pieces and pawns on the board
it's still too early to call a result
but this is a dream position for the
woman world champion we will zoom out
from this because at least on one board
I can see that the Norms have a dream
position and that is the bottom right
board and as I was saying it I do see
the eval bar come down now the move the
last move Bishop E3 that was played I
think this just comes in the way of
white building an attack on the H line
and gives black time to actually
consolidate the position finish
development meanwhile bottom left board
we see alham hasn't managed to create
too much although he does have a nice
Knight on D5 but it's perhaps not enough
to try to push for a win yeah he's got a
slight Advantage I would say he's got
some chances there uh but uh you you hit
the nail on the head Nino does have
exactly the kind of position you want in
a must-win situation unfortunately on
the top left uh the game is moving in
the direction we predicted it's a dead
drawn end game for Pavel Eliana to win
that position I mean a miracle would be
understating it but let's have a closer
look at Nino batsia who is in the midst
of playing a really nice attacking game
against Louisville is in big trouble
here tactically I mean it's another iqp
structure and look at Nino's pieces and
how well coordinated they are there's
Knight takes F7 sacrifices in the air
black is super passive Louisa Peng is
walking on hot coals here
and black has an extra Pawn but White's
the one with all the piece activity here
building that attack and that's often
the theme when you're playing with an
isolated Queen spawn that you kind of
don't care about material but you care
about your opponent's king and as you're
pointing out the queen has not only left
the pin on the c-line but doubled up on
the e-line threatening a sacrifice on F7
defending that an important move Bishop
f8 now white cannot trade these Bishops
because that would really take the fuel
out of the attack Bishop G5 as you were
pointing at has been played pinning that
night and now you can still imagine a
lot of tactical ideas continuing with
Rook F3 attacking that Knight on uh on
F6 and building more pressure
yeah and the Queen
you can do something similar having done
its job on E2 it can swing over to F4
there was a beautiful mating line a
couple of moves ago uh you pointed out
that Knight takes F7 was a threat if we
could pull up an analysis board just for
the sake of entertainment if black had
ignored the threats and played a random
move such as Asic look at this line
Knight takes F7 King F7 now Bishop E6 is
made in two but why sack the bishop
that's not even a sacrifice when you can
sack the queen look at this mating
pattern
um the two Bishop Chris Cross mate would
have been a very nice way to conclude
this game unfortunately Louis Peng was
not born on a May 10 2023 he knew what
was coming and that is why he dropped
his Bishop back to f8 he is not about to
be on the receiving end of this bro and
see Tanya he's holding on
I don't know how you do this you just
create all these mating ideas out of
nowhere love to see it but definitely Lu
you ping was aware of all these threats
and he keeps things under control by the
way Rook F3 on the board and if armor
did not exactly approve of that move we
were talking about this white dust put
the pressure on F6 but this did allow
the light Squad Bishop to get activated
and which means that the most important
piece in the attack for the for white
the Knight on E5 has been traded off for
the bishop and that definitely takes uh
takes the poison out of the attack
absolutely good way to put it uh Tanya
this is also looking bad for the gnomes
not only will they not go 4-0 here it
looks like they might actually get blown
out in this round as well
um and and the Tigers aren't going to
end this with a whimper they will end
this with a roar without the Knight
centralized on E5 white has no anchor
the pressure on F6 is annoying but it's
not working out tactically Queen E5 will
always run into I was gonna say a move
like Knight G4 maybe even Knight F6 to
D5 centralizing that back to D7 is a
very sloppy move she's just allowed
Queen F4 that was a really bad move by
Louis bang now Queen F4 creates massive
problems forces F6 and Rook takes E6
gonna pick up a pawn there
wow your queen is hanging upon enough
seven is hanging F6 just weakens
everything Nino batser Chevrolet is
again better in this position and now
some direct threats what is he thinking
about I actually don't see another movie
Queen A5 with Queen F7 whoa what is that
whoa queen of seven King h8 he's forking
the rookie rook and the bishop
okay so that's actually very tricky
Queen F7 King and and you might not
have a good way to defend both these
pieces hmm I think Rook takes E6 might
work out there it's very important that
your Bishop on C4 can drop back to F1
can you go Queen F7 and just take on E6
let's take a closer look with the
analysis board Queen F7 rookie six now
Queenie one check is a very pretty move
but it doesn't work Bishop drops back
later if Rook takes C6 Tanya don't take
with the bishop take with the queen
no it's working out for a White Queen G5
Queen D7 a white is simply two pawns up
and again Queen C1 always meets with
Bishop F1 game is not over here after
Rook d8 but White's ordered a line
winning I think
yeah this is looking uh
this is looking pretty bad or black here
Queen A5 on the board Nino is gonna have
to work out these complications and
queen takes F7 has to be placed she has
to realize first of all uh that there is
no back rank made on E1 and second of
all uh that Rook take C6 hits the Knight
on D7 so
Nino
continuing to ponder Her Moves
all right I think I'm back online here
Tanya go ahead yes
I hear you now Daniel and well Queen A5
so that's super tricky with what you
were showing in Queen F7 and Nino there
she slows down on that bottom right
screen she's taking her time there are
all these ideas of picking up on F7
picking up that pawn on E6 she needs to
calculate her way but this is brute
calculation this is the moment Nino
cannot skip this she needs to do this
for her team big big moment in Norway
gnomes and he finds the queen of seven
on the board she finds it it's over
because way has drawn his game against
Pablo yanov sorry to be the party pooper
here but the match is over
the match is over
and uh way Yi has hell and rookie six as
well has held his position against
paveliana that wasn't even close for the
Ukrainian Grand Master and all the
Shanghai Tigers needed
uh was
all the Shanghai Tigers needed
was a draw and they got it
uh just a moment here
and we do see that
has ended in a draw on that top left
which means that the Shanghai tigers
have won their Master needed only half a
point and with that win they go over to
the semi-finals it is indeed the end of
the road for the Norway gnomes and now
it's just about fighting as much as they
can on these three other boats we see
bottom right Nino batser Chevrolet in
driver's seat she has found all the
tactics brilliant blow there on the
bottom left as well alham Abdul RAF
has the better position not only the
space on the king side but that Bishop
on C6 is an absolute monster pinning
that night on D7 all the pieces playing
Super actively there and wenjin holding
her own against Prana but pranav has the
worst is over for pranav but it just
looks like for the Norway gnomes well
the worst has just started because
regardless of what happens on these
three boards they are out of the protest
League yeah and obviously the match is
over Tanya but the individual
performances are not you want to end on
a strong note this is great experience
for these players but we didn't invent a
storyline where there was not a 4-0
victory against the Tigers
it's impossible it's just not possible I
mean way Yi is just such a solid player
with a white bottle did what he could
ultimately as I said before when the
board one scores 50 or under we'll do a
little statistical analysis before the
next match but I'm pretty sure that the
success rate of those teams is almost at
zero and we can swing over to uh shui's
game against elham
wow and it looks like white has got an
extra pawn and all the compensation here
as well your Rooks are more active in
this position you've got this majority
on the king side can try and create more
play but once again it's just too little
and too late for the Gnomes uh Daniel
and as you pointed out with the kind of
performance that we've been seeing by
all the boards every single board top to
bottom where do you strike how do you
score a 4-0 things started going wrong
for gnomes from round one and it only
got worse in round two
yeah yeah it was a blowout Victory and
uh that 3-1 victory in round one we
always sometimes have the feeling that
there's a certain determinism
that there's a certain determinism
in uh
in in the way in which these matches go
but
the reality is
the reality is that uh there isn't right
things could have gone differently it
could have been 2-2 in round one elham
could have won that game against wayi
Tanya so it's important not to get into
the habit of thinking that things were
meant to be this way one result could
have caused this match to go down a very
different Road
it was a
as well as what happened with eleanov
and now if we just take a look at what
is happening on that bot bite it does
look like Nino is really trying to
create her chances that d-pawn will
start marching down the board but again
time is off the essence here as a black
will block that pawn from Queen A3 keep
everything under control it is opposite
color bishop and white has an extra Pawn
I do not think it will be enough with
the material white has to create chances
against black skin you have to try to
deliver mate here that's the only way to
win the game put that Bishop on C4 hit
that Queen take control of the squares
foreign
and the action continues Bishop C4 on
the board by Nino she hits that Queen so
she is trying to give a mate she can now
line up the battery on the A2 G8
diagonal Queen D5 that's what she's
eyeing things are getting super tricky
for Louis ping they're on the bottom
right board he's trying to run away with
that King to eight six but it looks like
White's the one in driver's seat right
now and this game as well is where the
Gnomes do indeed have their chances and
Daniel is facing some technical
difficulties we will be back with him
shortly but until then Chad it looks
like elham not happy with his position
currently Rook G1 played he's defended
that G4 Pawn with an extra Pawn on the
board and it looks like this will be a
difficult position for black to defend
the good news four the tiger fans is
that where he has already drawn his game
which means that the Tigers do indeed go
on into the semi-finals but let's bring
up a bird's eye view and get an overall
look while Daniel tries to fix up
everything and he will be joining us
soon and here we see on that top right
board who engine against Prana that
looks like a queenless position and this
is when I miss Daniel the most because
I'm sure he would come up with some
attack with some mating ideas in this
position
you're back voice connection I am back I
am back and uh unfortunately the Norway
gnomes there's no coming back because
they have already lost the match but for
elham this would be a meaningful win
right there's always next season and in
these moments that's what you have to
tell yourself you're making a statement
to your team captain to your team
manager that I belong on this team and I
want to be in next year's roster so
elham doing a great job here thus far of
converting this Rook end game he's a
pawn ahead he's got the king cut off
Tanya along the e-file and I think you
should just bring his King up maybe
start advancing the queen side pawns
this should be winning with the best
play
thinking about where he's performance
today Daniel you know when it mattered
he went for the attack he kept things in
balanced he gave all those sacrifices
all the brilliances of the day and then
when he knew that the team needed only a
draw to go into the semi-finals he had
such a professional approach with the
white pieces kept things under control
gave no chances at all to Pavel and then
took his team to the finish line now the
other players just play without any
tension at all they've done what needed
to be done and we do see the games
continue and I'm also very excited to
look at the Nino board if we just zoom
out for a moment this is going to be a
long grind by alham he's going to try to
push for a full point it is all about
while doing the max you can given the
math situation so while LM tries to push
in that with this extra pawn and play on
the lights Quest how much is that with
the opposite color Bishops
yeah it's a funny narrative that's
starting to unfold imagine if uh the
Gnomes win on the rest of the three the
three boards Tanya it would be a three
and a half victory that would be
particularly painful Nino has an extra
Pawn here in an opposite called Bishop
end game but I am pessimistic I am
pessimistic uh about her winning chances
because how does she make progress Tanya
what does she do here there's no mate
there is Queen City
she answers it it was a blunder by
yipping he moved his King back now Queen
takes H5 is an Unstoppable threat
because if you move your king back
there's Bishop takes G6 there's a big
threat on the board Queen H5 is coming
in with that PIN the black king has to
move but where do you move if you move
the king you lose the G6 Pawn
but again it might be too little it
might be too late Bishop 86 was the only
way to continue he had to block that
check otherwise would end up losing the
G6 Pawn as well now all hopes for black
are on this A4 Pawn but that Queen is
coming on to F7 Queen F7 Bishop G6 white
doesn't care about that pawn queening
you're going for checkmate I'm loving
this action that's happening Queen it's
a queen of seven and then finally the H4
Pawn will join the attack with H5
delivering a killer blow and look at
that little move Bishop B1 just making
sure there's never any A2 I still think
Queen F7 had to be played
um yeah Bishop B1 was good prophylaxis
because she she does have a minute but
she still has to make progress without
wandering this D5 Pawn away she plays
Queen E4 ganging up on the G6 Pawn now
she might be threatening H5 Tanya but
these opposite colored Bishop end games
are so hard to win even when you're up a
pawn up two pawns you need to deliver
with accuracy I think she should go G4
G5 and focus on creating a pass Pawn on
the king side
yeah again Daniel she had that moment to
put that Queen on F7 in the same
position I wish we had seen that on the
board but it's still a difficult ask for
black to hold this she trades this
season but she believes with the four
versus one this should be winning on the
king side and as our chart is saying
Nino you got this it does look like this
will be the silver lining for the Gnomes
on this board four versus one in an
opposite color Bishop the pawns can
start advancing the king can come onto
the center of the board it's too much
with it with just two extra pawns it's
easier but with three extra pawns I
think this is an easy uh easy win for
white with two extra pawns yes black and
still hold
yeah King G4 now and then H5 and you've
got three extra pawns on like on the uh
King side time you're exactly right with
two pawns black in a position uh his
Bishop such that you give the bishop
away for White's two remaining pawns now
the game is over elham has also won his
game uh so all of the games are ending
here at the same time Jew and June and
pranav have drawn their game not that
that matters it is likely to be a 3-1
Victory once Nina wins her match so
Silver Lining is Right a great round for
the Gnomes they did their best it's just
not going to be quite enough the deficit
was just too large
oh there's another silver lining for the
Norms that they will walk away with
seven and a half thousand dollars for
their performance at the protest league
but winning 3-1 again it's a big margin
Daniel but it's too little and it comes
at a point when it doesn't matter and we
see Bishop D2 this is not a holdable
position the pawns are marching marching
down the board you don't want to maybe
make a movie like eight seven because
then black can actually block with the
bishop on B2 and that will end in a draw
so take it a bit a bit slow with that
the king marching down to G8 and then
the H Pawn will go down she chooses
another part with King H5 wants to get
G6 in just defending that it's a great
winning plan too yeah King G8 and H7
would have been winning as well giving
up the G pawn and a great Point Tanya
for newer players particularly in
opposite colored Bishop end games the
way that you screw it up is you push one
Pawn too far forward and you give away
control of the dark squares uh which
black occupies in uncontested fashion so
you want the pawns to be close together
so that you can break the blockade with
the pawns defending each other G6 and G7
is going to work even if black puts the
bishop on C3 uh yipping is going to
resign but he's undoubtedly been made
aware that his team has won the match so
a great effort by the Gnomes Nino but
see is really doing her part but it just
wasn't quite enough it's way Yi it was
definitely the MVP of the match along
with Jew and June
what a performance it's been for the
Shanghai Tigers today they pretty much
had the match wrapped up after round
three needing just half a point and
that's a miracle that you need and there
we have it Nino ends the day on a high
but it's not enough for her team she
wins a brilliant game against Lou yiping
but it is the end of the road for the
Norway gnomes the Shanghai tigers go
through to the semi-finals and Daniel
they were clearly the better team today
um they're such a well there was no
fight they were such a well-built team
as we look at the final score it is nine
to seven it is deceptively close and the
individual scores tell you all that you
need to know way you with three out of
four Jew and June with two and a half
out of four she did her part and uh
wasn't the best day for shuyi but he did
what he needed to do he made the draws
at the right moment
I mean they just have no weaknesses
every board is incredible they're going
to be so hard to take down
and that's the full story as you point
out right every board has been such a
big performer including that last fourth
board with International Master Liu
yiping with an over 50 Squad two and a
half out of four some big winsy and he
lost the final game with Nino but he had
done all that needed to be done for his
team so far a brilliant day for Shanghai
Tigers well so far they've only lost one
match in the protest league and it has
been against the Gotham Knight and while
it is the end of the road for the Norway
Norms it's not end of the chess action
because we do have another super big
match coming up we see the Shanghai
tigers have made their way into the
semi-finals one more team in fact will
make their way into the semis as the
Bishops the St Louis archbishops headed
by none other than Fabiano caruana take
on the Gotham Knights which is being
headed by Hikaru nagamura what a
fantastic match that's going to be
Daniel
my goodness Tanya Hikaru Nakamura is
already streaming he is getting ready uh
for his match he will need to deliver
once again a very poor performance by
Hikaru in the regular season of the PCL
he seems to be losing game after game
after game he merely has 10 wins and one
loss but Fabiano caruana he saved his
best for the end of the pro chess League
regular season so did the St Louis
archbishops in general they were down
2-0 I can't keep repeating Tanya it's
crazy they were 0-2 they're in the
playoffs but they have their toughest
trial yet as they face a Gotham Knight's
team that just seems to be unbeatable
when Hikaru is playing well
this is amazing stuff coming up and as
you mentioned a car has been playing
well he had it he's been having a
fantastic run the whole of last year he
won the chessable Masters of the CCD
he's Unstoppable in the title Tuesday we
saw his phenomenal performance in the
American cup with Fabiano caruana as
well right with the performance of the
world rapid and also leading currently
the grand Chester in Romania he goes
into the second half Tournament of the
tournament with a half point lead he's
looking Unstoppable currently and it's
not just the top board Daniel we're also
going to see Alice Lee in action today
I'm super excited about that
man I'll be I'll be on the road uh
watching that match but I'll be keeping
uh my eyes on the road but also on the
match it's gonna be unmissable action
archbishops and Gotham Knight's
Unstoppable Force immovable object
however you want to describe it and
compare it Tanya it's going to be an
amazing match but so was this one it was
a a real pleasure to cover this first
match amazing action and just such high
level Chess By the Shanghai Tigers it's
uh a pleasure to watch such good chess
being played Wei definitely is the MVP
adding all the
all decided Affair it was a blowout by
the Tigers completely knocking out the
completely knocking out the Norms but
for us for now this is all stick around
and after a shot break Daniel Rand and
James Canty will be here to bring you
the next quarterfinal match Big action
as the Bishops take on the night Hikaru
will be there Fabiano caruano will be
there Alice Lee will be there you don't
want to miss this stay on course for now
and we leave you with the best moments
from the Tigers win see you soon
foreign
here and he will resign he'll let us
clock her now that's it it's 3-0 and
shanghai's Ford four has defeated noise
board one how long looking
for them I don't know if you saw but he
did a little dance that a little bobbing
of his head he knows that this is so
close what could go Bishop H3 here and
Trey oh he fell asleep no way
unbelievable oh what a tactic Bishop H3
and F3 ends the game this is insane is
this
Wolf's games of the protest League and
that's a point for the Shanghai Tigers
one step closer to winning this match in
blowout fashion
whoa whoa
inside before
she is also the three times reigning
women world champion is an absolute
monster it's over because when he has
drawn his game against Pablo eliano
sorry to be the party pooper here but
the match is over
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this year saw the return of the pro
chess league and thank goodness chat so
good to have you back PCL the Saint
Louis Archbishop returning to the pro
chess League playoffs let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh one
hundred thousand dollars up for grads
the quarterfinals of the protest League
playoffs have finally arrived
we win oh my God the PCL is here to stay
who will be crowned its next champion
here
we are live with the second Pro chess
League quarterfinal matchup of the day
if you've been with us welcome back to
our next our next set of games with me
the one and only James candy
International Master Danny Ranch Canty
you pumped I'm pumped bro we here is
Knights versus Bishops chat Knights
versus Bishops literally now then
literally it's it's an existential
conversation we're going to have here
with Gotham versus St Louis Knights
versus Bishop but let's quickly remind
everybody of what just happened in the
match-up that took place all you need to
know is that the Gnomes have been sent
back to their Garden Canty wow you know
what it's impact of the garden that's a
funny one day Danny didn't do that one
so that's a funny one okay
we're saying uh the Tigers definitely
eat up those gnomes there of course as
they uh gnawed all over the Gnomes there
in the garden and they've made it
through they're a very scary team among
them
yeah I gotta be honest I see the Tigers
as the favorite regardless of who moves
on with the Blitz and the yogi shout out
to those teams who've worked very hard
to get there and of course I could be
wrong but man those Tigers looked
ferocious Canty and it's going to be
exciting to see what happens in that
semi-final matchup but we got another
quarterfinal right here right now it's
the Gotham Knights versus the St Louis
archbishops as you said Kenny Knights
versus Bishops pick your flavor pick
your match up that you're most excited
to see too that's exactly right do you
guys have Knights oh you got Bishop chat
put it in the chat do you like Knights
or do you like Bishops well of course
one is going to be a winner and if
something is going to be decided today
Danny that's for sure
yeah you know again we're gonna have a
million Knights versus Bishop jokes I
think we all favored the bishop here
until Alpha zero came along and threw
things out the window I see a lot of
Gotham fans in the YouTube chat if I'm
honest I wonder if that has anything to
do with the man Libby Rosman but Canty
you know this is this is a matchup where
you could pick your stars right you've
got Hikaru Nakamura you've got Fabiana
carwana on the other side the top two
Americans of course St Louis sticking on
that side has Alice Lee I I don't even
know what to say but let's let's bring
up the the round by round lineups in the
board pairings because I think right at
the top candy want to get your thoughts
you have Hikaru versus Alice Lee the
rising star uh your thoughts on what she
needs to do to maybe mix things up and
pull it upset in fact the first thing is
she has to use a Hikaru here and we're
going to the mind of your opponent here
and what I mean by that is literally
don't care what she's been doing already
she's been doing a very good job
actually just keeping the pressure off
by just playing her game and you can see
whatever whatever she's eating whoever
is coaching her it's working she beat
the big GM's before she's done it she's
been in the seat of course half man at
everything else and the other half we
don't know yet but at the same time
Alice needs to just do her thing play
her game and hope for the best
I like what you said the Hikaru phrase
literally don't care as we look at Alice
Lee here I'm not sure she literally
doesn't care we uh we we know that she
feels the pressure because every win she
gets every every opportunity she has
against the top player she tends to
deliver which makes her expect that she
should be able to deliver in those
moments so you know even though it's a
board forward versus Board One mashup
she gets the white pieces we know that
she's deeply prepared working hard I
can't wait to see what happens there I
want to quickly draw attention to
another match up there no there we have
Alice on camera and we see her already
leaning in getting her game face on
Canty
um again I I think you I think you made
a good point right you gotta relax into
the pressure I know that's a weird thing
you know you know that you're facing
Hikaru so there really isn't any
pressure on you but who knows this
result you could pull off might be
something that helps push your Bishops
into the semi-finals when all is said
and done today so we'll see what she's
able to do
um quickly I want to mention that
another matchup in this in this first
set of games we should be looking out
for is the big fish versus Nicholas
theodoro that matchup I know I know we
talk about this because the day goes on
and all you tend to remember are the
last set of games candy but that matchup
is one I circled whoever gets the better
of fedosea versus theodoro may end up
being a result that we talk about at the
end of the day absolutely I actually
believe that too as well I mean that's
some that's a mix of a toss-up in fact
got to say I mean car on the same team
is very strong it's scary because both
of them fighting each other is always a
bloodbath there even in the last few
title Tuesdays better say it was able to
get the best of Hikaru so it's very
interesting I mean it's very strong
there but Theodore having that rating
anywhere between
um 3K to 3100 I mean really hanging up
there with Hikaru right so having him on
board two or three actually is going to
be very very scary for everybody else
too as well I love that point because he
dude I love that point because even
though it's Blitz Theodore getting 3 100
people stay in splits well if it was
that easy you'd see more names than
Carlson Nakamura you know Dania
noraditsky theodoro I mean that's it's
not an easy thing to do and it shows the
talent of Nicholas Theodora but okay we
have uh we have a lot of Talent on this
board here we have to come knock
Immortal look at that camera two the
fair play cam I hope you see it we get
to see another view of the man because
he's streaming that's right yeah
wow yeah Carter played a Dutch ain't
quick Hikaru was actually black in this
game everyone just just FYI
um and uh and he's playing a Dutch with
uh
with Annie playing quickly like she
expects the Dutch I know right look at
the C5 idea yeah this one now wow he
played rookie bro he's just moving
there's it's just everything instant
most of this is Theory too as well B3
move actually cover had a game where he
played actually 94 believe it or not I
actually remember looking at this from
Hikaru just studying his games 94 was a
movie played but he actually chose
rookie here so I'm actually very
interested in what he does here he
actually won that game very cleanly with
94 and playing Bishop takes A1 and took
the exchange but it's different wow it's
just instantly moving but can you
breathe bro breathe for a second the uh
the game is moving is moving fast here
which shows that both Alice Lee was
prepared so you gotta love that
storyline right she came ready to go
against the man Nakamura but Hikaru also
you know he blinks for nobody right he's
like you know what I'm gonna play and
I'm gonna play it and I know it better
than you and I like my Dutch although I
like this D5 idea for those looking for
the more advanced chess ideas white
opens the light squares for that Bishop
on G2 right maybe you're you know gobble
up that Bishop on E6 canny and have some
long-term light Square advantages if
you're Alice Lee so again Alice Lee is
indeed white in this position go ahead
Katie
absolutely of course uh I mean after 96
is definitely a move here you also have
Bishop C8 this is something that you
play in these situations and you play
Knight E4 and of course you're one of
the greatest players to play the Dutch
is actually of course Hikaru Nakamura if
you guys don't know so you can look at
the Dutch this is the linen Dutch is
what he's a fan of usually we have
classical and other Duchess the lining
Rod is more a positional one you do have
some aggression there in there but Queen
E7 and stuff like that happens too as
well so what you see is we bounced out
to our bird's eye view the second board
is also getting underway Nicholas
theodoro playing the white pieces versus
Vladimir fetto say of there and uh we
have a an English a ready whatever you
want to call it pick your pick your
nomenclature for that opening move order
and uh I think we'll head back to Alice
Lee versus Hikaru
um at some point here well we can go
wherever you want candy why don't you
pick your flavor in fact I'm actually
checking I'm just looking at the uh
theodoro game yet there's nothing going
on yet they're still in the in the
starting point of that game so I'm just
going back to the Cardinals game there
is a trade on E6 so she does have the
Queen B3 I mean I like The Confidence
from Alice Lee here definitely Queen B3
happened King h8 now for me Carlo tuck
in the king and Roland in the corner
there
yeah
I know
I know it's Hikaru and we will we will
forever suffer from Hikaru bias itis
it's not an Affliction they make they
make a remedy for because when the guy
wins so often you just expect him to
keep doing it but there's a reason why
it has an edge there candy it's because
of the bishop pair it's because of the
long-term problems that the Dutch gives
black on the light score so Hikaru is
good at these positions and you know
he's playing quickly but there's a
reason the eval bar likes white and
Alice Lee not in a bad position there to
start off with the Bishops
well absolutely I mean those Bishops
right you know nice versus Bishops today
guys right so of course yes ambitious
battle and she has both the Bishops here
it could be very very annoying and very
strong obviously if you open a position
but ikaro is just a resourceful player
it's very scary even when you have an
advantage you don't have it yet you have
to like you know be they say beat these
players you know multiple times per game
sometimes a hundred times a game you
have to be or over and over and over I
mean look at this Advantage Hikaru has
played 94 if we want to head back to
that game we uh we can pull it up a
little a little bigger here in a moment
you see how Leslie just traded on e4
and not a bad move the eval bar still
like in white and here we see we see
them in their element a comfy couch
there behind Alice Hikaru Nakamura with
the the well-known neon pineapple sign
for those who follow this stream okay
Bishop H3 wasn't wasn't the favorite oh
wait a second we have an exchange sack
by Hikaru and Alice Lee Alice Lee is in
the driver's seat here Canty absolutely
see that but it takes some real
Precision Precision maybe F4 believe it
or not but Precision here because uh the
I understand Knight F3 King G2 Eagle
Queen G4 Knight H4 is in there there are
some huge possibilities for a nasty
attack obviously of course the Rooks
need open files so yes this is the only
open file you have and maybe you can try
to bully this Pawn but at the same time
you do risk your king being attacked
from a ferocious attacker attacker like
a commercial it is something if watching
your highlights Is Wrong I Don't Want to
Be Right I love every idea you just
pointed out you got those unwanted
in-laws and by I did for dinner hopping
in on the light squares Knight to F3
Queen to H3 this is stuff that Hikaru
Nakamura does that gives people
nightmares but I love what you said the
D6 Pawn is really the biggest positional
weakness for black if white could
somehow play F4 right if you could take
advantage of that Knight's temporary pin
you know maybe maybe you take care of
some problems but if I'm Alice Lee I'm
in one of those spots right now candy
where okay I have a material advantage
but it does not feel does not feel safe
against Nakamura at all absolutely in
fact I mean what you have to do here
from Alice is just breathe breathe first
play the board don't look at the zoom
don't look at the name you plan just
play the position because if you start
thinking I'm playing Hikaru he's acting
exchange oh is that a pawn like how does
the knight move again right you just
forget all of everything right
everything so you have to just play your
game here and queen D4 was nice after
Queen takes oh what is he gonna do after
game D6 Knight of Creator Queen
h36 where you can't play Queen history
first because the night hangs with Chuck
against so it's got to be a pony move
Hikaru knows how to play with the
Knights not just because he plays for
the Gotham Knights but let's let's say
if Queen takes D6 56 Knight is there a
knight F3 check King and I'm chilling
and the engine is like White's winning
right like what is this yeah you know
what it might be candy back up a move
instead of 903 check it might be the
move Rook to E8 honestly you just build
up on the position you defend the Knight
now you're threatening Queen H3 with
Knight F3 coming in again this it's a
bit of a Gamble and we see chat calling
out Alice for being a beast you are
right uh for those who uh if you somehow
didn't know now you know Alice Beast is
is capable of great things and and I
don't think this will be an aberration
when her career is said and done but
but still it's very tricky she's she's
using her time for a reason so I can
check this out Danny like Alice Lee is a
very scary opponent right and the reason
for it is because you look at her and
she's just like the little sweet girl
that's not gonna do anything she play
like she goes to school she gets
straight A's like everything sees the
awesome Golden Child but she's actually
a ferocious killer right ferocious be
very scared of who you look in there
right there of Chess be very scared be
very very scared indeed I think she's
she's really pausing to make sure she
hasn't missed a trick we obviously have
the luxury of an analysis board at an
eval bar that says white can indeed take
D6 as you showed uh I'm not the thing of
the thing that's funny about the
position though Kenny is I'm not sure
there's another move like you wouldn't
place for prophylaxis yeah right because
Queen comes definitely but check so
right the thing that's nice about her
position sometimes when you have those
hands where you kind of have no choice
but to play the best card and that feels
like her position here
wait around
really I mean I guess he really didn't
like to check it which is obvious but
Queen B6 definitely you have to just you
know test the waters there duel hey play
the boar play the position but okay King
G2 and then what does uh 394
it's still not clear I mean White's
definitely still I know but I'm liking
hikara's chances much more I feel like
this is one of those hikara moments
where the pressure was more uh as they
say the threat was more powerful than
the execution and she she took the bait
and maybe she'll take the draw or will
she uh will she take the pawn the second
time around
the win Danny everybody
yeah no like in real life like if you
draw it actually counts as a win against
each other only against Hikaru only oh I
didn't know that special rule of Life
yeah that's that's a new that's a new
thing that's a new rule all right well I
mean what's funny is what will she do
here I'm sure there's a coach watching
this or a manager for St Louis shout out
to Mike cummer if he's still the manager
of the St Louis archbishop's been around
for a while been doing it he's like just
take the draw Alice don't mess with
Hikaru just take the draw don't take the
pawn right you know right
we win we draw we win that's it you know
what I mean like you you win you be like
ah we got the draw like bro you didn't
win no we did like that's exactly how it
is against Hikaru every time so it's
King juli Carl was thinking about it he
showed it he should because look the
eatal bar is closer to equal which means
there is compensation I think about Rook
d8 if I if I was him and and you know
when you're a younger opponent is kind
of saying that they want to draw that
means you know what that means you smell
blood in the water and Hikaru was a
great white shark he's been he's been
circling prey for years and uh I don't
know I have a feeling we're going to see
Rook d8 Hikaru is uh bantering away
I'm not sure we're gonna go to another
game but I do feel like we should back
up to the bird's eye view and at least
take a sneak peek see what's going on
and all the other games going on because
because let's not forget Kenny you have
another Super GM former former former
Challenger for the throne in Fabiano
caruana taken on Alina over there 4-4
for the knights you've got Federal save
and theodoro all these games seem very
close to deadlock and of course we have
vaquita versus bulk over on the board
three board two battle so what are your
what are your thoughts here
well uh the VOC game was bought that's
very level that's probably going and
maybe in the draw I mean white has the
two Bishops there um so bukid off is
actually having a great position I mean
he could just play for whatever that
might be a draw peaceful there Nicholas
Theodore with Felicia that game actually
is quite spicy three four five three six
so he's there's some Pawn tension there
I mean this is quite wild but it is
in-game Wise in-game Wise Bobby's game
probably is the one that has the most
life to it in fact actually let's go
over there where uh
um you know Aloha here actually is
playing I mean there's some aggression
there's some Bishops you know this Rook
on A3 looks strange like the knights
look at uh fabi's these nights as Hikaru
says so the knights look really good
over there there's definitely something
in this in this game here
similar to Alice Lee getting white
against the Kara Nakamura the board four
for the knights alua normanova gets
white against Fabiano caruana
um
not sure how we got here but we don't
have time to back this up for the
opening you got this very very big grip
on the queen side for fabi's Knights you
got the bishop staring each other down
on the H4 d8 diagonal something's going
to break there something's got to give
shout out to Jack Nicholas
move here
well what do we do I want to get F6 in
but obviously he's going to take twice
that doesn't work I want to okay perfect
we got moves takes takes and now what
yeah this is I look at this
Annie can we go 54. look at that little
spicy action
for the C6 Square taking advantage of
the PIN for the win
you know everything I know Danny Danny
always has some Nifty moves Chad well
Danny's aggressive player like myself
here but he plays with me like just like
I think he's a smooth aggressive I'm
just like a aggressive aggressive just
more aggressive but it's more it's very
smooth Knight D4 is a smooth move but
it's very aggressive at the same time
that's Danny style there nice C6 very
nice F6 right wow wait was it play it
looks like it was playing that was on
the floor that was on the board Bobby
immediately takes A4 look at those pawns
on the a file doubled but doing it as I
like to say look at that they're holding
down the B3 square right the Knight
comes in C6 but I don't think fobby
cares he just moves the queen and says
what next
well next yeah Knight before and rookie
three Rook G3 there we go okay we got
something we got some potential
but it's definitely tough with this Rook
on A3 I mean you basically down a piece
I agree shout out to Gateway from chat
calling it out right as candy says that
the Rook on A3 is uh a rook only a
mother could love at this point what's
the future Junior you don't got one man
there is no future I mean you have to
sack it that's the only way you know
this is the way yeah this is the only
way Rook takes B3 at some point or maybe
try to win the C4 Pawn if possible with
like if we need two or F1 hc4 candy
candy when they quickly go back to
Hikaru because right as I was about to
say it I saw queen of three check on the
board and it was an instant draw because
King G1 was followed by the pre-move of
queen of five The Carter pre-moves to a
draw uh the good news is this even
though that was our matchup of the day
we didn't really miss any action because
the position we left it was the position
the game ended on but if we take a quick
peek there Alice Lee takes a breath
you got to be happy with the Half Point
against Nakamura even if she was white
and up the exchange there Canty I mean
it's a win like you know I you know I
have some draws where icaro and I have
them all framed in my house every girl I
have the position just framed behind me
right so I can see it yes I drew him
right that's you know Alice Lee
absolutely and that's a win every single
time Alice Lee is feeling like an
absolute Beast you better watch out now
because she didn't like that's that's
your first board who's next it says
Alice Lee seriously if you if you draw
Hikaru you just set up your day to feel
great you know what I mean it's it's uh
it there's not much better way to start
a chess tournament than drawing Nakamura
this is this is we got a little into the
walk away there just to see what that
final position was but yeah this was
where it ended the king to G2 if you
want to show the last couple moves just
because we're here
well we don't need to it was King G2 and
then and then King G1 and just like that
queen of five and the final position was
as I said right where we left it so okay
Hikaru kind of analyzing the game over
there must be thinking about where it
went wrong but let's back this thing up
because we got some games in progress uh
We've we've been following
we've been following the Other Board One
versus board for battle in normanova
versus carwana but I want to go to the
one I called out if you don't mind candy
theodoro with the white pieces versus
fedosev eval Bar says it's equal but
that's an evil eval bar because I think
that position is a potential blunder
away from an eval bar swing so you see
The Rook take on C4 what are your
thoughts
yeah take States went out Double Take on
C4 now Rook to D2 the engine immediately
says that's not a movie fella started
exactly it might be A4 yes you've
actually called it too like I'll do it
it's not yeah Play Bishop D7 which was
wrong I'm actually curious to see what
the move was the move was A4 but also
Bishop D7 so they both were correct
clearly enough it was just like a quick
eval jump that just
it calibrated after Bishop D7 so now all
this is just an advantage something you
know it's funny because it was what we
want
yeah it is going to be a position where
Federal save is pushing for a win uh
although time is favoring theodoro as we
kind of called out he is very fast very
experienced in these in these PCL rapid
tie uh fast formats excuse me I was
gonna say rapid tie breaks but we're not
there yet
um you know it's funny candy because
from a practical point of view if we if
we backed up I would bet the best move
for white was actually to take the pawn
on A5 with the Knight and allow after
after the trade instead of that I bet
the best move was to take but that
allows Rook C2 and then you're feeling
super nervous and so it's one of those
positions where a computer can say it's
equal but a human doesn't want to allow
that idea and this is this is uh gonna
be tricky for white to defend now rook
and Bishop coordinate better in this
open board than the rook and Knight
absolutely of course as the Knight is
even short on squares I mean your only
move really is Knight A5 or Knight A1
which is the most strangely enough
Knight C2 Knight E3 like you get this
Knight around here that's very strange
yeah and like every time you move the
Knight here in classical games you have
to twist it that's like rules
in the corner you have to twist area
you have to right but after yeah because
it's a strange move but 985 also is a
thing and now he goes for the pawn so he
wants to swing around maybe nobody it's
slipping wait a second
is Rook E4 Knight C1 I guess holds
everything
interesting what a crafty move by the
way if Rook takes C5 Knight takes C5 and
it's white who picks up the A4 Pawn so
so this is uh this is a very crafty
little trick from theodoro
I'm guessing the Big Fellas
the big The Big Fellas I I combined big
fella with big fish because I'm looking
at the big fella I got the big fella
over here
on whatever my dyslexic weatherman
finger points to I got the big fella and
then I got the big fish the big fish wow
the Big Fellas that's very nice as you
see both guys are on the Zone here
calculating what is the time situation
better save is down about two minutes
here and that way it's going to count
but black actually has the better we
should say like uh activity to push for
more but there he is a blunder away as
we saw you know some type of uh eval
swing in the philosophy moves here so
the line that's that's rookie four
forces Knight to C1 and then the black
king comes to D6 with Tempo on The Rook
yeah and I've got ideas like F5 F4 I
mean best play maybe a draw but I I feel
like fiddle say oh he goes for G5
instead Kenny Kenny look at that outside
pass the H Pawn
oh hold on hey hey shout out to Uncle
devaresky okay right you got some
outside H pawns here on takes takes and
we're gonna take this one and we have a
passer we got a runner and Bishop C6 at
some point he's going to hold the
squares you have some weaknesses a
passive piece on C1 black is for Choice
definitely in Practical chances of
course engine can hold but practically
speaking this is definitely some type of
initiative for black yep
wowzers Warehouse as well if you're just
tuning in everybody as you can see the
only game in the books was an upset for
the Bishops to draw for board for Alice
Lee the rising star she is she scathes
the Half Point from hikaranakamura
although you know a draw with black for
Hikaru he knows how dangerous she is I'm
sure he's uh he's feeling fresh and
funky for the rest of the day all right
but G5 makes me really like Federal
saves chances I think black chances are
even bigger than the ebal bar shows here
everyone this is a very tough position
for white to defend
if we want to head back out to the
bird's eye view though Canty because
there are two other games also going
yeah shout out to uh Sun Temple that's
right we got an existential crisis
everyone's looking at themselves in the
mirror and asking do I prefer Knights or
prefer Bishops I just don't know right
well my favorite players on this team
but I don't like this and they just like
Bishops but I understand I like Fabiano
Carlota oh man
therapists it's just it's a real date
it's very speaking of Fabiano caruana
the reason I pulled it back is because
that's the other game that looks like it
could be close to a result with the the
uh the top us player and former
Challenger for the throne back when
Carlson was doing it Fabiano caruana in
a great position and look at normanova
she's also way down on the clock
way down on the clock is a thing of
course you want to use time as a piece
as well like you can have all the
position everything could be winning you
flag okay didn't matter gotta have your
time management treat it as just as you
do your other pieces here really she
makes some moves here and it's already
minus three unfortunately the time God's
over there was not able to calculate and
find the right sequence you are playing
5v2 as well probably with a huge time it
looks like this is just going to be a GG
soon Bobby with the time Edge probably
up the exchange Fabi looking fresh Bobby
needs a haircut shout out to fobby we're
going to talk about that later buddy
you know when he had that when he had
that short Buzz going
um but he's been letting letting his
soul glow there
[Music]
all right well I think fobby's about to
take this one we can stay here if we
want to see the uh the handshake
the proverbial handshake
um
I don't see any any oh nope with the org
just switch there to a different game
okay there we go with bird's eye view in
it we bird's eye doing it right now we
got vaquita I said Boke you said Bach
potato potato right um tomato two motto
well it's the only game we haven't
looked at if we want to check in on it
Bobby is about to get things done as we
see in the lower right
I think the big fish is going to
continue to press so let's just pay off
one game we haven't checked uh checked
off and that's for keyed off oh my God
Rhyme Time taken over me right now
versus both no there's a uh there's
there's a result in the book there Fabi
does indeed take down normanova so let's
quickly head on over to the kid off
versus Benjamin Bach and uh
and see what that position has in store
because
it's an interesting one it's the eval
Bar says equal but there's some there's
some potential chances for a blunder
this is a blunderable end game
absolutely I actually thought this would
be a draw a long time ago here but in
fact this he's playing on box time which
is totally you should you know you
should play this oh yeah especially for
the team as well
um now there is a blunder away for
really both sides I mean the bishop has
to stay around both these pawns you
can't actually move it without hanging
one of the other pawns so it's actually
interesting okay when I move to the
Knight here it's the bishop that's a
nice little yeah what's this bishop G6
yeah wow this nice versus Bishops like
whatever you want I don't know I might
take the Knight here
you got Gotham Knights versus Arch
Bishops you've got a lot of Knights
versus Bishop battles on this one and
the Knight versus Bishop Dynamic with
the Rooks in the theodoro versus Federal
save game if you're just tuning in so
lots of fun talking about the Knight
versus Bishop Dynamic on and off the
board today
um definitely getting dangerously long
time the one thing about bakis is
extremely incredibly strong in all
formats but what he does get low on time
and it's very frequent that's why he
doesn't play as much bullet he does but
of course he does get in time trouble
because he thinks he's a stronger Master
absolutely but he does not actually uh
uh he thinks a lot right as you can see
he has a such a huge time deficit here
but he is holding he is holding we do
get that two second increment
yeah indeed he's holding on we can kind
of see the uh the fair play double
camera there in the lower right corner
viewing them shout out to the team
working hard to always be proctoring
closely what our Peeps are up to he
needs to take some tips from you on that
green screen by the way yours is looking
flat and fresh and nice he's got a
little wrinkles there that's not good
for the chroma key I know
what a chromebooking right exactly yeah
of course he just dropped adjustable
chords too as well shout out to uh Bach
with his name so India make sure you
guys check that out Enzo Indian festival
course from Bach that's why he's sitting
with a green screen is so yeah you can
just get one off that this is the Amazon
one very easy so that says box hair yeah
black always has a different hairstyle
in a way
all right well
we said this was blunderable but I think
we should go back to the one that did
have a blunder theodoro and fedoc has
completely changed and it's exciting if
we can get there because Theodore was
losing but he's up on the clock okay we
have wait did a result happen right as
we pull up the board indeed Bishop d55
wow it's a it's a skewer
and and the door goes down on time man
yikes yeah this was getting tough anyway
with the Rook checks and stuff coming in
I'm curious what happened in the last
few months yeah that was a tough game it
happened right around here 55 kg5
F3 was just wrong King D6 okay
let's make some moves here
oh wow spicy he took apart E2 but you
know okay theodoro was holding his own
until that move Rook D3 check yeah five
seconds here too yeah The Rook has to
vacate the third rank everyone and then
the F3 Pawn Falls just to show why why
King C4 is winning uh after you throw in
a check for good measure but the F3
opponent is falling there with the
bishop
um actually even more checks I'm wrong
it's more than just for good measure
it's actually a really nice way to
improve so that's how the position fell
apart
wow interesting stuff and this one it's
funny what is what's going on here with
the irony of it Federal say of board two
for the knights dominates the night
dynamic in the bishop versus night
battle here so I'm gonna I'm gonna
question my very existence at the end of
this match but I do know we have a 2-2
tie heading into round two can't he wow
two two I mean hey you know the Knights
versus Bishops are still the Battle of
today guys the Knights versus the
Bishops who are you gonna choose in real
chess as well do you like the Knight or
do you like the bishop you're gonna have
to show up today chat it's still even
two versus two yeah and you know we we
uh we called the upset for Alice Lee it
happened or we said she was capable
right we called the fedocia versus the
Adora battle for being huge that one
goes the night's way uh but okay carwana
getting it done on board one as well for
the bishop so we have a lot of things to
get done here today Canty the show has
only just begun we are deadlocked we
don't know anything more about these
teams than than how we started but we do
know that we're going to take a very
very very quick break before we head
into the next set of games everyone so
don't go anywhere it's the pro Chesley
quarterfinals our second match of the
day continues when we return
foreign
it's impossible
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
League playoffs continue here we are in
our second matchup of the day thanks for
being with us alongside James Canty
Danny wrench right here and a player
named Alice Lee Canty showed up and
delivered as she's been doing all year
for the bishop she gets the draw against
the board one for the Gotham might say
coronakamura but take us through a
little bit of her bio here Canty and
just talk about the rising star that is
Alice Lee
says number two rated woman in the U.S
three-time World youth gold medalist
right 20 21 feet a youth rapid World Cup
winner second youngest player in PCL 13.
right 4 5 and 11 in 2023 PCO regular
season and we need to add this Drew
Hikaru Nakamura like you put that on any
resume for anything yeah you did wow
like you get the job whatever it is you
know that you're looking for you know so
that's amazing there now of course she's
a force to be recorded
three-time gold medalist that's three
more than I have and she's already
sitting there ready to roll for the next
game uh she knows as board four that
every time she plays it's kind of out of
The Frying Pan into the fryer or fire
depending on how that phrase goes I I
mess up mess up those phrases from time
to time but the point is she draws
Hikaru but she's ready for the next
fight man has she been impressive and uh
someone who's been absolutely key for
the Bishops as they made it this far in
the quarterfinals will she help carry
them to the semifinals we're going to
find out at the end of the day on that
note let's bring up the round by round
lineups and talk about what board uh
What uh what game two right what boards
shift as we head into the second round
Canty uh we know how the PCL format
Works they roll they roll on Hikaru
Nakamura now takes on Nicholas theodoro
he gets white fedosaev gets Lee she
plays the board too out of The Frying
Pan into the fire but keyed off versus
carbona OMG I can't wait for that
matchup and nurmanova versus bulk uh
King Andy pick your flavor oh definitely
I'm following Alice Lee you know all day
like the Alice Lee is just she is has so
much potential she's so strong she's
young and she's uh you know you can tell
in the face she's very slow it wants to
play the board not the person right she
just played Carl great game got to draw
she didn't play Cairo she played the
chess board 64 squares in front of her
so she's gonna do that every single game
so it's very good to see how she does
against FedEx who is the number you know
two here like she she already drew the
number one so like she's like hey let's
you know bring your best game for the
safe I know you were a big fish but I'm
big Alice Lee
but she gets black there so that'll be
tough we're gonna obviously follow that
one but we're also gonna follow Hikaru
Nakamura as we always do versus Nicholas
theodoro in this next game Hikaru gets
white so he'll get a chance to kind of
rebound a little bit aggressively
theodoro though is a guy he's thrown
down against a lot right you think of
title Tuesdays you think of all the
blitz battles so this will be an
interesting one I think I think Hikaru
is obviously the favorite when is he not
but uh I expect theodoro to make it
spicy it's a it's a fun Battle of
aggressive Styles at times too with
these two absolutely of course
aggressive Styles I'm always a fan to
see right wrong but theodoro is you know
he's just an element he needs to bounce
back right you know okay I'm Abby Caro
so that's kind of that's really annoying
like I lose the game and then I get a
car over the next round like it's really
hard to bounce back like that but of
course you do have to do it you have to
do it for the team here and again try to
play the poor Harry Carlo is looking to
win you know he's like yo I just had
that draw honestly yeah very strong and
he's looking to get on the board today
too as well so this is
the rest of the weary when it comes to
the protest League man it is just like
you know insert uh one one way to uh to
talk about it out of The Frying Pan into
the fire no rest for the weary the the
action rolls on never a dull moment and
here we have a nimzo will we get a shout
out to Benjamin box chessable course the
nimzo Indian evening
hey Carter knows this stuff well this
will be a fun one to see the test and
How Deep The Rabbit Hole goes in terms
of the theory
yeah this one's uh I remember this
Theory from a long time ago Bishop A6
you have a new end of taking and you
play D5 I think and Bishop takes F1 you
allow King takes you play G3 King G2
black plays C5 like it's all active play
very active yeah takes takes D5 yeah
correct takes Bishop takes F1 takes
takes G3 King G2 like then we just have
an easy game or whatever it's just gonna
be a slow one might be a slow one here
but let's see what happens here
you have to be you're doing a great job
highlighting the how deep that theory
goes but also some of those lines lead
to really direct Force variations which
can get very drawish right so you have
to be a little careful uh those Nim Zone
lines have been played okay we already
see a more tension full it's tension
four position you know what I like that
that's new attention full positions
with B3 and C5 hanging pawns here we
come
all right hanging pawns here we come the
hanging Pawn structure these are tough
too because usually you know they always
say keep the tension but of course he's
tape wall yeah that's gonna be that's
sharp that's sharp baby boy yeah we that
is sharp stuff
wow take C5 takes C4 one of those
moments where there's so many captures
on the board I'm glad I'm not playing I
just get to you know
let's go nice right let's go nice chat
who do you have we got the epic battle
of the year of the century Knights
versus Bishops which one do you choose
put it in the chat of course yeah we
want to know if you want nice Universe
really I mean it's funny I think if you
pull people more people prefer Knights
as their favorite piece quote unquote
but push come to shove you end up
favoring the bishop and a lot of
exchanges if you're real honest with
yourself I mean let's be real so exactly
to be very honest you gotta understand
when the board opens up most times it
does when it does it favors those
Bishops so of course we do have two
Bishops here where Bishop B2 is going to
be a thing but he's thinking about what
he wants to do and he takes on d8
takes on d8 we have more of a quiet one
yeah there's so many moves here I I okay
the email bar slightly favors white I
admit I don't know the theory well
enough to know the best move here I mean
taking b6 is obviously an option I don't
think you really want to take back on C4
is is B4 an option um in a weird way
white has the bishop pair so long term
dark Square Bishops will belong to white
as long as it stays this way
but uh wow but it could have really
taken his time you know this is not one
that he wants to slip back to my point
candy that some of these nimsos can get
very forcing and so before you know it
even if you're the stronger player the
position doesn't have enough to push so
Hikaru was taking his time here for good
reason everybody he wants to get a
position where he has the potential to
keep playing
and that is trying to figure out the way
the best way through obviously
calculating variations okay so he takes
here I thought this one was cool too but
I mean you had other options before B5
like how do you want to do it if you
take C5 he can actually take on B3
weirdly enough and this is what I didn't
like maybe he takes about Ace but then
this is weird this Pawn is very annoying
on B3 he could take on B3 very possible
I was trying to get some B7 in there but
that really doesn't work it just takes
Bishop takes 867 Rook V8 so like there's
nothing yeah no big deal
enough MBD which is French for not going
to matter I mean you know exactly
yeah let's exactly all right well this
game does matter it definitely will
matter but let's back up because there
are three others that matter as well you
see as we said Federal save with the
white pieces against Alice Lee she just
got that draw against the car Nakamura
if you're tuning in Where Have You Been
car one of Akita off over there as well
in the lower left and then Benjamin Bach
versus alua numer Nova uh
you know we love checking in with some
Alice Lee over there
gonna tell me twice
hello
sometimes I look at these positions and
I don't know the theory and you know I'm
actually trying to figure out what was
this opening let's actually just start
from the beginning real quick it was a
petrol wow okay right that's Raw
ain't very solid she's with the solid
route
very solid C4 Theory
in the position we can see on the board
the Knight is on e4 here on our bird's
eye view and as Kenny said that was a
Petrov
that got them there we'll we'll pull it
up big time here for you in just a
minute but as we're looking at it there
it's it's still just almost deadlocked
and uh
yeah it's
nothing uh nothing has changed as I said
something's got to give shout out to
Greg Kinnear and
Helen Hood
and here she plays Queen D7 allowing
Queen takes B7 to happen but if you do
that you might as well hit the button
when you do it that's the resign button
after Rook key to B8 the queen is
absolutely trapped Believe It or Not
craziness this is actually pretty I mean
I like it for both sides Bishop H3
actually might be a real thing is she
really feeling aggressive here and you
got the queen coming in and queen H2 at
some point Rook E6 to G6 he yeah he felt
the heat there Bishop everyone
definitely understand that it's like
yeah you don't have to do this to me on
National Television all of us watch that
would have got bad very fast
and she's once again in in a great
position out of the start we will say
that regardless of where the results may
go she came well prepared against icaro
for those of you who missed it she
blitzed out that prep against hikaru's
Dutch was no thing for her and once
again in a very equal and playable
position
with the black pieces against Federal
save just amazing amazing chess right
now from Alice Lee
yeah that B7 Pawn is poisoned you could
we can show show the kids at home that a
rook goes to B8 and uh yeah you can't
take right now because why I played
Bishop won but if that Queen takes a
rook goes to B8 and Bob's your uncle
there
obviously
[Music]
Queen has no Square so
that's it
run it back live position what is Alice
going to do now she plays A5 as A5
the A4 that's what she wants
yeah
we gotta develop this right like I have
to develop
dude she just knows these positions so
well
yes it is it's very impressive
she plays Jess strongly here against
these top GMS with no fear no fear
that's why it's scary like you can look
at that there's no fear in her face
whatsoever she's just reading the board
calculate make a move read the board
calculate make a move I wish there was
someone who really understood how
important calculation was on this on
this uh cast I wonder calculation wow I
wonder what you should favor a
calculation over you know anything else
maybe maybe it's over everything it
could be a thing but maybe it could be
calculation over Everything Chad that's
right have you have you checked out
Kenny's merch shout out to Kenny's merch
go check it out get yourself a hat that
he's wearing right there yeah
swag at your next turn we
it's interesting because it almost feels
like she overextended a teeny bit
because after Knight C3 now you've got
this uh this this tension coming to D5
White's gonna play like rookie to see
one next and if you take on C3 as you
said the pawn will take the bishop has
to retreat and then that B7 Pawn is
backward on that open file whether the
queen can take it right away or not so a
little bit of an edge now it happens as
we always joke pawns pawns can't go
backward right and so there's one thing
at a high level you can really start to
focus on as what is dictating the plan
and that B7 Pawn even if it was poisoned
at first watch out for it to be a
weakness in Alice Lee's Camp as this
game goes on E7 Punk I'll be very very
careful about this uh we have Rook a to
c a and I still like her position it's
very solid there's like okay white has
some trunks but also black give a nice
night on e4 we have the pinning of the
Knight here you have isolated phone I
have isolated font we have an isolated a
I have an isolated a like this is even
it's very even very strong very
impressive right and of course they said
you know at the high level they say win
with the white pieces and uh draw with
black right now of course so what did
Bobby say he was like yeah it changed
for me when I was you know I could play
for a win with black is when he started
playing like King's Indian stuff but it
is good to understand like you know you
don't always have to just you go
aggressive here that's one thing I had
to learn you know I always have to like
try to crush them every game because
these guys are especially as good as for
the save is you won't be able to do that
so you have to play um in different some
chess here in fact H6 very nice
improving move some love for the king
Maybe
a great town population us but let's
back up to the bird's eye view our
population goes from one game to four
games when we do so and I wanna I wanna
check on that that Bot game versus Norma
Nova because
somehow a pawn fell on H3 for white but
the computer says it's good it's good
for the man competing for the Bishops
white has an interesting Edge there uh
with uh with the Knight on e4 because
the F Pawn is also gone for black so
interesting one yeah let's head on over
to Bach versus Norma Nova and see how we
got here Canty what a weird position D6
Pawn is weak another Dutch Hikaru
hikaru's uh he's spreading the Dutch
love over there for his teammates
everyone's in on the Leningrad now all
right like the lining ground man look
I'm not gonna lie I didn't cry it's not
serve me well but it is definitely a uh
aggressive opening and it is risky
because you do have these these
weaknesses but if it works it works very
very well here this Mr G5 very nice move
D6 is very weak giving up D6 the Knight
takes E4 is the move that's a strong
move it's a very strong move tactics
scary stuff he's also one of those
positions that's funny because you know
how like our human biases we don't look
at pawns Hanging On The Edge but Queen
takes a
and computers have taught us to be a
little more greedy than we were
comfortable being so you got to watch
out for that uh
The Edge seems to belong to white with
an accurate move here according to the
computer I think you could even defend
A2
um I wonder if there is it is a forcing
line on camera
six but then there's Bishop there that's
the only thing I didn't like but then
the queen comes back to D2 and am I
defending the A2 right you're right bro
right maybe even Queen E7 too yeah takes
takes by the way it's on the board looks
like it's happening and King D6 is uh
it's just yeah because we want to show
the line well over here there's there's
Queen oh it's happening and the point is
happening the reason this stops Queen
takes A2 everyone is because now in this
move order you have Knight takes F6
check as a threat and if you save that
Bishop either with Tempo or not then
there's Queen D2 oh so Rook B2 comes
from nurmanoba but now you oh wait
I guess they can take the pawn
I guess that's risky
yeah what else was white supposed to do
by the way because if you played Rook C2
Queen takes E1 check you're actually
wait a second hold on that's kind of
strange maybe we're B1 that doesn't
really oh Rook B1 and queen D2 yeah
absolutely let's look at Rook B1 yeah I
think Rook B1 if Queen takes A2 Queen D2
pins the bishop
subtlety there man I love calculating
with no hands and you're in control the
less commentary I've done they take the
pressure off of me I just get to show up
make some bad jokes and get out of town
you know this is awesome I'm like say
something no hands in here I went on a
bike ride the other day and I rode with
no hands you ever do that it feels like
you're flying yeah I felt like you know
Leonardo DiCaprio was holding me I was
looking out over it was amazing wind in
your hair you know I didn't hit a rock
and like and then uh and then fly off
the bike and I do that in home chat
make sure you put your hands inside of
the vehicle at all times Chad yeah I
wasn't endorsing riding a bike with no
hands unless you're very experienced by
the way can black just take A2 what if I
just take that yes I was thinking the
same thing Queen A2 okay let's have
Queen A2 I wasn't gonna play Knight G5 I
mean this is an aggressive move I might
know I don't have this routine but
Knight G5 like seems right 85 or queen
C7 now you have Rook F7 so definitely a
knight G5 make you move the bishop
I don't have a follow-up yet I'm just
figuring out it seems like 95 should be
right maybe bishop
McQueen takes A2 is possible
I just feel like I got a funny idea I
got a funny idea lurkin something I feel
like I can say because I I'm not in
control of the mouse okay rookie eight
prevents it but I was looking at
something like G4 at some point for
white you track that Bishop on H3 now
Knight G5 is brutal 95 yeah right
beautiful so it's beautiful it doesn't
work here now if G4 black can take the
poem with the bishop and E4 Falls but
it's very it's very uh it's a spice you
know oh it's windy oh wait even here
Bishop B6 check and King G7 Queen E7 get
some get some oh wait yeah this is tough
this is tough to defend if you even you
can play G4 in this position this is a
very tough position for bikes to the
film practically engine obviously you
can do anything but this is practically
very hard to defend for the black pieces
but it is white to move now what is
block point I mean it actually is nice
um but let's see if I mean it's not very
obvious to play this you have to really
calculate here which Bach is very good
at doing G4
or I mean B4 is also a possibility
yeah I don't really have many moves in
fact G4 does plan out Knight G5 can't be
played because it takes G5 and I'm not
trying to trade the Queens what else
what other moves do we actually have but
you could you could you could play Queen
D2 because White's up a pawn last time I
did my math good and again you know how
I feel about math let's be honest but um
but I think you could play Queen D2 and
head to an end game with the pawn but
all right
he does it I I think so yeah I'm again
I'm feeling fresh today feeling feeling
lucky with no hands again shout out to
my boy speaking of feeling feeling
funky all right let's head back to the
bird's eye view
and uh and see because some other games
are also Rolling Along including
nakamura's battle versus theodoro we
have a king on D4 and he knows how to
use it ladies and gentlemen also another
Bishop versus night battle
the other games are closer
say have although starting to starting
to hit the gas
down against Alice Lee so I could be
either wave can'ty you're in charge
Federal save versus Alice Lee
because it's more action here in the
theodoro game and I think white actually
is pushing I mean he has his King he has
the king activity right which is huge
it's either gonna be like white winds or
Draw there unless there's some type of
huge funder
very often we're choosing games that
aren't hey Carlos but let's go to
Federal save Alice Lee she's a star oh
yeah everyone's like the starboard games
we like hey girl who's that yeah yeah
Alice yeah we know
well no I think you suffer from a little
Hikaru fatigue at a certain point
because you're like hey Carlos gonna win
like at the end of the day
photos save is trying to slow down the
train that is off the tracks known as
Alice
yeah after C4 she didn't take and then
takes allowing this this is uh wow look
at these pawns he's a very ferocious
player with tactics some of the tactics
I've seen that he puts on people are
pretty wicked it was really gross dude I
mean I mean this is crazy look at the I
mean we're talking dirty to me with
those pawns look at that peace sack I
mean by the way did you see that psac by
way Yi in the first match that is the
way you do it man that guy was a month
okay we're not talking about that match
but
um this this position right here you got
those Pawns in the center you're down a
piece but who cares
owie
yeah this is a I mean this is definitely
hard to face and I don't see seven here
it was a good Petrov too it just kind of
went wrong somewhere yeah
we talked about this A5 Bishop before
earlier it's a very common kind of thing
to do you want to extend and bind but
it's very mature you know the the old
school Soviet School of Chess photo save
is like yeah keep pushing keep pushing
and then as soon as I rebound you've got
positional weaknesses and it felt like
Alice Lee kind of overplayed her hand a
little bit there and now she might be
paying the price
85 okay we got some tactics I think we
just take on C8 first so
probably correct
yeah so so many moves here you take C8
you have to take back as the Queen's
hanging why and we have this bishop C4
snacks there's also a G4 here
there's
there's a G4 coming by the way that's a
great move G4 then Bishop C4 that Rook
yeah fall with gusto
G6 is probably a bishop C4 Bishop F7 she
somehow okay is still surviving there so
yours Bishop B5 understand look at that
it threatens Bishop D7
Queen C1 check who cares King H2
and yeah this is
the consequences of moving your f-pawn
somewhere in the world if you listen
closely you can hear Ben Feingold saying
always listen to Ben you know yelling at
people you move the F Pawn you get
punished and uh right now Alice Lee adds
the clock to her many problems she gets
down on time
it's not looking great but she also
loses very strong too as well like and
that's it's even crazy to say that like
she loses very strong like she's gonna
play still find some resources it's like
she's definitely a force to be reckoned
with Harry of course you're not looking
good this game here but I mean she is a
star we all know this for sure he's
strong it's not the game for her and
obviously feather save is able to take
this game or at least he's looking to
close it out honestly still a beach chat
still an absolute Beast
well and remember if you asked her to
start the day would you take half a
point versus the top two boards for the
knights they'd say they'd say a good job
youngster so I think exactly again I
think this one's going to go Federal
saves way hard to find a move for Alice
Lee
I'm just buying those other boards
hikaru's Edge has slipped at some point
we'll check in with that uh five in a
car one and we also haven't looked at
the whole time but kid off holding his
own against the top American player but
uh but okay
um although wait Hikaru who's higher
rated in classical right now Hikaru just
continues to be like oh yeah I'm not a
streamer remember how I almost won the
candidates exactly you must have played
for the world championship but I'm
almost yeah okay the federal save does
take this one down uh we see the big
fish gets a big dub for his Knights
um right now the night's proving a
little bit better than the Bishops shout
out to Alpha zero and the Google
deepmind team okay yeah let's back up
let's take a look at the other games
remaining um
I kind of want to check out karwana's
game versus vaquita off because it is uh
it's a big matchup but there's there's a
pass Pawn on E7 yet somehow black is
better going on what is going on over
there you gotta be kidding me man put
this on the screen right now everybody
guys what is that look at this game what
is that this is nonsense and it's like
almost equal it's almost they prefer
black by a little bit that's how you
know the conversation is real because
they only prefer black by a little bit
let me just how do we get we gotta see
how we go black is yeah we got to bring
up an analysis board black is up two
pieces
and only a little better
only a little better so even here he's
down at peace yeah right
I mean he sacked one wow Fabi just
didn't care about nothing Queen takes
green D5 first
bring the queen back okay brought the
knight in it's funny the computer's
gonna like the sack by the way just
didn't like D5 but continue it yeah
correct they didn't like D5 right here
E7 then he said give me those and then
he Stacks another piece like I mean come
on bro you're playing a GM you know that
right Bobby relax
doing with that second sack now that we
now that we're here we have full clarity
hindsight is 20 20. I think he thought
he's trying to bail I think he actually
knows how the ACT didn't work and he's
looking for a perpetual
and as we see in the live positions
wants more he's trying to run the king
out but kid off wants the whole thing
not just a piece Bob Barker I'll take 56
and raise you one Rook seat three bro
this is crazy you can't take it but you
can take it with the queen but then oh
my goodness this is crazy Danny what is
going on Danville man talk to me baby uh
dude I'm I'm right there with you I wish
we had a super Grand Master I don't know
maybe a former world champion twist
ending he might be joining us in a in a
bit that's right wow stay tuned um
because I don't know how to answer this
Rook to E3 is a check but the king would
run so Fabi plays the sort of confusing
move right add some smoke and mirrors to
your problems
um
this is a Wicked Game Boy because roofie
three is a nasty check
that's a nasty check and he really has
to figure out what to do
rookie three is nasty then I take I get
the piece back and then I'm cool I am on
that one piece all these pawns yeah I'm
probably winning but you can't get back
made it in the process right I mean you
gotta do something about that guy yeah
yeah okay we're checking out king D7
that's just like very calm move wow it's
very last in the face of danger of B4
you know why because he is maybe he has
Queen E4 no Queen E4 rookie three in the
queen Falls so yeah Bobby says Bobby
says what you doing here comes before
Queen E4 there's rookie three
um wow
this is crazy and probably I mean this
is uh this is they only give it one
point Advantage now to Black and
actually as it thinks wow that's crazy
I'm up two pieces and it's like yeah
it's probably close to equal well I
don't understand how huge this moment is
regardless of who wins the match these
came the early games count for just as
many points as the games at the end and
so if a kid off getting an upset against
carwana would not be held the bishop
scripted it this is this is a huge
moment for St Louis Bobby has got to
come up with something he freezes back
rank
keeps the pressure on
is very stoic like yo this check would
have been played so fast in many cases
we're keen to do seven and you got the
back rank problems he's so annoyed by
that so he plays the G3 move to stop it
it's a super good lesson in discipline
right because when you're panicked you
play the check that feels like the
obvious move when strong players really
understand candy like the best way to
solve a problem is often to make it
bigger right and when you have an
opponent who's feeling the pressure you
have to create more opportunities for
them to go wrong and when you when you
play the forcing move don't be surprised
when the fish kind of slips off the hook
right so yeah obviously with best play
Black is okay here but I G3 is just like
right screw it into the square here so
he knows you meant it I meant to play
that move right boom Twisted for 360
motion all the way around and then hit
the clock like sir like I'm still
twisting as I'm hitting the clock with
my elbow that's how much I mean it
G3 right hit the clock with the elbow
chat you know what I mean it's one of
those and he takes on E7 yeah he's
giving back C5 they gave it back but
this is equal this gotta be at least the
draw at least to draw
you gotta like how Fabi kept with it by
the way speaking of draws it looks like
theodoro is not only going to hold
against zacaro but he's the one pushing
uh I'll be back to the bird's eye view
because we got to look at all the games
and all the pressure yeah that's a
little bit very important very very
important that game and that's down to
seconds that may end in the draw it may
in this draw because of the seconds it
should end at a draw Remember The Rook
at night do not actually beat The Rook
theoretically for those wondering Rook
at night is not a forced win against the
rook and it's also even less of a
practical win than the rook and Bishop
but but okay that's still a big a big
game for Theodore to draw Hikaru with
black
that's true
with two draws in a row wow yep the one
game that seems to be going clearly The
Bishop's way is Benjamin Bach over alua
normanova
yeah that's where you want to go oh man
we got red everywhere right like I see I
see red people thank you Haley Joel
Osmond what happened to your career I
see red people
yeah and the bot game actually looks
like it's it's a little Haywire but it's
really I gotta say this Bobby game
because there's just the movie okay yeah
let's stay with the father
again it's all good
remember you can follow games at
chess.com events you see that URL in the
right corner it's not just for looks you
can head over to there and follow the
games if you ever don't like the
adventure as we choose it but we're
going to stay right here with car one of
a keyed off
a king on D5
wowzers oh he's holding oh minus 11.
whoa
Bishop Bishop takes it too oh my
goodness we can't take
oh my gosh
what a game for the knights and vaquita
takes down Fabiano caruana with the
black pieces no less can he highlighting
it well GM Hess in the chat this is one
of the craziest games I've ever seen
you can't spell chess without Hess
that's one of the craziest comments I've
ever seen from you Hess not insulting me
what's wrong with you okay we gotta
quickly back up we have another game
going because and and by the way
obviously it shouldn't be a draw but
whenever there's time pressure involved
blunders do happen Nakamura still has to
hold against the adoro it's not over yet
yep let's do it Hikaru
versus theodoro theodoro trying to get a
dub what a huge win that would be for
the Bishops
that's so crazy because like
I rarely ever see this as a win I mean
it's like you really have to try hard to
lose this game you have to try to lose
it you know what I mean this one is
always like it's raw
it should be but it just stranger things
have happened right I mean you've got
time pressure you never know
we see we see a nice little rundown of
the current performance for the
archbishops and finally finally it does
indeed end in a draw and if you're
wondering why the auto draw was claimed
by the server that's because 50 moves
was reached so Hikaru held this end game
for enough time to reach the theoretical
50 move draw as the rules of Chess
dictate Canty
yeah that's uh that is 50 moves and of
course nothing crazy happened usually
you'll see more in the bishop and Rook
versus Rook King and King um we're Kings
will you'll see like the bishop Prevail
but the night one's just much harder to
do right so well as we see here
Hikaru gives up the draw with white
against theodoro but it doesn't matter
because his Knights got the job done in
that second set of games look at that
look at that double picket fence there
with fedo save and vaquita for two and
three respectively taken down Alice Lee
and Fabiano caruana that was enough for
the knights to jump out and take the
lead in this match with a 3-1 score in
the round two set of games Canty yeah
those tricky ponies is what they say
right the octopus and you put it in the
middle of the board and it can just hit
all eight areas you get two of them but
then you forgot about these other two
points that they had that slip in this
last round here it's very tough it's
very hard of course it has a lot of
Chess left first eight and a half wins
the match so they are behind Now by two
but there's still a lot of chests left
for sure well you mentioned it's first
eight and a half so let's remind
everybody of where the overall match
score sits as we said the knights took
down that round by a score of three to
one that gives them a two-point lead in
the overall match score five to three
wow again we're gonna be talking about
that but keyed off Victory with the
black pieces over the Bishops if they do
ultimately go home if Knights proved
Superior
deepmind project wins Canty
right the my project wins of course nice
versus Bishop chat as we are still about
it because it is the match of the year
in fact Knights versus Bishops of course
you're just getting here put that in the
chat who do you prefer what do you
prefer Knights or Bishops
I love it I love it and again do you
prefer no Castle Chef shout out to
kromnik in that whole report but all
right we gotta give a shout out right
now to a big event that's coming up if
you watched it last year you know it and
you love it it's the chess kid stars
versus streamers and it is back in the
first event chess kid stars took down
their streamer opponents now Anna
krambling and Eric Rosen are back with a
vengeance joining them are Levy Rosman
and archers Nixon's the Stars it's an
impressive lineup but the chess kit team
is insanely strong PCL star Alice Lee
Brewington Hardaway Tony arawami Megan
paragua this is gonna be a thriller mark
your calendars now and don't miss the
chess kid stars versus streamers rematch
it's Sunday May 14th at 1 pm Pacific
time and that is Vladimir ferrose of the
big fish as he gets set for the next set
of games we we get set for our break he
uh he's gonna sit there feeling good
about his victory and we are going to
come right back and see you in just a
few
foreign
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
goodness chat so good to have you back
PCL the St Louis Archbishop returning to
the pro chess League playoffs let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh 100 000
up for grass
the quarterfinals of the pro chess
League playoffs have finally arrived
we win oh my God the PCL is here to stay
who will be crowned its next champion
and we are back and there is a man who's
looking to bounce back while his team is
leading he started off with a couple of
slow draws you recognize that face
that's a coronakamura number one steamer
number one player in many ways and many
time controls and uh
he wants to write the ship today but
candy he's got quite the pedigree so we
expect him to do it take us through a
little bit of those career highlights of
the five time and reigning speech has
Champion well first thing it says up
there is half man half unidentified
object because we don't understand
sometimes how he does things in this
chess game and then number two is
reigning five-time speech has Champion
five-time U.S Champion we're official
random Champion he's a world champion
right you have to put that on his name
of course number five feed a world
ranking streamer first he says 10-0 and
1 here in the 2023 PCO regular season
only losing one game which was actually
the first game that he played which is
interesting enough only one person was
able to take it down that was a
Pioneers anymore but she won of course
right so amazing for me Cairo Big Stuff
of course is he leads the Gotham Knights
trying to uh win and close this thing
out
honestly you said it well you know his
mindset we joke about the literally
don't care comment but he's relaxed he's
enjoyed chess more than ever over the
last couple years he said so himself
with the streaming it's just incredible
to see him do what he does all the time
and right now he needs to he needs to do
some of that right to help his team
maintain the lead uh let's talk about it
they're up five to three currently in
the match score maybe he doesn't maybe
sometimes you uh you show up and your
teammates carry you but I'm gonna guess
Hikaru is going to need to be hikara
before all is said and done if the
knights are gonna hold on to their lead
over the Bishops can't he absolutely of
course Hikaru is gonna just keep keep
playing right you know of course what he
just says literally don't care or just
like play chess I'm a streamer first
right you know all of this stuff so that
pressure is off but also the pressure is
still on as you do have to perform here
right so if we have kikaru does what he
usually does he wins the next two games
that'll be great for the knights but I
mean he didn't beat Dallas right he
didn't beat theodoro here so he's and
then he got Fabi and box deals so these
are like sure you know oh these would be
easier these aren't easy at all so of
course if Favi and Bot can hold there
and also do something on the other
boards I mean this could this is
definitely still uh in the in the works
for the Bishops too as well even being
well you mentioned he's got Fabi and
Bach left let's take that cue and peek
at our lineups as we head into the third
set of games Bach goes first of those
two players you listed is reverse order
with Hikaru taking on the black pieces
there and then you have carwana get
white against Federal save we get closer
and closer to even rating matchups as
the pro chess League format rolls on you
know it you love it and so these
matchups just continue to get even
tighter even bigger let's also point out
that the knights are a big round away
from actually winning three and a half
points gets it done now we don't
necessarily expect three and a half out
of four that guy would uh would have
something to say about that he's not
going to let the knights walk all over
him in this next game Canty absolutely I
mean he's ready to go you know Bach is
in the zone there and it's not he's very
serious because guys he don't have the
microwave with him we know him for the
microwave always behind him and it's
nowhere to be found right now it seems
like he's like yo somebody at the door
right now I'm trying to play chess like
he's actually uh you know absolute Beast
maybe he got a message from the team
that says hey make sure we can see
everything they're always working hard
not hardly working shout out to
everybody behind the scenes who makes
these things possible our broadcast crew
our game Ops crew Our Fair Play crew we
love you guys so much everybody is
crushing it and uh on that note I think
we're about to crush ourselves another
round here because it is game time
Benjamin Bach with the white pieces
against Hikaru Nakamura that's coming up
service well Canty what opening you
think we're gonna see you know I think
he's gonna he likes to play Catalan he
he definitely a Catalan player so let's
see what he plays and he went D4 okay it
still can be counted and like so anyone
Queens game what's this nibs of course
man you know this is just chessable
promo right here just like hey in case
you missed it I released a course on the
NIMS on chessable now Danny and Canty
have no choice but to talk about it and
uh and there you go these moves out too
hey I mean bro hey relax guys hey Jay we
trying to do this commentary here
this is Theory we have seen Hikaru
played so well I I feel like I've seen
him play this position for both sides
against so many people battles against
Jeffrey Jean come to mind uh vladislav
artemia there's so many games I can't
even can't even name it all but I know
this is Theory Hikaru knows well but Bob
not afraid of jumping into The Fray
absolutely not in fact I'm a fan of me
this is a strange movement H4 I'm just a
big fan of this type of creativity H4 H5
Rook H3 Rook G3 you develop this way of
course we can figure out what to do with
the bishop later too but I mean hey
kingside is damaged so why not attack on
that side obviously Bach is very
principled but he's also very strong
with tactics but very principle I like
the D5 move here he takes it's C5 look
at this Theory bro like Queen was
hanging like instant chest this is I
swear we saw a game in the cgc
quarterfinals in Toronto in this line
where Hikaru was black and I again
um often often rely on others to jog my
memory I'm getting old Canty but
nobody's in this position
the last time I commentated for Hikaru
but okay um maybe not this exact line
but something close to it and you see
the blitz is on
this is the blitz are thrown down
against the yogis Manana but this is
Blitz chess for both these guys right
here I mean absolutely I mean they start
thinking now this is move 16 already
like not only gonna start thinking and
of course it wasn't maybe not even now
because if it rotates you have to put
our King takes took the Rook here kings
in the center what a game this is
definitely Dynamic for sure and what do
I do with my king I'm not gonna sit here
forever bro we're gonna be kingy two the
car offered to draw oh wow a car also to
draw and he just Mark was like all right
cool it is what it is that's a win it's
a win in my book you know they just took
a draw they took a draw they out of
there you want to draw bro oh for sure
absolutely now you know go get my frames
go to Kinkos and get my little about to
frame it you know that's how you do it
every time you get a job where you
covered but uh you know that is
interesting I'm surprised by how quickly
the game ended I was pulling up you know
pulling up YouTube or twitch chat here
thought I had a moment to breathe turns
out I don't uh apologies for that but I
I guess I'm I'm both surprised and I'm
also
I'm kind of impressed by by Hikaru who's
had a slow day he's had a couple of
draws against low-rate opponents but he
doesn't let that make him feel frazzled
that he that he needs to over push and
he's like look I'm on I'm on the black
side of a nimzo here I know Bach knows
these positions well I'm gonna accept
that it's a half point it's just strange
to me I mean is that good Mass strategy
he because he's protecting his leads so
part of me is like wow his team is
leading I'm gonna play for the mature
result where even though I'm frustrated
with my first two games I'm not going to
let it get the better of me or maybe he
has to push I don't know what we're
going to end up looking at at the end of
this match I think that was actually a
good team player method there from
hecarly he just picked a draw I mean I'm
up we up I'm gonna let you guys do your
work I trust the team is what he says I
trust the team we're up here it's very
strong okay cool you know what we'll
take the draw and we'll go into it and
maybe I'll push if I get the chances
with the white pieces in the last round
so yeah very very nice I think that was
a good boxes it's absolutely strong so
you can draw is what it is get out of
there we still have a half point we're
still two points up
yep well and we're going to move on and
I think we'll head over to Alice Lee the
star of the Dave Akita with the white
pieces against Alice Lee uh what are the
stars of the day we should we should
give Equal Credit there but I'm sitting
here I mean the initial Instinct you
have as a commentator when a top player
takes a draw is to kind of be critical
I'm not gonna lie it's kind of what you
do you're like ah like what's going on
but then I'm sitting here like
recognizing the frustration nicaro
probably feels after the first two games
but knowing his team is leading there's
there's a there's a maturity to that
draw because you get yourself that much
closer it's a team game in the PCL and
all you need is eight and a half points
he didn't want to overpress and maybe
blow the lead by losing to Buck with
black 100 I mean interesting I don't
know it is very interesting no you
you're correct the folks a lot of times
emotions uh in chess not even chest but
in life like making emotional based
decisions it could be good it could be
bad right so emotions he probably oh hey
you know what I've drew the first two I
want to really crash back which is just
not a thing you can just Crush back
right so if you want to go in here and
play and okay we got to draw it is what
it is it favors us it's a team game and
we're gonna you know see what chances we
get in the last round with white so I
think that was a very smart decision for
me a car over there and hopefully it
doesn't backfire because if his team
loses his liking he's like I shouldn't
have took the draw but I mean it was it
was a smart decision I think overall but
he still has to place him with white in
the last round
I tend to agree this has baked off
playing White against Alice Lee for
those wondering it's not a camera issue
he just loves playing in the dark let's
back up and look at the bird's eye view
vakino is like I prefer the lights off
he's like you have approached the
darkness I was born in it Batman okay
which do you prefer nights before
Bishops
um the uh
the anyway so vaquita prefer in the
darkness over there like his man Bane
we've got another game we need to prefer
right now and I think that's car Juana
fedo save that's another board one
versus Board two battle if you don't
mind if you don't mind all right
um yeah that's a great game let's see
what this was in English reversed
okay oh it says reverse Sicilian oh
that's what this was okay so if we have
an English which move is it it is fabi's
move it's just Bishop B2 is a natural
move I'm a fan of the Knight F3 B3 setup
so always open position 1 B2 I mean it's
definitely a move and get all the bishop
that's what we want it for but he is in
the think tank so I'm curious to see
what else he's thinking about maybe a C5
lock it up
Bishop B2
we'll see
I like I like the big Center and I like
the big Queen side for fobby but super
solid for black you know you've got
these these pieces kind of spying a
chance to bust to bust out right for a
track to explode on the bishop on A7 the
queen on F6 watch out for a sneaky a
file to open up right with those pawns
and the tension on A5 and B4 so
close to equal for a reason thanks
Captain Obvious We Appreciate You eval
bar yeah thanks right exactly oh man
these guys
eval bars Queen C2 interesting okay what
is the plan what are we gonna do next
and just move the queen out the back
rank right Bishop D2 or B2 trying to see
what you're doing here this is gonna be
a level they're going to be here a while
I think they're gonna leave for a while
right so anyway look at the bird's eye
view see if there's anything else out
there yeah let's do it you're right yeah
it's gonna be a longer
anything wild
that Nicholas Theodore game look at this
what is that
with you let's do it what are they doing
over there Irma Nova versus theodoro
who's better and why
the opponent A5 is holding back the the
backward B7 Pawn but black
black has uh the space advantage on the
king side but those are pawns that came
back up I'm not gonna lie I look at this
position and I feel like there's
something I'm missing because material
is equal
yet the computer likes black by almost a
full point despite black having
overextended the king side pawns right
there's something that does not compute
about this position for me yeah it's
more I guess some calculation work I
think also overall okay D5 is weak A5 is
weak but when we have G5 but G5 isn't
that weak we can't just play H6 really
strongly I mean C4 okay these pawns are
weak for sure but I also have my own
fair share like a weak pawns 2 as well I
mean this is definitely not as much of
an advantage that I think that the event
that the engine has oh now it says 0.9
after Bishop D3 this is annoying like it
takes Queen G7 G4 at some point stress
the compositions when you do have this
type of space is nice but it also is
risky yeah
is a little bit of an offer for an Ops
Code Bishop position if the trade on D4
is followed by Bishop takes F5 and here
we go okay and it's happening right
instead we have a rook ending this I
mean I think it's equal practically like
you have weaknesses I have weaknesses
right so yeah an engine takes two as
well now it's about level but the
further this game goes on that trade I I
agree with the email bar and I'll add my
my own human weak understanding right
forgive me for translating the engine
but to me as as the pieces are traded
you regret those pawns extended in front
of your king a little bit because now
it's just kind of open left and error
and you're not really going to launch a
Checkmate attack every Pawn you push
from here on out for black you're making
your king just as weak whereas white has
a very safe majority to advance over
there on the queen side four versus
three with D5 C4 b2a5 and in this kind
of Pawn majority yes exactly is Candy's
highlighting eventually you get C5 okay
wow but F3 holy but Geezer snaps all in
oh man it is he's awesome I like white I
like just play G3 it's a bit of a bluff
I think I think you play G3 that F Pawn
could wander too far
and again I I I I feel like that major
wow she takes it the majority on the
queen side is gonna favor white but now
the now the king is open
just attack the weak Pawn that is there
that we highlighted earlier it is a weak
Pawn now of course H6 defends it I mean
now both kings are weak there are
tactics here yep guys there are some
real attacks Rick have two actually
threatens queen of three and mate and be
very careful there's also the Rook H2
and some possibilities we get the other
Rook to the file who's actually winning
we don't know there's a lot going on
this is a double X position for sure
a great town man
um
if I'm white I I don't know whether I
want to play moves like rookie one or
even even like Rook G2 and kind of beta
trade just to like get my pieces over
there to defend or if I if I laugh in
the face of danger somehow and and play
B4 C5
that's too dangerous man just like not
caring literally don't care B4 and C5 is
like crazy Richie too
yeah
you invite this Rook F1 don't play Rook
G1 after Rook F1 LOL if you want to show
that
LOL translates to laughing out loud for
those who don't you know know that
they're like uh LOL
yeah
okay yeah this is the line we thought
Queen takes C4
am I crazy or is Rook takes G5 a
Perpetual job correct check and if you
don't take well
uh
check okay I was thinking because the
king gets all the way I have no idea
exactly right let me take C forward to
your G5 takes King F6 Queen check King
E8 check there check King C let's show
it we got analysis board we might as
well do it I mean we we might as well
show I mean queen takes C4 Brook takes
G5 check HG yeah it is a draw you check
you check
The King The King can run to C8 oh this
is winning okay then it's too far by the
way the key we should show the key is
you can't check on f8 and take the Rook
because Queen F1 is Checkmate for black
at the end of that line that's the
reason absolutely this is why we're not
doing it right check and here it
obviously takes no but then then they
get it yeah yeah Queen's Queen to F1 so
what is the draw right where's the draw
that's what I'm trying to figure out
here too so this is all zero so is it
here
oh
it's not it's not here either what is
this raw oh man that's tough okay hold
on it's tough you need six no Queen E6 I
think Queen E6 is still a draw and after
28 you just can't take D6 you have to go
back to F6 oh my goodness if King C7
Queen E7 and you stay on the dark
squares this is the idea wow this is not
human
this is not human what a draw bro block
and if King A7 you have Queen to B6
check
what in the world
oh get out of here Queen F2 bro
yeah nobody finding this nobody find
this B6 dude a B6 you take and queen of
seven what up
oh my God okay this is like dude you
know what's crazy you wanna know what's
crazy is that whole thing was a ton of
fun for us and that is ultimately what
it's about commentators having fun but
there's a legit chance this happens like
there's a reason Theodora was thinking
you see that head in hand everybody look
at the live position below us they're
looking at this line they're theodoro
was like can I take that pawn that's
legit asking yeah can I take it can I
take C4 with the queen I have never seen
that type of draw in my life and he goes
he does I have never seen that draw in
my entire life wow what's funny what's
funny everyone is as wild as that is
Norma Nova has to go for that or she's
just down upon like and D5 is falling
yeah and D5 is falling exactly is you
have to go over G5 and trust that it's a
draw but the problem is I mean queen D6
is such a move that a human will do oh
my goodness you can't take it you gotta
play Queen episode yeah you have to use
your okay you gotta use your time here
how much time she got six minutes so
she's calculating it man that's some
spice baby
if that happens this will be the game of
the match that might ultimately prove uh
to be why the knights eliminate the
Bishops I'm not kidding I mean this is
like if she finds this draw knowing that
they are up right now five and a half
three and a half you can see the score
below the board everybody looking at the
other games vaquita looks like he's
going to get the job done against young
Alice Lee so if she finds this to Raw
this literally puts the Bishops up
against the wall again as you see there
vakidov pressing that Bishop on F6 is
not something Alice Lee is happy about
and okay car wanna fetus still have a
lot to go but but if she finds that draw
candy I might I might just walk out
we both just get up we're just gonna get
up we're gonna walk away and then you
know we'll keep you know producers can
click and switch the scenes and then you
know they can go to the games right so
if you know commentators for the rest of
the day
man will she find it I see a roof garage
talking about it in twitch chat shout
out to everyone who's playing along with
us featuring you throughout the day
we're having fun I hope you are too
we got a long weekend ahead candy we got
before chess League playoffs all weekend
boys and girls right up to the finals
baby right playoffs and some stuff we're
at work and chat hope you're having a
good day Knights versus Bishop who do
you have if you're new here welcome guys
who do you have we got Knights versus
Bishops who do you choose and what piece
do you choose night or Vision we had a
poll earlier I think it was Knights by
the way that got these nights from Chad
nice it was nice it was 66 9 34
wow yeah we uh it's like I don't care
nothing about my Bishops I love all the
nights yeah so
thank you for Chad who played along nice
737 votes 66 for the knights and right
now they're both favoring the knights on
the board and off the board apparently
um
oh yeah she's definitely looking she's
like We're G5 takes takes but she's
trying to find that draw trying to find
that draw and queen D6 if she plays
Queen D6 we understand like it's hard to
see
um luckily I mean we that was our first
choice and it didn't work and we found
why then we went back and worked it but
you don't have that luxury of going back
after Queen D6 it's over if you take so
she has to find Queen F6 which is I mean
literally puzzle rushed like like his
study like in a way Queen F6 is the only
way to draw when you reach that position
it's insane
you probably want a boy come on girl
what you guys
he's got to take it and theodoro is
definitely Gonna Take It
does he have King h a wait a second here
maybe considering it
h8 is that a mole
yeah because I I was like I was trying
to see I was like I don't see a
follow-up that is that strong for white
I mean okay you have this maybe King oh
that loses right so this was my idea was
trying to you know stay around this Pond
right so this immediately wins so he
might go for this because it gives
chances it gives chances taking but you
do have to trust that she will find
Queen F6 or she won't find me six I'll
take on these like the psychology here
is crazy he's raising his eyebrows
because it wouldn't be held against him
if he calculated let's show the line
because we've got the analysis board up
show it again in case anyone just tuned
in if hg5 Queen G5 king f8 queen F6 King
E8 Queen E6 it's possible he went for
this and also just kind of looked at
Queen takes D6 it seems natural yeah and
King C8 go ahead and do it and just like
that black is winning and the reason is
you get out of the perpetual and you
can't take the Rook on Aid at the end
because black checkmates white on F1
so this is either way this one's
actually it's raw here
is winning yeah it wouldn't be held
against the adoro if he kind of like
thought ah that you can't go for this
Rook takes G5 but now show the line why
it's a draw right if HG Queen G5
in the end of that line instead of
taking on D6 you go back to F6 and play
a little tickle on the dark squares King
C7 queenies or if you go there we're on
the light squares and if you go to C7 we
go to E7 and how insane is this King I
want to show King B8 Queen d8
oh sorry or this way for no yeah or this
way first you go queen f8 queen f8 and
then at the end even B6 isn't a win like
I've never seen anything like this man
like
even even that way it works because
black can just play King A7 instead of
instead of uh Queen C8 so it takes D6 it
takes DC C7 queen of face yeah fake in
here
and then B6 takes takes this is the
craziest thing ever still a draw bro
that is the sickest job ever seen I've
never seen a Perpetual in this way and
let's see what he plays in fact he has
he plays King h8 he didn't want to go
for it he plays King h8 and Rook back to
G2 wow that was the sickest thing ever
bro what a draw that was but King h8 was
played and now Rook back to G2 so let me
just take the second part or like yeah
let's take this
wow Enduro on the move
okay I'm not surprised and no judgments
there King h8 taking G5 was too spicy
let's go back to the bird's eye view
anyway
yeah we were so focused on this but
vaquita does indeed take down Alice Lee
this incredible draw held our attention
for good reason but with that win the
knights get even closer now you see it's
six and a half three and a half in favor
of Gotham right now that's right yeah
only two more and they are punching
their ticket and sending the Bishops
home and the debate oh wait he settled
uh-oh speaking of only two more what we
got an evil bar slippage black has taken
over in the game between carwana and
ferozea we have to go to there okay
let's just go to there what is going on
a blunder from Fabian just the last move
actually let's actually see what that
was everything was um
smooth here he plays okay so the move
was Knight A4 and Bishop A1 is
apparently just a huge blunder but why
oh Bishop okay and then we move the
queen and what's so bad about this right
now
yeah that's uh wow that's actually
interesting what is so bad about this
maybe bishop F3
something like that there's something
wrong
something wrong
yeah what is going on he's up
no materials equal
but the queen has no squares to continue
guarding the F3 Knight yeah I think
that's the only thing after Queenie won
Bishop F3 and I guess I'm just literally
better like I'm just better I get I
guess I get Queen G5 in and I know you
forever
let's let's back up a move and see where
did fobby blunder this position was was
I guess he was supposed to take this
Knight maybe it's just not a move it's
appealing but you might just have to
take it
foreign
classes permanent form is temporary but
of the form between these two guys
Federal save is is seems to be playing a
slightly sharper brand of Chess today
right he took down Alice Lee this game
before here in a great spot with the
black pieces against Fabiano caruana
this is this happens right even to the
best of them and if Bobby doesn't have
his best chest the Bishops leaned so
hard on him all season their run might
be about to come to close which by the
way we haven't talked too much about how
impressive it's been for those who
followed the whole season the bishop
started out oh and two before winning
every match since so you really have to
give the Bishops credit for being here
but right now they are up against the
wall and their protest league title
hopes might be about to come to a close
if Fabiana goes down here yeah there is
a lot of a lot of pressure and in fact
that's exactly what happened here after
this Queenie moment if we go back here
Queenie one did happen they should have
three damage the structure this is why
this is not the greatest for white yeah
this is expect to see foreign
I want my pony on it also talk about F4
oh man if you like it you better put a
pony on it I'm loving it for black if
you like it you better put a pony on it
right hey thanks for the primary plumber
wins appreciate you Frank yeah Bishop D4
is very strong obviously enough to take
some you got Knight D4 Knight F3 I mean
look at this Fork like he's like yeah
this is why we like Knights good nights
yeah flexing for the nights right
everything nice have a good night
you're saying having a good night you
know there's there's a lot of good
things happening for the nights and
another thing to add to it is uh
Fabiano's time it's also indicative of
when usually someone is all form you can
just see them under time pressure not
feeling comfortable with their own
calculation and uh this does not look
good for Mr carwana absolutely not after
34 take say we have a trade and look at
the night these nights my goodness but
of course it's not attacking F3 anymore
so he's able to move away
still winning definitely for black I
mean all the dark squares are gross for
white wait oh man it almost works this
is
yucky dark Square problems right it
takes a five
Knight takes F3 Jeff looks tasty indeed
by the way Rook to see I was about to
say Rook C8 looks so good just pinned
the bishop Rook to A4 this stinks for
carvana before wait oh wait I'm good why
did he do that
oh my God it's the time
he ain't got no dude
at five and we live you got to right but
dude the turnaround Rook B4
yeah Rick before and I guess he just
missed that Queen G3 and we defeated can
we take C4 oh my gosh
F6 what a move oh it blunders Knight F3
is GG get him off the board
two grabs the bit oh you're right but 90
okay but g7's mate G7 is made so don't
blunder that yeah I saw can you have one
here and it doesn't work it doesn't work
in each one but
that's it I get made it check key two
you wanna take a draw maybe Queen E3 oh
he plays it he's playing for a win he's
playing for you yeah in the night's
hanging at the end of the line the
Knight has no defense I take the knights
hold on this is getting ready
takes takes takes takes takes and shake
hands
wow shake hands if Bobby dude if Bobby
holds this draw what a what a what a win
metaphorically it is
oh my God white was winning
white was winning on Queen D3 check 93
was GG bro it'll say it misses it wow
that was a win Queen D3 takes and pushed
Deva rescue getting him off the board
yeah the a-pawn would have ran what a
huge moment for the knights
jeez
on the edge of these seats here wow
by the way normanova and theodoro are
also still playing also under mutual
time pressure but we have to focus right
here uh
holding
yeah everybody calm down and breathe
everybody calm down calm down and
breathe God you sound like my therapist
right now
oh wait a second speaking of therapy
queen beat me
I'm gonna need therapy oh my gosh
keep on runs wow
this isn't an easy win oh man he was
holding
oh dude
just don't play F3 oh he plays A4 first
and that's enough now King F5 and it's
Rover Red Rover Red Rover send Fabiano
caruana right over and the Knights
the night oh my goodness guys oh man
king of four and you can resign or A7
actually yeah right seven am that was a
sick game
wow topsychology
moment
bro
what a heartbreaking moment for Fabiano
caruana he doesn't even want to sit down
he doesn't even want to sit down and be
on camera oh my gosh we saw the other
game I thought it would have ended a
draw by now but dude with that win
the knights are in Striking Distance to
finish this thing in regulation right
before regulation let's head over to
Norma Nova's game with theodoro
yeah where he's at there we go got it
yeah as much as I wanna as much as I
wanna sit here and
just feel the Heartbreak for car wanna
this is uh
we don't have time to do that
yeah look at the pressure
yeah the score is seven and a half four
and a half now in favor of the knights I
believe after that victory
um no probably one but the uh probably
won that probably was white but the Rook
ending is likely going to be a draw so
okay I think no matter what we're gonna
have we're gonna have action in round
four I I don't think normanova gets a
dub here is white yeah at all here it's
definitely difficult yeah this is three
seconds too I mean this is very holdable
you just Shuffle the roof back and forth
wait a second you're going for more
they want to make it interesting okay
all right don't hate okay yeah
definitely definitely
yeah it's it's a rook uh check was kind
of an odd Choice Rook V6 was definitely
the
the better choice Here Comes A5 I mean
this is
this is still uh still a draw but uh you
know
got a little spicier there
and move the King around yeah this is a
I mean yeah hopefully there's nothing
crazy that happens H5 interesting okay I
mean it doesn't matter how you do it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
yeah
five takes wait hold on okay nice there
you go there you go it'll do nothing
crazy here nothing crazy a great job let
me see Drew Theodore like the door is an
absolute Beast yeah
yeah draw a champ
draw Town night's moving closer to
Victory town it's a good place to live
out here
with that uh with that draw
theoduro knows that his Bishops are up
against the wall not the result he hoped
for given that he was favored the last
time he actually will be favored
in this particular uh matchup his next
game going straight up against vakidov
but okay I gotta Catch My Breath man
just absolutely crazy man yeah
and uh let's bring up the scores from
that round
three in the books it is a 2-2 tie
despite lots of decisive results lots of
drama uh Federal save actually beat
Fabiano caruana so we'll get that thing
flipped around
um but uh and it was yeah it was
actually a 3-1 victory for the Gotham
knights in that room
the uh
the result no no the federal state did
win that game and um okay we'll we'll
come back to that but yeah it's a it's a
big it's a big opportunity right now for
the Gotham Knights they are this close
Canty to punching their ticket to the
semifinals they are very close sat in
fact wow I mean it's very close matches
right 2-2 in his last match up here but
of course look they real close real
close guys so nice versus Bishops is not
over for the Bishops yet so of course uh
we're gonna keep talking it's not over
yet it's over
I don't know
wait wait Fabiano won that game on Time
wait what happened in that Bobby playing
White
why am I so confused right now
Fabi was white and he won the game
actually won that that was fine I am so
sorry I lost my mind on that I thought
the Swindle was the other way I am out
of my mind right now 100 my fault I was
so confused by that scramble there
oh yeah in fact it's very confusing
because of what was going on and the
energy and what and the game was wild it
was blunders everywhere of course it was
so much blundering like in in the eval
bar repping itself up and down that we
got confused we all did
absolutely well you know Fabi was under
pressure the whole time and and federal
save was winning and then I lost my hat
I lost my hat I should have had a
calculation over everything hat on and
everything would have been okay right
now that's right but there you go the
score is indeed correct as you saw seven
seven to five excuse me in favor of the
night so the Bishops are still within
Striking Distance what do they have to
do in round four to get this done
yeah they have to this is everything
everything's on the line right now of
course just honestly play like if you
think about that oh this is the last
round we could you're already in the
wrong direction you got to say hey I
gotta come out here I gotta play we play
our best game and we'll see what happens
we learned that from you Carl of course
one of the best to say it but just come
out here and play and see what happens
hopefully yeah and by the way we've seen
bigger comebacks than two games like not
even close right we've seen bigger
comebacks for cancer you should have
yelled at me when I was saying fobby
lost man I don't even know you got to
say Danny what are you doing man
the uh all right well we've got a round
four and we've got an epic match up
ahead Omega Lola is hopefully someone
clipped every moment of Danny's Gaff
there that was fun
um and we're gonna we're gonna take take
a break when we come back it is going to
be the last set of games round four in
our second quarter-final matchup of the
day can Nicholas theodoro help the
bishops get it done don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
foreign
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiana carwana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James we're gonna see who recognizes
these guys out of the out of the random
passerbys and we're gonna ask them some
fun questions about Chess for five bucks
do you know who this is
no okay active an actor well you see
this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right it goes by
75. you want to play chess okay so what
is he a player or something obsessed
he is a chess player I'm not but he is
yeah I play on the side yeah I've been
taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster Canty over here recently
over here calculation over everything
what's your name again sir uh my name is
Jamie what's your name
I already know it it's uh it's Daniel
yeah Daniel nerdinsky okay
there it is come on on the attack baby
on the attack if he wins I know the guys
at chess.com we'll get him a diamond
membership okay do you know what that is
yes okay is that something you want yes
yeah okay look at you look is this a
London yo we got a pro here with the
London
how'd it go
I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL just YouTube
actually don't remember
that look at the pot
[Music]
foreign
will get the white pieces versus Fabiano
caruana in this last round battle
between the Gotham Knights and the
archbishops what will he do
what's HE capable of here in this
scenario will you go for the win chat
thinks so 64 say so 36 percent say easy
draw
candy Let's uh let's pull up Hikaru
Nakamura and the Gotham Knights get a
quick look at their lineup uh and ask
ourselves whether Hikaru nakamura's
undefeated streak we'll continue we uh
we know that he's got a big match up
here against Fabiano caruana that's a
guy who can take him down and uh your
thoughts on what what Hikaru is thinking
right now yeah of course with uh Hikaru
uh he he's just gonna play his game you
know he also is a team player as we saw
in that last round he took that quick
draw so because he took that quick drop
me he's a team player if I take another
quick draw cool we're like at seven and
a half we need actually one more point
and that's game over out of three you
know games here right so this is the
most evenly matched up here so of course
if we got some Knights do uh two more
games that's it one and a half that's
all we need so he's playing the match
even two results yeah as you said
they're up seven to five a half a point
would get them to seven and a half but
let's bring up the head-to-head match up
here and just compare these two absolute
Superstars 35 to 30 as far as the age
goes feed a ranking I knew I caught
myself earlier for a reason Bobby has
been higher rated than Hikaru uh for the
last several years but not so much in
the last year when Hikaru is just
absolute dominance has kind of shocked
the world but maybe maybe uh maybe it
shouldn't have he almost won the
candidates he's number five now over
over Fabi who's number six and look at
their rapid scores there with the Hikaru
leading
yeah it's actually uh believe it or not
I mean uh Hikaru is working honestly
harder than really everybody I mean he
streams and plays chess all day long
right so yes on title Tuesday he streams
the entire event eight hours of
streaming and playing high level chess
and winning the title Tuesdays right
she's playing thousands of games like so
much right so if you're not getting the
same practice right it's going to be
difficult of course but Bobby is now
getting that practice he is playing a
lot more and it was all he almost beat
him in the Champions chess tour the CCT
has just passed so yeah Bobby's been
working on it no Fabi has has really
come into his own as far as you know
competing in in the online events it
wasn't something he did as well as
Hikaru uh for a while but now we've got
this matchup and of course we have the
overall matchup between the knights and
the Bishops let's look at where we sit
it is seven to five in favor of the
knights and uh
where do we go from here right I mean
the knights the nights are close they
only need one and a half they could even
lose this last set of four games two and
a half one and a half so the Bishops
Bishops are in must win territory here
candy absolutely must win territory here
and it's I mean you have to take some
risk you have to say anything I don't
even know if it's at the top boards
where are we going to try to get these
points right it's very tough uh and even
like I mean with the white piece like
your car having white like you can steer
it to something very boring right and
probably may have to take some risks
which may result in a loss there so you
have to play a strategic two as well
five to seven I mean it is very close
but it also is very far away at the same
time so it is difficult
you asked the question where are they
going to get the points so let's take a
look at the matchups because I it's so
hard to expect carwana to play for a win
as black but if he doesn't that means
where are they getting blocked with
black against federal sales theodoro and
Alice Lee have got to win so I'll just
start right there with white on those
bottom two boards The Comeback actually
needs to be led from the bottom in terms
of this last round Canty and then two
draws at the top which make it eight
eight and then we will have ourselves a
playoff or Armageddon there which would
be very nice to see of course she had
more chess for us we always want to see
that stuff so it's going to be amazing
to see us we have games about to kick
off guys who do you got nights or
vicious Shadow The Bishop's gonna take
it or are the knights going to finish
this out and hop around like they always
do in our games and be tricky nights and
take our pieces and be annoying so
what's gonna happen Chad E4 I sell fobby
doing the neck roll I figured we were
all taking a big stretch before the last
round there especially after my my Gap
where I'm gonna need therapy given how
much I publicly embarrassed myself
thinking Bobby lost that last game I
said Bobby needs therapy I need therapy
I just lost I lost track of what was
going on there and you know hey but you
know what content is King College
Danny Danny made me second guess reality
hey man I'm second guessing a lot more
than that in my life these days if you
want to talk real okay oh my reality is
like just at the at the at the start of
the list of what I'm questioning
um we got we got Danny's backs out you
know what that's goddamn the man A6 and
E4 look look at this I like the opening
to start as far as avoiding a quick draw
right there's flexibility in this
rosalimo Sicilian which is Bishop to B5
check rather than some of the open
Sicilian forcing lines so
I again who knows these guys all have
four straw lines in their back pocket
can't eat the bust out but I already get
the feeling this is not going to be an
easy one which makes the fans super
excited which is exactly why Fabi went
for Cecilia and I do like the fact that
Cara went to with the bishop B5 check
stuff number one this is the most
annoying Sicilian ever if you're a
sicilian player you want to see every
Sicilian except C3 and Bishop B5 these
are the ones that are super annoying uh
and so you know when Bishop B5 check
happens I mean it can steer to really
complicated positions but also white you
know got the bind in the center here I
mean black definitely has some counter
play this is what you want you want a
game actually black
I agree with you as far as how
irritating those Sicilians are but if
you're in Bobby's chair right now you
are much happier to have this position
on the board than any other sort of
forced you know variation right because
you you need to win even with the black
pieces your team needs you to get a dub
against your car where the Bishops
Bishops are probably going home so and
this is yeah you have to love the
tension that's right it's also one game
too as well there's also one game and
like you know we've seen in the
championship tour where Fabi has beaten
ikaru so I mean it was in there they
actually played twice two different
matches where your car was just able to
actually win there um in both matches
but there were some games that probably
had it was just decisive wins especially
actually it was a sicilian game where uh
um played Queen takes B7 it was a
disgusting move and finally just
trampled them after that so it's very
possible Cecilia's give you those
chances and maybe Bobby will get some
chances in this game
yeah Sicilians give you the double-edged
play and you know at this point I'm
already liking the double-edged chances
Bobby's getting he puts a bishop on D7
simply to free the C8 Square for The
Rook which by the way
how do you deal with the threat of Rook
C8 and c4's hanging you already have to
consider moves like F4 Canty to kick the
knight from E5 but if you do that Knight
to G4 and now you got dark Square
problems and uh
again Hikaru will will come up with
something resourceful because that's
what he does but
but I'm already liking black chances
this is a simple move Rook to ca coming
okay we played Bishop G5
[Music]
yeah I'm slipping exactly I'll slip just
don't do that guys so Rook C8 is very
annoying you see this in like morocci
buying setups what this is weirdly
enough the bishop is misplaced like the
bishop needs to be locked exactly and
the Queen on D2 and you play Pawn B3 but
because this is here yep he definitely
put himself in a strange situation where
this is a maroxy vine where the bishop
is just the worst piece on the board I
mean it's already worse anyway on E2 but
it's better on E2 than it is on B3 if
Rook C1 I mean we might have to like
Rook C1 and oh you can't even move the
Knight E4 is hanging yeah it definitely
is something he's definitely in some in
some hot water here this is where foxy
wants to be Bobby's feeling good Rick C1
all right Rick C8 and then one I don't
know we're C8 play quickly here we are
what the one thing Hikaru is going from
here is it's hard to take that C4 Pawn
because it can get explosive based on
the pin on the C file there so we'll
come back we'll come back to that C4
Dynamite pun in just a minute in it but
before we do let's uh let's check out
the bird's eye view every one of these
games counts toward the total score just
as much as the super heavyweight battle
Nakamura carwana uh which game to go to
next you've got Federal delivery
you've got theodoro vaquidov and you've
got Alice Lee against normanova candy
yes give us a quick thought on these
these positions that's good that's a
good one let me actually see let's let's
go around the horn here Benjamin Bach
and Vlad there it's like a maroxy vine
on three positions that's insane three
positions have the E4 seriously set up
like that's insane there so really the
only game that is not the same as these
other ones is the theodoro gamers so get
off here where that seems pretty level
that looks like some type of Sicilian as
well no there's a bishop on G2 maybe it
was a system strange still wild correct
that's probably where most of the action
will be right now is in that game with
Nicholas theodoro and vokita off the
plans and the other three games are
quite simple as well with uh E4 and C4
pawns and Etc so maybe we'll go over
there it's fine let me do uh
yeah yeah let's uh you're saying
Theodore overkidov absolutely
it's the only game that's different than
the other structures it's like they're
the only guys that uh that miss the memo
right we were supposed to play maroxy
buying on all four Awards in the last
round but theodoro and uh and vaquita
didn't get that memo oh yeah here's
their game but uh we'll we'll we'll come
back right to that 985 has now been
played after that D5 Pawn push and uh
I like White's chances so that's good
news for the Bishops who need that
comeback I like that pawn Center for
white it's a little bit of space
but I think theodoro knows how to use it
yeah I think it's very good I mean he
has a rookie one right his possibilities
the dark squares may be a little weak on
the queen side for black I don't really
want to trade because the Knight exactly
I was actually this is my first move
because I mean I don't want to trade
this Knight it also hits E4 your queen
gets off the back rank I was definitely
a fan of Knight D2 yes is it block no or
whatever but I mean B4 I hit the Knight
I can play Rook B1 afterwards if Finch
had on my Bishop as well like this is
fine this is nice I did like this Knight
D2 Retreat it restricts your knight as
well B4 is on top
it's interesting yeah because it's not
very every day you want to retreat
pieces like that maybe rookie one was
another option because now now White NOW
white is is wishing you could put a
knight on D4 how are you developing that
Bishop on C1 when you got that G7 ninja
of a bishop lurking In the Shadows on
that long diagonal over there so I'm
sitting here like the kid off who likes
to play in the shadows apparently again
you were born in the darkness I was born
of the darkness Every Time I Think of
the Shadows I think of Bane and shout
out to Tom Hardy right I mean that is a
guy that I'd like to spend some time
with Tom Hardy
all right we uh he's a great actor he's
always great roles you know Tom Hardy
okay here we go Queen to B6 and I I'm
having trouble figuring out how white
undoes the queen side bind I think Rigby
wine is a good start you just got rugby
one and try to play B4 but Rook B1 is
Queen B4 interesting he's gonna put a
piece there and say you can't play B4
wow that is actually really annoying so
no I was feeling your 92 at first and
the more I think about it though man the
more I'm like uh I don't know man here I
think you called Queen before I don't
think vaquito is gonna have to be asked
twice I love that move
and
the bind on the queen side is a is a
little tricky that is quite annoying by
the way
I know we've been talking about the uh
the the you know you talk about it Carl
Nakamura leaving the knights talking
about the big fish but this guy here the
kid off right he's the one who got the
dub over caruana this guy has been the
unsung hero for the Gotham Knights today
in many ways and if they do continue to
dance here in the protest League
playoffs look no further than that guy
right there even if you have a hard time
seeing him in the darkness oh very
strong he already seen him in the
darkness yeah but he also uh he was uh
you know with the strong Uzbekistan team
right over there with norderbeck I mean
These Guys these kids are really really
strong so absolutely I'm going to see
him play some strong moves here as we
saw Queen before he plays Bishop G4 to
provoke and F3 makes the dark squares a
little bit more weaker I can always play
Queen B6 we check and you know it just
provokes a weakness and or these these
pieces are squat are fighting over the
F3 Square so it's a very nice middle
Queen C2 you get hit with a rook C8 so I
mean what a move Bishop G4 was nice you
see this a lot in these King's Indian
type positions F3 and maybe yeah 57
Knight D3 Queen D6 Bishop
I was gonna say Nicholas Theodora agrees
with you so much he's willing to part
ways with that light Square bishop and
that that definitely improves black
chances I want to play Knight D7 before
thinking too hard on it and just open up
that Bishop on G7 prepare to put a
knight on E5 although by the way is A4
hanging or you just happy to see me you
know what a little bit of both in fact
but A4 actually is I shouldn't even had
ads I know you're happy to see me
that A4 Pawn
that's a free Pawn bro that boy is free
that is free and that's for me it's free
is for me A4 definitely is a pawn buddy
um I don't see a follow-up I mean look
at the pieces on the back rank so if you
say oh I got compensation where with
what for what are you talking about
right you don't have any conversation
you know A4 whoa is a thing you put
Knight C4 though it's an interesting
move right off the rim yeah so but it's
still good because if the trade on C4
happens then E4 is also hanging all
right but kid off he's playing like a
monster candy but we're gonna back up
and take a look at the other games
because another person has been playing
like a monster in her young career and
that's Alice Lee and today is no
different she's already got an edge
against alua normanova uh this Pawn C5
move making me happy about white space
advantage over there in that board for
battle I'd love to love to check that
thing out a little bit closer C5 also
make sure those doubled C pawns are
stuck can'ty look at that move wow C5
and after d takes C5 you get Triple
pawns the trips the triple prize the
trips the trips is that what they called
you in high school James candy the trips
James can't see the trips I mean the
third I mean trips yeah trips James
candy the trips I just made up that
nickname I think from now on we shall
call you henceforth with the trips
James can't see the trips yeah I like
that first shot of course you like that
well I say we should head into the Alice
Lee game uh versus Norma Nova and take a
take a look because look if Alice Lee
gets the dub there
don't count out the Bishops just yet
and uh I'm liking her I'm liking the
pressure that she has
okay you're looking for her game here
I'm not able to uh to see it in fact we
have three games and we're we're working
on that we will get it on the back end
here look at that coming up in a second
well we can keep looking at the mini
Boardwalk while we're getting that
figured out because you see she takes on
D6 un doubling the C pawns but opening
up the b square B6 squared as you look
at that fans the Knight comes to A4
that's a fork town right that's a
forking problem black has a lot of
forking stuff to figure out right how
many times can I dance on the line
Knight B6 of this
of this uh of the forking pressure that
white has on the Queen's side yeah
that's that's looking nice I mean it
would definitely uh Advantage for Alice
Lee as you can see weakness on D6 B6 C6
everything six has uh some weaknesses
there a62 as well it's just not looking
the greatest to say the least but
honestly it's trying to close that one
out and put the Bishops on the board
they got to do it they got us to get
some dubs I said to start if the board
at the bottom boards don't lead which
unfortunately doesn't look like it's
happening you look at the game to the
left or as we just left it the E4 Pawn
Falls the kid off is just uh
just rolling dude takes down Fabiano
caruana NBD better with black against
Nicholas theodoro maybe we should just
head back over there honestly yeah okay
we've already got the uh the board
pulled up and you've got theodoro oh
just bro on the ropes right now this
might be the
dude this is the match if if vaquita can
get the dub against uh against theodoro
yeah this is ugly for for for white here
three four five three six I'm down a
pawn it's not terrible okay it's bad but
it's not terrible like D6 is weak it's a
weak on
I have some chances I mean one Pawn
doesn't say the game but it is hard to
win this let's say the least you know
black is definitely playing for two
results unless there's some type of
blunder somewhere look at this menacing
Bishop a lot of times I started
realizing a lot of times in this reverse
these are like almost reverse catalans
where like the bishop is extremely
strong and you have to be very careful
like you would see in the catalans with
the bishop on G2 so black definitely is
for Choice up to pawn as well good game
okay
yeah the one the one uh tough thing for
black is despite the extra Pawn it's a
D6 Pawn that has a long way to go before
it can inflict any real damage on
White's position that's why the evil bar
is close to equal there because despite
the extra peshka yeah look at that
Bishop before theodoro feeling better
unfortunately for him the Bishops are so
down that he really needed to come in
here and get the win but at least he's
not losing has got to be his mindset
right now exactly at least he's not
losing right you know you want to play
as much as you can and just right it may
not go your way but you just play a
great game here don't worry about the
emotions don't worry about anything else
just play the game hopefully you you
could uh reward it for
well speaking of playing great games we
uh we now have someone joining us who's
played a few of those in his career oh
really and lucky for us we still got all
four battles all four battles remaining
Magnus Carlson enters the arena Magnus
thanks for being here man how you doing
well thank you
what's up Magnus we've got
we've got all four games going man we'd
love to get your uh your quick thoughts
and let you drive let's head to the
bird's eye view and as we take a look at
this the the knights are up by two games
headed into this last round man your
thoughts on on The Bishop's chance to
make a comeback based on based on the
positions you're seeing on the board
so I've been like on the broadcast here
waiting for a couple minutes and I I
think that the Bishop's chances have
improved quite immensely
as you're just during those two minutes
so I think Lee is absolutely winning uh
Bach is probably a bit better
um
Bob is slightly better
and Theodore I think was completely lost
and is now I I would say favor to to
make a draw in this one so I think it's
it's far from from over
okay well that's awesome exciting uh
let's let's maybe go back to the uh to
the top game between Nakamura and car
one I want to get your thoughts on that
position obviously you've uh you've
played those guys a few times in your
career your thoughts on two things one
the current position but also
hikaru's rosalimo against the Sicilian
in the in a position there like what
would you do in that scenario you play
in the Pro chess League you know your
team's leading was the rosalimo a good
choice to give Fabi some flexibility out
of the opening or would you have done
something different
yeah I think Russell limo generally
suits both players uh I mean first of
all it's
uh
uh it's an objectively good opening
where black generally struggles quite a
bit to to equalize so I think in that
sense Hikaru is happy to play it and uh
there are also lines that can be pretty
double-edged if you're if you're well
prepared so I think it suits it suits
both
um I don't love the last few moves for
Fabi though
um I think he's participated on some
pretty awkward squares so now uh I don't
see him winning this one
okay Knight to G6 when you say the
pieces on Awkward squares there's no
real way to kind of go after that weak B
Pawn right so Hikaru is Hikaru is
holding on and
what would be what would be your give us
some quick analysis in the brain of
Magnus Carlson here
yeah so the normal move here which would
be to play 95 I think
uh but probably that's not gonna you
know suit the match iteration so he has
to do something uh yeah so something
else uh generally black which
like to to trade off the
uh the darks were Bishops at the very
least
um
so I could see you I could actually see
Bishop B4 Happening Here
uh unless that runs into night
uh unless yeah
yeah and then now now Bishop D4 could be
met by E5
okay uh uh so I'm not sure like I'm not
sure that
because last couple of moves have been
particularly accurate well 95
uh I don't like it uh so much now it
doesn't come with Tempo and I think
white would be quite happy to trade off
a pair of Rooks with rookie A8
um and and the trade of
the trade of uh Knights doesn't
particularly help black uh he really
needs to tread the Bishops
if we're looking into the future here
Magnus and let's say candy let's say the
knights come off Knight takes E5 Bishop
B5 and and Rook A8 is played
or or Bishop E5 first what what are the
chances of winning this end game Magnus
for for black
given the weak Pawns
I think like the last few months have
improved his chances immensely
so okay here why it doesn't have a
does have a clear way if it goes King at
three then Rook B5 and his Rook is
either gonna have to give up the pun
um
and really this
with the isolated e-pawns that's one of
the more difficult for against trees to
uh to hold and if he just passively
hangs on to the to the pawn then that's
not so easy so I think hikar has done it
in a much better way he's traded off the
Rooks uh he's traded with both pairs of
works and now he's not even remotely
worse
big one
crazy yeah yeah the the you know the
importance of his outside past one has
increased quite a bit with these uh with
the exchanges of uh of Brooks
so it's just a draw here right man
yeah
um frankly I think
we're pretty close to entering
two results uh two results area here but
where fob is not on the right side so
um all right well yeah this is if that's
the case let's let's back up to the
bird's eye view then and head over
because it'll mean that other players
have got to get the job done for the
Bishops as as we said coming in a two
and a half one and a half win in this
round is actually not even enough they
need more than that they need three one
um why don't we head over and see the
final moments if Alice Lee is about to
take down normanova Magnus I'd love to
guess your thoughts on Alice Lee real
quick as a player she's impressed so
many people she Drew her car to start
the day when you look at a rising star
like that what do you what do you uh
what do you see when you look at Alice
Lee and her Talent
um yeah I think
like from the games I saw of her and uh
uh the U.S Women's Championship I mean
frankly I haven't seen other games so I
don't know but uh she seemed
um
really really sharp tactically uh
and obviously like other areas have to
have to improve over time but she seems
to have a lot of
a lot of promise
yeah we got the bird's eye view look at
it we see she's got the queen for the
rook and Knight Dynamic I guess that one
is actually kind of simple right not not
too many chances remain for numer Nova
there so St Louis should get one dub
yeah and now uh
got in a big shot with uh Bishop page
for Mr H4 which is kind of sloppy to to
allow because Theodora had made a lot of
a lot of progress like
obviously the position was still not
better for him but
um only he was improving his his
position and now he either has to play
on two pawns down which is
uh uh a pretty pretty hopeless Prospect
or he has to take the draw with GH4 and
um the petrol check
so yeah maybe we should head over there
then that looks crazy the uh the
theodoro game what do you think you
wanna you wanna check out that one now
also probably has to has to repeat
otherwise he's
anymore so
look looking pretty pretty hopeless
right now
position
yeah it was a draw
final position we should probably head
back to one of the other games still in
progress
why don't we why don't we head over to
Federal save Bach we said Bach has some
chances and there's real time pressure
we see red on the clock
let's get magnus's thoughts on that one
we're about to hit a scramble
yeah it's really hard for me to say a
lot about this position in a few seconds
because it's so complicated but it seems
intuitively
it's gotten some
some counter play but maybe now the idea
maybe is
a black maybe it was better to go Brook
Cafe to keep some more control and than
if Bishop E6
um it was a little trap Bishop E6
probably King J2 would have been
it would have been winning but um yeah
no yeah D5 is hanging it's really
it's really complicated so oh this is a
nice trap room for the save he's hoping
for Bishop D5 excitement before
foreign
strange things are probably going to
happen
foreign
Knight F6
yeah that was cringy three back after
night
this is
this by the way oh obviously wins her
game that's a draw
Alice Lee wins her game by the way guys
and the theodoro game Drew so this is
for everything box has to win and he's
unable to do it
and the Knights eliminate the Bishops
just like that
wow silver nice versus vicious it's been
answered
yeah it was right one point
yeah I think I've had a real real chance
but
nah Bishop H7 was a really nice shot
from feather save with so little time
that's yeah
Bishop H7 Perpetual check draw very nice
yeah as Magnus said and there was no way
out
also Queen H5 would have been like an
even funnier way to to make a draw with
the idea of Bishop G8 and then Bishop H7
very very fun
okay well let's let's quickly pay off
the result so we see we're going to keep
Magnus here and recap real quick this
match while we have him but there it is
everybody the Gotham Knights do indeed
get the job done they send home the
Bishops the existential question which
piece is better Knights versus Bishops
has been answered the Gotham Knights
remain alive in the protest League
playoffs they move on to the semi-finals
what a big day for baked off there board
three look at that three out of four
score look no further than that guy as
far as why the knights got the job done
and uh well Magnus let's get your
thoughts on it you said you tuned in you
saw you saw a couple minutes there of
that big round uh your thoughts overall
on uh what you thought coming into this
match did you sing did you see the
knights as maybe being the slight
favorite or are you surprised by this
result
the other side no idea who was playing
so as far as it's hard for hard for me
to say like
but like not having seen the games like
the most surprising thing for me is the
result of the word ones
um like generally like scoring plus one
or fifty percent as for one should do
more chances but in this case it seemed
seemed to have been like very even
nobody scored less than than one point
and
yeah it seems like you know anything
anything could happen but I I saw in the
preliminaries that Gotham Knights are
very very strong so
um
they're they're probably going to be
hard to beat
okay well your team coming in Magnus
while we have you because we may not
have any more thoughts on the 2023 PCL
by you might as well ask how did you
feel about the chess bra season this
year right obviously it didn't end the
way you guys wanted but did you have a
good time and your thoughts overall on
competing for Canada and maybe what
could have gone better for you guys
yeah it was a bit frustrating
um I thought you know my play overall
was was uh was okay
um
I I don't think like I particularly
influenced the results at all in any of
our any of our losses so even when when
I messed up it didn't really didn't
really matter
um I like the formats a lot since it
means that
basically every match is going to be
um is going to be pretty close at least
on on paper so I think that's
you know that's that's very good and for
the future as well
um I'd love to to try to try again
um you know obviously
failing to qualify for the The Knockouts
is
um
is uh to paraphrase uh Giannis that is a
failure but uh nevertheless
um nevertheless it was uh was a fun
experience so I hope to be hope to relax
all right um I have a question a future
chat question for you Magnus I see what
are some similarities similarities that
you find between poker and chess
um I I think like
wasn't great sugar said that
poker tournaments it's like hours of
program followed by
uh seconds of Agony or something
um
chess is fun so that's the difference
similar to say is it the opposite for
chess hours for seconds of Victory who
knows
um
in comparison
bringing it back to the PCL the question
was asked again from feature chat of all
the bottom boards but I'm going to kind
of ask of all the boards of people you
saw performing in the PCL who impressed
you most this year
um anybody you took note of is just kind
of turning your head and had a great
season
uh
that's a good question
um
I think
uh Prague sister by Salish it did pretty
well in a few matches like also against
also against us
um
otherwise
otherwise I don't I don't I don't know
yeah it's a great that's a great pick
great color she did she played well yep
and and for for us for the browse I
think
Russian priyota did pretty pretty well
in like a couple of matches there was a
little bit up and down
um he saved us in in one match at this
so he did uh hit it well it wasn't about
bottom board but he was support 43 I
think
yeah well we we brought it back to the
PCL before we let you go Magnus we we
gotta ask who do you have winning the
pro chess League
Let's uh let's call it out while you're
here make your predictions we're taking
a look at the bracket Tigers won today
so did the knights but who do you have
winning uh winning the full thing here
on out
well I think I got a I gotta hope for
the
the Gnomes
um that they got eliminated today
okay then then I'm gonna ask you a
better question
show me that show me the bracket again
okay let's do the bracket again I I want
to give a serious answer
based on oh okay now I see obviously the
Tigers
the uh the knights
um I think
yeah I think the yogis are very good
um
it beats us pretty comfortably as well
uh I think the knights and the yogis are
going oh we have the Wizards yeah
they're also very strong yeah I mean who
the hell knows uh
but I I'm still gonna go for the knights
and the yogis in the finals and the
Yogi's winning at all well well Yogi's
who eliminated the bronze so there you
go go with yogis I'm sorry I gotta get
one more question
yeah I got I just got to say like
picking the top two seeds so we end up
in a final extremely controversial
that's when people pay the big bucks for
that's right Magnus we speaking of big
best you quoted Giannis so I gotta ask
we've talked basketball who do you got
at this point the Celtics are they going
to come back against the Sixers who's
winning the NBA finals
I think the Denver Nuggets are winning
damn day at finals
wow nuggets
yeah all right well pains me to agree
with you but I think it's a good time
also going to be the yorkich uh revenge
tour
you know okay that's my heart you hear
you heard it here first Chad
all right Magnus thanks so much for
joining us man appreciate you
thank you
see ya bro and that was Magnus Carlson
the greatest chess player of all time
highest rated player ever had a pretty
good PCL season himself although the
bras went down to the yogis and you
heard that pit Kenny he's taking the
yogis the team that beat him to go all
the way
yeah absolutely something in that Indian
water did you know that the yogis
actually have two teams I mean the Indy
India has two teams in the playoffs MDG
one and the yogis no one I mean okay if
we have the American teams obviously but
hey whatever the Indian water is going
on whatever they doing over there we
know it we got people over 2 700 kids
teenagers right most
really important to understand that
those yogis are strong
it's it's crazy and I don't think it's a
bad pick even if he was kind of joking
and picking them because they eliminated
the bras I don't think he was I mean
that was a that was an incredible and
incredible match they had to take down
the world champion LED chess bras and
the yogis are dangerous they will be
playing tomorrow of course versus the
blitz so he uh recapping the day real
quick candy let's remind everybody of
what we saw we saw the Shanghai Tigers
move on to the semi-finals send the
Gnomes back to the garden and then we
saw the Gotham Knights answer the
existential question which do you prefer
it's Knights over Bishops boys and girls
they move on to the semi-finals as well
candy I had a great time today you oh
absolutely had a great time here of
course as we saw the Knights versus
Bishops we get to see the knights won we
chill with the chat we saw some gray
chests Alice sweet bihikaru it was a
draw but a draw is a win always when you
draw Hikaru so it was great it was also
uh you know great chess here I mean they
didn't make it vicious to make it
through but at the end of the day very
strong team and especially coming from
O2 in the start there so good to see
tonight's events it was great Justin
yeah well the and I want to give one
last shout out of course thanking the
now former world champion God that feels
weird to say because he's still the best
chess player on the planet and of all
time but Magus Carlson also thank you
for joining us that was fun to have him
there for those final moments and once
again congratulations congratulations to
the knights for taking down the Bishops
but that's all for today everybody we're
gonna see you tomorrow that is Friday
for two more quarterfinal matches if you
didn't know that the PCO playoffs
continue but for now we're going to
leave you with some of the best live
moments from the knights victory over
the Bishops Canty they make it to the
semi-finals thanks for being here and
we'll see you tomorrow everyone
see ya
oh wait a second we have an exchange
sack by Hikaru and Alice Lee Alice Lee
is in the driver's seat here Canty Alice
Lee takes a breath gotta be happy with
the Half Point against Nakamura even it
was white and up the exchange there
black is up two pieces
and only a little better
only a little better it's holding oh
minus 11.
Bishop takes it too
we get Jake
oh my gosh
GMS in the chat this is one of the
craziest games I've ever seen dude it
probably holds this draw what a what a
what a win metaphorically this one
oh my God white was winning
you can resign or A7 actually yeah that
was a sick game Alice the Winter game by
the way guys and the theodoro game Drew
so this is for everything box has to win
and he's unable to do it
and the Knights eliminate the Bishops
just like that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]